foreign
foreign
the public order emergency commission is
now in session the commissions
okay I understand we have a new panel of
witnesses for this morning
okay and who uh from commission Council
foreign
commissioner this morning we have the
first of two RCMP panels
commissioner lucky and Deputy
Commissioner dwem and I would ask if
they could come to the panel and while
they are getting themselves seated I'll
just make a preliminary
comment to the parties that could you
just identify yourself for the record
please
Gordon Cameron commission Council
uh
commissioner yesterday at the close of
the proceeding a matter was raised
uh
by Mr Miller about the state of
documents on the party database and in
light of those comments commission
Council investigated the matter last
night and most of the parties will have
received and had a chance to review
commission council's email to them
explaining
what we've been able to learn about that
situation and so I won't elaborate on
that except to say that two things we
did recognize that there had been a
glitch with respect to the uploading of
documents and that was corrected over
the weekend it was unfortunate but the
matter is in hand and the party database
is in good form
and the other thing we'd like to assure
parties Mr commissioner is that
commission council did have access to
all of the documents uh and indeed
parties will notice that
the documents including those that just
went up uh
on the party database over the weekend
some of which are included in our list
of documents for the examination of this
panel and so we're prepared to proceed
confident that we have had a thorough
review of the documents in advance of
this panel appearing okay thank you for
that update
and it's appreciated and again I'd
simply reiterate if there are issues
please raise them with commission
Council as soon as they're
noted so that we can address them and
resolve them if there's something to be
done
so with that uh
if I could proceed with the panel the
panel be sworn
Deputy Commissioner Durham will you
swear on a religious document or do you
wish to affirm
we have available the Bible the Quran or
the Torah
foreign
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
full name is Michael Robert duhane do
him is about d-u-h-e-m-e
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God yes I do
thank you
commissioner lucky
will you swear on a religious document
or do you wish to affirm
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Brenda Marie lucky
l-u-c-k-i
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission should
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God
I swear thank you
foreign
commissioner Deputy Commissioner morning
morning to you again and I'll begin by
reminding you that uh you met with
commission Council uh back on September
7th and with you were a number of your
colleagues and you were interviewed and
a summary of that interview was prepared
that has since been put on the party
database and been made available to the
parties for the record it's WTS
six zeros 69
and so I'll ask you some questions about
the adoption of that summary on the
record with the qualification that uh
four of the people who were in that
interview aren't here today so I'll just
ask you to confirm uh that the interview
summary is accurate to the best of your
knowledge so the way I'll put it is this
that you have reviewed each of you to
have reviewed the summary and confirmed
that in so far as it contains your
information you believe it to be true
and accurate to the best of your
knowledge and belief and that insofar as
it contains the information of your
colleagues you understand it to have
been reviewed by them for accuracy and
confirmed is accurate is that true yes
thank you
um now Deputy Commissioner duam we got
another chance to talk to you uh later
on on October 11th and there is a
separate interview a summary of that
interview for the record that is WTS
6068
and have you reviewed that summary and
confirmed that it's accurate yes I have
and it's accurate and you adopt it as
part of your evidence yes thank you
now uh
there is a a third summary and uh this
is the summary of the interview of Ms
Ducharme and Ms Vanette and for the
record that is WTS
6067 and since they're in your division
uh Deputy Commissioner drama will ask
you to confirm that that summary has
been reviewed by Ms ducharman Ms Vanette
for accuracy and that his it has been
filed with the commission as part of the
rcmp's evidence my understanding it has
been reviewed by the two individual and
it's adopted as part of the rcmp's
evidence correct thank you
now finally uh there the RCMP filed an
Institutional report that has been on
the party database for some time as
doj.ir Dot
six zeros 11.
um and
I'm
gonna
ask you to tell us what you can about a
recent clarification to the status of
that institutional report
so that we can make sure the proper
version gets adopted as your evidence
can you help us with that
yeah I can I I don't have the exact page
because I was given a copy this morning
from Council from from uh doj but it
does refer to police agencies and
jurisdiction and the
um understanding is that Council
commission Council had requested this
information and we did uh when we go
went through the validation process is
what was written in there is a standing
operating procedures that was not
enforced at that unit at the time so we
just wanted to clarify that and so the
institutional report that is about to be
or perhaps already is updated in any
event will soon be updated to the party
database we'll have that correction made
in it I am I'm assuming so yeah yes and
so if I can put it this way can you
prospectively adopt that in corrected
institutional report as the evidence of
the RCMP but based on the copy I was
given yes yes thank you and Mr
commissioner for the benefit of parties
who may be concerned about a last minute
correction I I can confirm and I think
Deputy Commissioner I'll ask you to
confirm this is a relatively minor
correction to the currency of a version
of a document cited in the IR that has
in fact been updated and that updated
version will be reflected in the as
filed version correct that's correct
thank you
uh with that with that administrivia out
of the way uh commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner I'll ask you some overview
questions just to get you to introduce
yourselves to the commissioner and to
the parties and so I'll ask by uh ask
Begin by asking you uh commissioner
lucky to just describe your role within
the RCMP and
just so that you don't need to tell us
the whole of that perhaps you could
concentrate in particular on your role
as it pertained to the Convoy and
protest events that are the subject to
this inquiry thank you um generally my
role as Commissioners to oversee the
operations and administration of the RCM
RCMP in relation to the convoys
obviously we had convoys across the
country so I was getting operational
updates in our in our jurisdiction when
it came to the specific Convoy in or the
protests in Ottawa there was a few roles
I had one was to uh I was liaising with
Chief slowly uh on a couple of occasions
uh
uh relaying resource asks that we
received if I if I was in receipt of
those uh resource house I would pass
that down through our command structure
I was also uh one of the major
responsibilities was to get the
information from across the country and
to brief the deputy Minister Community
the ministers uh there was four
ministers that we would uh that I would
brief and then halfway through the Prime
Minister called incident Response Group
where I would brief situational reports
from across the country of anything that
was happening related to the Convoy
generally speaking ahead to make sure
that in in our police of jurisdiction
that our mem that our divisions had the
resources ensuring that they had the
resources the equipment that they needed
to uh deal with those incidents
and with respect to your observation
that you were briefing uh ministers
would that have included Minister
Mendicino and Blair and
also uh presumably the National Security
intelligence advisor yes and I I believe
it also included Minister Al Gabriel the
minister of Transport as well as the
minister of government affairs minister
LeBlanc and you also participated in
regular briefings with PCO pmo uh and uh
Justice intergovernmental Affairs
briefings where those departments would
have been represented
um mostly at the deputy Minister level
we would have discussions I am not sure
who all was there but it was mostly at
the deputy Minister level the
representation of the same Ministers of
the DMS of the same ministers I
mentioned before and in particular you
participated to that point uh
commissioner like you participated in
the deputy Minister's committee on
operational
uh conditions they did the dmoc yes
um we normally have those meetings and
we sort of morphed it into uh Convoy
briefings as well and judging from the
minutes of the meetings of the SSE and
the IRG you were in attendance at those
meetings as well yes I was
and you mentioned that you liaised with
uh then Chief uh slowly and presumably
later on with deputy chief Bell
were you also in regular con contact
with the commissioner of the opp Mr
Creek yes I was thanks
and uh Deputy Commissioner duam could
you describe your role uh in the RCMP
generally and as it had particular
application to the Convoy and similar
events yep I'm responsible for federal
policing Federal policing program within
the rsmp has about 5 000 people assigned
to the program our mandate is to
investigate National Security such as
foreign actor interference terrorism
ideologically motive violent extremists
we also investigate transnational
service and organized crime
we are we are also responsible at the
border between the ports of Entry
and uh we also have a protective
policing mandate which ensures
protection to certain incoming
dignitaries for the Prime Minister chief
justice the governor general and others
that are appointed by the minister and
they also have our intelligence in
international policing that reports into
Federal policing
so my role on the Convoy from the onset
really we were looking at it through a
lens of protective policing that was our
that was our core mandate when it all
started as the resources started and
this as this grew the commissioner
appointed me to be the point person for
the organization to coordinate the
assistance that we're providing to Ops
throughout
uh I was part of the goal command
structure when it was formed my
responsibility throughout from the
beginning was ensure that the
commissioner had the right information
to brief up at the various briefings at
the DM level at the ministerial level at
the urge
and uh the coordination of resources
from across the country that needed to
be brought in I had a team looking out
for that so really the the assistance to
the Ops in support of resources
regardless of the skill set was under my
responsibility
thank you we're going to come back in a
in a few minutes to the federal policing
responsibility of the RCMP
but you mentioned an expression in there
that might come up uh later in our
discussion
uh it has been mentioned before in
various contexts I I think you might
have called it the gold uh command
structure but I I think the expression
is the gold silver bronze command
structure could you just describe how
that works uh for the RCMP uh and how in
some of the contexts it came to to bear
on the management of the Convoy yeah the
gold silver bra instruction it's well
explained in the uh in in the report but
basically the goal structure is really
providing the Strategic uh Direction uh
to manage the operation the bronze is
really the people who would look at
planning the event and then when you get
to the silver is actually people who are
actioning the plan that's been done for
me reverse gold seller bronze uh gold
silver sorry yeah silver are actually uh
um
preparing the strategy that was dictated
by the goal command and and as it
trickles down to the bronze bronze are
really the feet of the boots underground
the smbs that actually action uh the
plan okay and that command structure
there what as I understand there wasn't
just one applicable to all of the RCMP
that might be implemented in particular
jurisdictions or indeed to deal with
particular situations or incidents am I
right there that's correct
so you might for uh
for example for Coots or for a province
have a gold silver bronze structure
implemented to deal with events in those
locations correct the one in Ottawa was
specific to dealing with the one in
Ottawa thank you
thank you
now now coming to the to the uh RCMP
Federal policing mandate this is the
first just to help you answer the
question and contact stuff first of a
series of questions I have to try to
describe what the RCMP does
with all of those 5 000 uh Personnel uh
in Ottawa
compared to what it does with the
Personnel it has in the provinces where
it is Police of jurisdiction under
contract to the provincial governments
so uh with that overall picture in mind
Federal policing in Ottawa you mentioned
some of the areas it covers but with
respect to the Convoy your particular
concentration was on the rcmp's
protective policing mandate is that
correct that's correct and I just want
to correct this when I mentioned 5 000
people it's not five thousand in Ottawa
five thousand federal police employees
across the country and posted
internationally as well but not just
uniquely in Ottawa I see
I'll come back to it to a distinction
there but how many are in Ottawa roughly
speaking
um National divisions composed about 700
people and then when you add the
component national headquarters
um
probably around I'm throwing a guess
here 1200
that that'll do for these purposes now
could you expand a bit on the rcmp's
protective mandate as it's sometimes
called the uh protective services that
the RCMP officer offers in the city of
Ottawa or the national capital region
yeah the protective mandate for the RCMP
uh derives from the rsmp regulations uh
we are mandated to protect on a threat
risk assessment base of the Prime
Minister the governor general the chief
of the Supreme Court
visiting dignitaries presidents from
other countries uh that would fall it
would fall under our responsibility or
any other appointed official by the
minister of Public Safety
um we also have within that protective
we also have an Intel unit that feeds in
to prepare to better prepare our posture
and respond to to any um any uh any
incidents
um here in Ottawa we are looking at
about 400 people that are assigned full
time and when I say 400 it's all
categories employees assigned to
protective policing
and uh if you can describe it we might
come to some particulars as it relates
to specific incidents but generally
speaking what was the impact of the
arrival in Ottawa of the Convoy uh uh
what was the impact of that on the
protective Mandate of the RCMP
uh
well one of the things and I forgot to
mention the people that were protected
is also elected officials
um that fall under responsibility so it
was bringing
a coordination and ensuring the secure
transport of the elected official uh to
Parliament on on the Monday uh the
Monday 31st I believe was the 31st uh to
it uh coordinating routes to get into
the area there was also concerns with
demos that would creep up at Dorito hall
or at the prime minister's residence
which required us to mobilize additional
resources to make sure that we had the
right posture to address
uh any incidents that would occur uh
during uh the arrival of the Convoy
while they were there
okay well that's a helpful example so if
if you expected to encounter protest
activity uh
as part of escorting and ensuring the
safety of the Prime Minister or one of
the other people for whom you're
responsible and you encounter this
protest activity sort of if I can put it
this way in the way of your uh
that the path that you expected to take
your protective policing mandate would
that include dealing with those
protesters on a public order management
basis
or would it deal with getting your
protectees where they need to go uh
safely and in this instance
um
our pou's were not dispatched to clear
the roads or to assist in any ways we
were working with Ottawa Police Service
to ensure what were the egress and
Ingress uh with regards to Parliament
Hill without obviously with the dynamic
and the fluidity of what was going on
downtown a lot of the routes could not
be guaranteed so that's something that
we had to factor in and had to shift our
plans as we went forward
okay again at the risk of belaboring the
point I just want to make sure I
understand correctly the impact on your
protective policing mandate wasn't that
you had a public order mission to clear
the roots it was just that your mandate
was more complicated because you had to
coordinate with the Ops and make sure
your roots were safe coordinate but also
with the elevated uh the intelligence
that we had the increased resource that
were required to ensure the protection
of the different sites that we that we
are responsible for thank you
foreign
police work I'll put it this way because
I'm not sure how it would fall into
these mandates certainly your your
federal mandate was to to collect
intelligence as the Convoy was
approaching
uh now
we're not going to spend a lot of time
on that and commissioner this is the
point where I would uh footnote so to
speak the witness summary that I
referenced at the very beginning because
commission council did do an interview
and filed at the interview summary of Ms
Ducharme and Ms vignette specifically on
this point of the rcmp's collection of
intelligence in relation to the uh
Convoy so
we'll just ask this panel a few a few
questions about this
um
you did have intelligence uh at an
intelligence team analyzing the
information available as the Convoy was
approaching correct yes we didn't uh
can you just give a quick overview of
who of who those people were yeah
there's there's several structures in
place when it came to Intel within the
organization so
we had ideologically motivated criminal
intelligence team that we're looking at
it more from a national scope as to what
was going on and providing strategic
threat advisory bulletins I think
there's eight in total that went out
throughout the uh
throughout the legal protests and we
also had our protective intelligence
unit that was really Gathering
intelligence to help us with our
protective posture but it doesn't
neglect the fact that the information
gathered and in under the piu unit would
be shared with other agencies and
eventually early on I think it was on
the 28th or the 29th pardon me we did
create what we can what is known as a
combined intelligence group that would
bring together people from different law
enforcement organizations within the
Ottawa area such as you'd have Ops OPP
suptets Quebec uh the service of
possibility gets new that would be
present and that's meant to bring to HUB
together so everybody can share the
information that they have because it's
not just the rsmp working on a block of
information every organization is
working on the information and it's
coordinating through that combined
intelligence group
as as as this grew and there's more and
more increased resources being being
brought in
we stood up at the national headquarters
we stood up another combined group
really to coordinate the Intel from a
national perspective so that we could
prepare the commissioner with a picture
of what's going on across the country
I'll factor that into you've heard the
Hendon report several times that was a
report from the opp that was also used
to to help the Sig the combined
intelligence group uh in the in the
analysis of all the Intel that's coming
in so there's uh there's several players
involved when you look at a combined
intelligence uh unit or group
and uh where was the combined
intelligence group working
um I believe is all the ncrcc's national
capital region Command Center that was
located it's located in Orleans
which is located in Orleans thank you
now uh
commissioner lucky this is probably uh
something uh that's best directed to you
because what I'd like to do now is ask
you to describe quite a
different role that the RCMP performs in
the provinces other than Ontario Quebec
uh and and perhaps Newfoundland but it
the the the
role of police of jurisdiction in the
provinces and some of the municipalities
of those provinces can you give us an
overview of that yeah this falls under
our contract in indigenous policing
business line and it is the policing
that we do in all provinces and
territories except Ontario and Quebec it
represents about 70 percent of our
Workforce and their contracts with uh
provinces municipalities and some
indigenous communities the contracts are
held by Public Safety Canada and we
provide the policing service under those
contracts in those provinces we don't do
policing in the entire province why I
say that is usually in big
municipalities for example in Alberta
you have your Calgary Municipal Police
you have your Edmonton Municipal Police
and then generally speaking the RCMP
there's a few smaller ones like
Lethbridge but generally speaking we
police the rest of the province except
for some of the bigger municipalities
who have their own
um uh independent police agency
let me ask if I can ask if you can draw
a a comparison for those of us who are
more familiar with the policing
situation in Ontario and Quebec where we
have a Provincial Police Force which is
sometimes also the Municipal Police
Force but sometimes the cities have
their own police forces do I understand
correctly that in the provinces other
than Ontario and Quebec that would be
the RCMP you would be the provincial
police force and in some cases the
police force off the municipalities that
don't have their own police force yes
very similar to what the opp or sort of
taking back are right so
functionally speaking
again this sounds Ontario and Quebec
Centric but the RCMP is the opp or the
data Quebec in all of the provinces
except Ontario and Quebec yes and that
is arranged by a contract with each of
the provinces correct
um no not necessarily we have 194
contracts 169 contracts some in the case
of BC for example the province has the
contract and they sort of subcontract
but in places like Alberta they have a
provincial contract and then they have
Municipal contracts any municipality
over a certain population will go into a
municipal contract and it changes the
funding formula as well as there are
certain indigenous communities where
there's
um uh in a different funding formula
now
uh when when you two have left the stand
we're going to have Deputy Commissioner
zablocki here to describe the situation
in Alberta in particular
uh but I just before he gets up uh to
describe that situation perhaps uh
commissioner lucky you could describe
the way in which the contracts you have
with the provinces either
single contract or multiple as you just
described allow you to move resources
within a province to areas where they
are needed or between provinces when
there are higher demands in one Province
than another yeah this is the the beauty
of our model in the sense that under the
provincial policing service agreements
that we have we can move resources
there's it's called an article nine so
in the case of Alberta commanding
officer is a block he can move resources
from within Alberta as he wishes just
advising The Province uh of of that if
we're doing any big movements of
resources and then again under different
subsection of article 9 we can request
up to 10 percent of resources in any
other Province and so what we do is we
normally if it's urgent matter we move
the resources and then ask for
permission later because we'll never
compromise the safety of Canadians but
generally speaking when we know big
events are coming on we will prepare
those letters in advance the letters go
from uh myself to the minister minister
to the applicable uh police policing
jurisdictions and it's always based on a
cost recovery
right
which is to say if if one Province
borrows a bunch of your officers from
another there's a financial arrangement
to compensate for that yes and that's
exactly what ended up happening in
Alberta during these convoys we do also
have access to Federal resources like uh
Deputy Commissioner duhamem was saying
across the country those don't fall
under those agreements they're Federal
resources right
now let me ask you are there advantages
from an operational point of view
if you are bringing in officers from say
British Columbia to Alberta or from
Northern Alberta down to Southern
Alberta Etc
uh in in having officers with the same
equipment and the same training and the
same command structure and whatnot does
that offer you an advantage that you
might not have been able to achieve for
example when you were coming into assist
in Ontario absolutely because we have
the same more or less training standards
and service standards across the RCMP
and that flexibility allows for
especially in extended events where
you'll have multiple you have to provide
relief and you can't sustain things like
the forest fire in Fort McMurray The
Manhunt and
um in Manitoba you you can bring those
resources in seamlessly because they
have the same level of training and the
and the same equipment
thank you now moving a bit closer to
home uh at least in so far as it
pertains to the events in Ottawa I would
like to ask and these are probably
questions for you Deputy Commissioner
but uh uh not necessarily so please feel
free commissioner knock you if you if
you uh are the better person to answer
to talk about the role of the RCMP and
Ottawa we've heard about their uh
Federal uh policing role and their
Protective Services mandate but I'd like
to take you back a bit in history and
ask you if you can uh well let's start
way back so to speak has the RCMP at
least in our living memory ever been the
city police the police of jurisdiction
in Ottawa
uh not as far as I can recall
uh but there there was a time uh that
you've outlined in your in your uh
summary your witness uh interview
summary when there was a more
substantial uh contingent of uh what you
might call uniformed uh officers on the
ground in Ottawa can you explain when
that was and what the purpose of of
those forces were yeah and that's
correct that the RCMP did have a larger
footprint in the Ottawa region
uh in the year 2000s leading up to 2014
after the um the attacks on Parliament
Hill uh there was a review that was done
and I should just say that prior to that
the organization here some people was
responsible for the security of
parliament Hills outside component of
House of Commons and Senate not the
interior the interior was managed by
House of Commons had their own security
senate had their own and the RCMP
responsible for the outside grounds at
that time also that we had more
resources when it came to our protective
policing mandate we had more clients to
protect at the time and then over years
there's a a different approach on the
way we did business that reduced our
actually our footprint when it came to
protective policing as well as patrols
at the embassies back to the back to the
uh our responsibility on the hill we had
in excess of 120 people there that were
assigned to the hill uh on the permanent
basis to ensure the security when
um
when uh when the attacks occurred there
was a review done of the entire security
posture on the hill and that's when a
new legislation was created to create
the problem or through Protective
Service
who the RCMP was responsible leading the
integration of security of the different
uh units that were there
um
what we saw after a year and a half been
uh there it was decided to put a plan
for that realizing that the job that's
being performed on Parliament Hill was
not a policing function but more
security function there's a transition
that was done with PPS with the with the
with the accor of the both speakers to
reduce the footprint of the rsmp
currently legislatively the only
position that requires an RCMP member is
a position of director so when you talk
about shift in resources in footprint
there's a significant one that happened
recently protective policing when it
came to our clients happened before that
so if if I may when you look at the
Dynamics prior to this change the rsmp
when it was responsible for the hill
looked after all the planning of the
different events that took place on the
hill this was prior to the creation of
PBS
and we would work jointly with Ottawa
Police Service be in a demo that's going
through the streets of Ottawa and would
land on Parliament Hill then it becomes
its shifted over from Ops to us and we
work jointly on that and regards with
the plans the preparation to respond to
any of uh demos that are going on Hill
when PPS came into to to to effect I was
the first director and
um what we're looking at is the PPS
becomes distinct and and basically not
separate from the RCMP because the RCMP
still had a role to play but must be
distinct so the planning was now done
from PPS since 2015 every event that was
on the hill was being done from PBS and
not necessarily rsmp we assist at the
beginning but now they're completely
autonomous when when they're planning
for events on the hill
and in your uh witness summary uh some
of the questions that commission Council
asked uh had you explaining that uh
this perception that the RCMP and the
Ops should be working jointly to manage
uh large events in Ottawa hasn't
entirely dissipated from the minds of
the people at Ottawa and the Ops can you
just give us a description of that
situation as you see it now so so we
still work jointly with with uh with the
Ops I I can give you an example of any
event that would occur on Parliament
Hill PPS would have the lead for
planning the event on the hill but you
would also have Ops would be responsible
for whatever's in the street and we'd be
involved from a protective lens as to
what's going on will there be any road
closures will it be what's the impact on
ours on our mandate but it'd still be a
lead role from PPS but organizations
will come together
and and would that also be true for
other events perhaps elsewhere in Ottawa
where you're protective policing mandate
uh would be affected right we talked
about how it in a convoy you needed to
move people around the city elected
officials and whatnot uh but would that
also be true if there were some other
event independent of the Convoy today
that you would that your protective
services people would liaise with the
Ottawa city police definitely any any
significant event in in
Ottawa I mentioned earlier the national
capital region Command Center that's a
coordination Hub where we have various
Partners at the table to understand the
Dynamics that are going on on a daily
basis or even hourly and and then
sometimes yeah it allows us it allows
emergency Personnel such as fire
departments paramedics to adjust their
response according to the intelligence
that comes into this Hub but on a
day-to-day basis yes there's liaison
going on with Ops with the Auto police
service but it's it's more it's more um
there's liaison going on but less of it
Reliance to rely on Ops on a daily basis
but it's only when events are in the
area that's when we come together in
crcc and make sure that everybody's
informed so that we can properly plan
everyone can properly plan
okay now moving to the period uh
immediately prior to the Convoy
um
what did you and you expect and I'm
saying you Deputy Commissioner but but
perhaps commissioner lucky you also had
a view on this but what did you expect
this event to be
well as I mentioned earlier
I was looking at it purely from the lens
of our mandate when it comes to
protective policing how is this going to
impact the people uh that were mandated
to protect
uh does PPS need any assistance as this
move forward so it's really through a
lens of not a demo but really how is it
going to impact us on our service
delivery when it comes to protective
um early discussions I had with Ops on
the matter there seems to be no concerns
whatsoever good relationships with the
organizer organizers and there's no
um there's no need for us to question uh
the relationship they had with them and
we felt comfortable well I felt
comfortable that the Ottawa Police
Service had things well in hand
negotiating with the organizers and and
having a discussion on how this would
unfold in in downtown Ottawa
foreign
if I just cast back to the point about
intelligence that was being collected by
your msit and other people uh in in
conjunction with the Convoy
your your forces in Ottawa including the
intelligence people uh would have been
aware of the project tendon and similar
intelligence that was uh being shared
among intelligence agencies with respect
to the uh
size and scope and possible intentions
of this Convoy correct yep yes and
despite your having had access to all
that intelligence you still viewed this
as uh
an event that the Ottawa Police appeared
to have under control and didn't cause
you any particular concern other than
the extra attention you would have to
pay to your protective mandate that's
correct and there's no additional ask
for resources as they were planning up
when the carnivore was going to arrive
in Ottawa so we I I was of the feeling
that they had everything under control
and as I said
um if there's no request for resources I
know an incidence situation like this
that the the uh the organization on the
Intel side come together to share that
information but I didn't have any
concerns uh because I was I was of the
opinion that they had everything in hand
thank you
there is a fair bit of material that's
come before the uh commission already
and a lot of it is set out in your
institutional report and your uh the
summary of your interviews so I won't
rehash at all but I do want to spend
some time on the question of the
requests by the Ops for assistance and
resources to be provided by the RCMP
um I'll begin by just asking you to
describe uh this is probably for you
commissioner lucky the logistical
challenges and perhaps administrative
challenges that the RCMP faces
when it well I suppose some of these
apply even when you're moving within
provinces that you have contracts with
but in all events the logistical
challenges that you had when attempting
to mobilize resources to assist in
Ottawa or otherwise in Ontario
well first and foremost in the uh
requests they weren't requests for
plainclothes officers which is what we
primarily do in within Quebec and
Ontario we obviously they're police
officers so they have uniforms they
don't work in those uniforms each and
every day so when we make requests for
the federal resources in a uniform
capacity that's changing their role
their primary role
within the two provinces it's it's a lot
easier than outside of the provinces
only because we have control of the
federal resources but also because they
can drive into Ottawa but they don't
come in a big chunk so when we need
additional resources we fan that out
from um Deputy Commissioner duhammer
shop to the commanding officer of
Ontario and Quebec requesting additional
resources and then they do their uh what
they need to do to get those resources
and they will come individually or you
know driving however they get there when
we're doing the same thing nationally of
course we have to request uh the under
the ppsa the article 9 and then we get
into way more Logistics in the sense of
flying them out are there going to be
Vehicles available what kind of Shifting
are they going to do what types of
resources do you need because in in
especially in the contract policing
environment we have a multitude of of of
different types of resources within the
uniform capacity so it's we we need to
know what kind of resources and how long
they'll be gone because when we take
resources out of the contract side of
the house they have to be backfilled
somewhere else because policing goes on
so we we have to make sure that all of
those Logistics are done at that level
can I add to that
um
an important factor that we have to
remember is that requesting resources
feed from quebeco Ontario
the RCMP still has a mandate to fulfill
in those provinces and mobilizing
resources you have to find the resources
we have ongoing investigations that we
cannot stop so it's finding that right
balance of how many resources can we
release to make sure we keep the lights
on so to ensure that we are still on
Mandate of what we're doing in the
respective provinces so it's not just
it's easy to say we need 50 additional
people but then we have to look at who's
releasable in those divisions based on
the functions of the responsibilities
that they're that they have right now so
thanks yeah there there is a lot on the
record and uh about uh how many
resources were available when uh
can either of you give us the uh basic
facts of how many RCMP resources were
available from
the beginning to the end of this and
approximately when they were made
available I'm going to leave it to other
parties to drill down on that but just
if we can have a big picture of what
resources the RCMP committed to the
events in Ottawa so go ahead
commissioner in a general sense any
request that we got from Ottawa Police
Service we had fulfilled and in the
beginning it was between 30 and 50 for
example and when that was the first
weekend and as the time went by the
resources started to increase so we had
not only increased a front line
resources but increasing at the NR ncrcc
when we got into a unified command there
was people behind the scenes those
numbers were increasing and at one point
I think we got up to um
the the the total number at the end and
its total numbers we had in excess of
1100 people uh
uh 1100 people employees dedicated to
either the Ottawa Police Service uh
assistants for our protective mandate
and I can break it down even more in the
sense that a little over 650 police
officers to assist uh the Ottawa Police
Service and close to 210 to assist uh us
in our protective mandate so that's a
significant lift I know there's been a
lot of numbers circling around from 30
why didn't we respond to 50 there's also
that 250 that was raised uh the 250 I
just want to clarify that
um it was uh it wasn't 250 dedicated to
Ops
Ottawa Police Service it was actually it
was a mix-up we went we tallied up
everybody that was sworn in and some of
the people that were sworn in was
actually in support of the protective
mandate not necessarily supporting Ops
but still available if if they were
required
if you could slow down your testimony as
much as possible for the translators
because you tend to speed up speed up I
know you want to get out of here and
that could work but
I will add as well um there was the
whole we had also provided resources to
Windsor so we diverted some resources
for the Windsor blockade
thanks we're going to come back to
Windsor though if I don't offer you the
chance to say more about that please
volunteer at at an appropriate point but
with respect to what you said I I sense
uh
there's a bit of a glossing over from
the initial 50 to the ultimate 650
we all know that there ended up being a
very substantial commitment by the RCMP
and the opp towards the very end when
enforcement action was was imminent but
can you tell me roughly speaking what
the curve looked like in the first
sort of
14 or 15 days before
the the Implement of the implementation
of the enforcement plan started to
become uh imminent
I would say generally it started at
around 30 and then it continued up in
the 200s it got up to about 200 uh
throughout that uh that timeline and
then of course when we were gearing up
towards uh the actual enforcement in
that last week the numbers grew
exponentially and that's when we went
outside of the up till then the
resources were drawn from Ontario and
Quebec primarily and it was uh in those
last week where we were drawing
resources from across Canada
foreign
that's exactly the uh information I was
looking for thank you
um on that point uh
can you ex there was a fair bit of
controversy uh both between RCMP and the
City of Ottawa and the Ops about just
how many RCMP officers were
available
uh and you've acknowledged some
confusion about whether they were
available as boots on the ground to be
deployed by the Ops versus people you
were bringing in to assist in your
protective mandate but can you explain
why there was that difficulty of
communication between the RCMP and
Ottawa or the Ops about just what
resources you are allocating to deal
with the situation in Ottawa well I'll
start and then I'll pass it over to
Deputy Commissioner Dem but part of the
confusion came out of the fact that we
were swearing in a bunch of officers
that may in fact be used but weren't
being used so we that were in the
vicinity so we made sure like uh Deputy
Commissioner Dem said we swore in some
of the people under protective in case
they were brought over to assist in op
Ops so their numbers even they were
swearing in certain numbers those
numbers might have not all been deployed
at that time of the swearing in
also the fact that there was requests
and some of it was there was confusions
over is it so many per shift or is it a
total number uh but from the Tactical or
from the you know the bronze level of
our Command that we were talking about
uh we were advised that any of the
requests that they had for uh front line
when I talked about Frontline resources
we fulfilled those requests and uh I
think there was a confusion between what
the the mayor may have been reporting
and what the chief may have been
reporting but we were advised at the
Tactical level that any time they needed
uh resources because that's where they
get into what kind of resource where are
they going to be placed what shift are
they going to be working that was all
done at their level we didn't we didn't
get the intimate details of that but we
were advised that any of the requests
that they were getting through the
command center that they were fulfilling
no that's that's accurate okay thank you
you Mr clerk perhaps I could ask you to
pull up on the screen ssm.can.408433
and if I've got the number right that
should be the letter of February 7th uh
from counselor Deans and mayor Watson to
the Prime Minister and the minister of
Public Safety
and you're familiar with this letter uh
commissioner lucky
um
or perhaps not the letter but the
substance substance yes okay
and I ask this in particular reference
to your comment that all of the requests
by the Ottawa city or the Ops had been
responded to positively by the icmp and
and yet one might say we have this
letter
uh
I would say going from about as official
as Ottawa can get to about his official
as official as the city of Ottawa can
get to as official as of as the federal
government can get in which there is a
very specific request
for certain categories of police
officers a total of 1800 and Mr clerk uh
yes if you just that's right
thank you right there
um
and yet uh this is February 7th and
that's why I asked you the time scale
you acknowledge to me that the
substantial 600 odd figure of RCMP
boots on the ground so to speak did not
get to Ottawa until much after this and
yet at this same time you were assuring
Parliament that all of the requests by
the Ops had been met and so the question
for you is how do you reconcile your
statements with this letter what was the
date of the letter the letter is
February 7th 7th at that point when
there was a request for 1800 resources
um and obviously I was in consultation
with the opp commissioner and it it
tells what kind of officers but it
wasn't is it 1800 RCMP is it you know
because there there was still the
um OPP who were responsible for uh
securing resources from all the various
municipalities we were under the
impression that it was 1800 between all
of us and what did that mean who was
going to provide what resource and when
we get into these high numbers that's
when we have to ask okay what what is
the plan what where's your plan how are
are you going to rotate these resources
what kind of resources specifically and
it sort of talks about that but 100
civilian staff what does that mean
there's all kinds of Duties under
civilian staff
um the the public order officers
um
600 there we don't have you know to to
have 600 uh public order office officers
the opp was actually responsible for the
prioritizing of public order officers
within the province of Ontario during
that time did that mean they were going
to provide the public order we were
going to provide Frontline so until we
saw what the plan was because the minute
we draw outside of Ontario and Quebec we
have responsibilities to our contracts
we have to know when we draw them out
how long are they going to be gone when
are they going to be replaced how are
they going to get there what are the
logistics
um is there equipment that they can't
bring with them that they need when they
land like a certain vehicles or command
centers if in the in the case of public
order uh if they are going to drive
their command post then they need lead
time so there's lots of things to
consider uh General request like this
it's sort of in a way caught us off
guard because we weren't we didn't have
those discussions with Chief slowly up
to that time there was a talk about
increasing the resources for enforcement
but we didn't get into any specifics
until this letter came out
um yes if
the paragraph that begins we ask the
government of Canada and the province of
Ontario to work with us to secure this
combined officer uh surge is is is is
that what you mean when you didn't know
which of which force were being asked
for yes because it wasn't even
Federal Minister uh who was in charge of
you know oversees the RCMP as part of
his portfolio we didn't assume that we
were being asked for 1800 so did it mean
that three-quarters of those resources
would come from Ontario and 300 or 600
would come from RCMP we needed to see a
plan so this is from
um you know politician to politician but
we needed to translate that into
operational plan so we wanted to see
what the plan was and what kind of
resources specifically they needed with
what skill set and with what equipment
foreign
question uh
during your interview commissioner
Lockheed you described what you believed
to be the appropriate sequence by which
the Ottawa police force uh sorry Ottawa
Police Service should uh
seek assistance when it was beyond its
own capacity and that in particular it
should go to the Ontario Police
Provincial Police first or at least the
Ontario government and ask for
assistance which presumably would be
provided by the OPP and you referenced
the provisions of the Ontario Police
Services act as indicating the path for
this to take place
but was it your impression that that
that that that was the that that
provision of the Ontario Police Services
act obliged Ottawa
to go to Ontario either first or only
to get assistance policing assistance no
us I didn't did
tario police act until this Convoy
because we don't fall under the Ontario
Police act so when it like I said at the
beginning we just provided uh resources
directly to Auto Ottawa Police Service
they didn't go through the opp uh this
was you know assistance to a neighboring
Police Service and we provided that and
even subsequent requests wasn't going
through that but when it got to this
number that's when the opp commissioner
explained to me the process in which I
wasn't aware of that such requests
should go through the opp and then the
opp would exhaust all avenues within the
province of Ontario and if required
would come to outside you know they can
go to like another municipality like
Edmonton City police or a different
police services or they can go to the
RCMP and it wasn't until we got that big
ask that I was getting more information
about the Ontario Police act and that
information came to you from yes thank
you
I want to talk to you now about the role
that the federal government and I'll put
in that category for now both senior
officials and uh and politicians what
role they played in uh
your decisions to allocate resources to
Ottawa or as it might be Windsor but
locations outside where you are police
of of jurisdiction and in particular I
could if I could ask you to go back to
the beginning and remind us for a minute
who it is you report to
uh and who it is uh gives you guidance
or uh input on matters such as the
events in uh in Ontario
well first and foremost any of the
um deployment of resources is uh the
government or the minister has nothing
to do with that this is uh operational
decisions and we make those operational
decisions based on our availability of
resources our ability to to deploy such
resources
um if in fact like obviously this was
the last example you gave this was a
letter from uh the mayor to the minister
he would pass the letter on to us and
say Here's a request and uh he would
never say fulfill this request he would
say uh see what you know here's the
request deal with it what what you can
do
um depending on the numbers because we
may not have the numbers available to be
able to do that
um and that's why we were surprised
because it never usually goes to that
level it usually just goes
um you know from Police Service to
Police Service if they require
assistance uh it would come through our
Police Service we would fulfill it when
we as best as we can because uh in this
particular Convoy
um our goal was to assist
Ottawa Police Service as much as we can
we could so that they could be
successful in putting an end to the
protest
um as far as the the
any of the operational decisions the
government isn't involved with that and
it's just more of an information where
we provided you know we're providing
additional resources to Ottawa Police
Service those were a situation in those
were included in situational reports to
the minister and the prime minister
so if but if you can remind us just for
a second who who would you have been
interacting with to the extent the
federal government was either inquiring
about or expressing an interest in the
situation in Ottawa
well um obviously the deputy minister of
Public Safety Rob Stewart would have
been uh sort of the interlocutor between
the minister and myself so at times but
when we were we were doing uh three
briefings a day one was at the deputy
Minister level one was at the minister
level and and after I think February
10th or so was at the Prime Minister
level so there was lots of briefings on
the situation the movement of resources
if it only if it included RCMP because
that's the ones that I would report on
but generally speaking we didn't talk
about numbers of resources uh
specifically with the with the ministry
um
let me ask
a clerk to pull up PB NSC can
four zero is 80 43.
and just so that we can understand the
timestamps of these uh as I understand
it these are about five hours ahead of
time
because they're in Greenwich Mean Time
so that's this conversation which is
begins a time stamp at 5 59 would have
been taking place at about 12 59 or
about one o'clock that day is that right
yeah I don't think anything turns on
that for this particular discussion but
um it might later on in the other team's
chats that we look at
uh can you Mr can you scroll down to
page three
and the line I'm looking for is a
statement by Flynn
to the effect of when the AG starts
talking like this there we are
can you first tell us uh who uh Mark
Flynn is Mark Flynn is the um
he's the second in charge of federal
policing I don't know his official title
yeah Mark Flynn's assistant commissioner
response for National Security program
as well as our protective policing
program
and can you uh
either of you recall what uh discussion
was being uh
usually these team discussions are a
discussion among RCMP Personnel at the
time some other meeting is going on is
that correct yes because often normally
we'd be in a room and they'd be in the
room with me I'd bring people to assist
uh with the information because there's
often questions that I wouldn't know the
answer so I'd have my team but when it
uh was like for instance on the weekends
uh often people would be at home so we
would just uh create a teams meeting
right and this this February 5th uh
teams chat is observing a discussion uh
in which we see a reference to the
attorney general talking so this is an
observation about a cabinet or SSE
meeting no okay and
uh did you understand what Mark Flynn
meant when he said and I say this
because you would have been listening to
the conversation that he's listening to
when he makes his comment when the AG
talks like this we better get our own
plan going and your response looks like
you were trying to thumb out
well because I think up top it says who
is this speaking and because I'm a slow
typer I probably I see and a bad typer
obviously so what what did you
understand Mark Flynn to be saying when
the AG talks like this we better get our
own plan going probably at the time I
would know what he was talking about uh
now fast forward I haven't I can't
connect the dots at all we had like I
said there was so many meetings going on
um three or four sometimes five a day
during this time and uh if you had asked
me at the at the point in time I could
probably give you a lengthy explanation
but I have no idea can can you can you
join me in the inference that uh
just by by what Mark Flynn said that the
attorney general has said something to
the effect that the RCMP might have to
take some action
uh
no when I look at that there's a lot of
things I think that it could be
possibilities it could be the fact they
could be talking about our protective
mandate and making sure that we our plan
is uh is going I I honestly I wish I
could help you with this I have no idea
what the reference was to this
okay well that doesn't look like I can
take it uh further than that uh let me
try another one uh Mr clerk can you call
up uh OPP four zeros 4583
and uh on page three of that
and we're gonna have to figure out who's
who in this text exchange but first of
all the commissioner lucky can you
confirm that this is a text exchange
between you and commissioner karik of
the opp I believe so yes hey
and
you I don't know whether to ask your
clerk to scroll up or down but uh
there we are
the blue I believe is is you miss lucky
is that correct okay and in the middle
there uh you say this
between you and I only
GOC and by that you would have met the
government of Canada yes the government
of Canada losing slash lost confidence
in Ops we got to get to Safe action
slash enforcement can you tell me what
you meant when you said that well
generally speaking I mentioned it
earlier is our goal and especially from
my point of view was how can we help
Ottawa Police Service succeed in this
occupation of downtown and so now we're
into the second weekend of course
there's not much we can do during that
weekend because the numbers are have
grown exponentially
so I think first of all when they first
came on the very first weekend people
assumed that they would the uh Convoy
would come into town would they had an
agenda they'd follow their agenda and
then they would leave and when that
didn't happen and we got into the second
weekend uh nobody's uh we didn't from my
point of view we weren't expecting that
for them to stay that long and now it's
uh they've they're they're
um creating infrastructure they're
disabling Vehicles so now they're uh
there for which appears to be a longer
term so instead of reducing the
footprint which is always our goal in in
protest to reduce the footprint so that
if you do go into enforcement action you
can do it the safest way possible with
the least amount of resources uh it was
increasing exponentially so of course uh
people are losing confidence in the Ops
uh Ops ability to deal with the
situation
now uh
I'm Gonna Leave to to others uh the more
particular comments in your uh the
summary of your interview about uh
the leadership of Chief slowly and the
specific operations the Ottawa Police
Service but on this point you talk about
the government of Canada losing
confidence in the Ottawa Police Service
what was it in your interactions with
the officials and politicians of the
government of Canada that prompted you
to have that view well we always got the
same question each and every day when is
this going to end how is it going to end
and we really couldn't answer that and
of course early on we weren't intimately
involved with what was going on so there
obviously could have been negotiations
with the protesters the leaders of the
protest groups but people from the
outside looking in weren't seeing any
decrease in the activity they were
seeing the opposite they were seeing
increase in activity from the protest
groups and and more people
getting involved especially on the
weekends so of course people were
wondering if there was ever going to be
an end to this because they hadn't seen
any outwardly enforce action so it was
it in a way it's it wasn't a completely
um
if I could use the word educated point
of view because nobody knew the nuances
of what was going on uh tactically from
Ops it was just a comment from the
outside looking in
okay I I've I've tried twice to get you
to describe what it was made you believe
that the government of Canada had lost
confidence and I think twice you've told
me why one observing the situation might
have lost confidence so if I can bring
you back to that and ask you if you had
some inputs that made you believe the
government of Canada had lost confidence
well well we had Deputy ministers
meetings people were nobody said out
loud that uh I I don't recall people
saying you know what we're losing
confidence it was my observation by the
various comments about how come this is
still going on when is this going to end
how come it's getting bigger so from I
was inferring from those comments when
is uh Ottawa Police Service going to do
some enforcement when are they going to
deal with this situation
um I could hear the impatience I could I
could hear the frustration and from that
I inferred that they were losing
confidence
in Ottawa Police Service thank you for
that sorry now if I can if I can take
you down uh
sorry not not down but further on in
that text you say we gotta get safe
action slash enforcement can you decrypt
that for us so that's all about Let's
help them get a plan together so that we
can help them with uh safe enforcement
so again on having experience in public
order it's all about minimizing the
footprints you won't do that on those
weekends as we all saw the numbers grew
exponentially so obviously any
enforcement action should be between
generally speaking between uh the Monday
and the Friday where the footprint was
minimal and so helping them get to a
place because we knew that the numbers
were too big even with a minimized foot
for for them to handle it themselves and
they've they already mentioned that they
needed assistance from the various
police agencies so how can we help them
do that is what thank you
in the last uh text here
first of all the reference in there to
the emergency emergency measures act in
in retrospect am I correct in guessing
you meant the emergencies act yeah I
would imagine right okay so because if
they go to the emergency measures Act
you or and decide
thumbs are not not working with perfect
agility here you or I may be brought
into lead not something I want so a
concern you had was that the if and
this is February 5th and you're
contemplating the possibility of the
invocation of of emergency legislation
uh if they go to the emergency measures
act you are May or I may be brought into
the
so that was a scenario you thought was a
possible outcome of invocation of the
emergencies Act was that either the opp
or the RCMP would be would be put in
charge so to speak of the of the Ottawa
situation yes very early on when they
talked about emergencies act I had no
idea what exactly that meant and there
was talk about well what happens if
Ottawa Police Service cannot uh uh
enforce uh or or have the ability to
deal with the situation and uh there was
talk about you know do you change
leadership do you change police uh it
was all in general conversation nothing
specific and really it was from a place
of problem solving everything was put on
the table and it was so that was one of
the things that came up whether or not
that could actually happen that's when I
started learning more about the Ontario
uh police act where if they started to
go through the process of the Ontario
Police act they would in fact be the opp
that would be next in line to assist and
so it was just all it was was sort of
let's we need to help Ottawa Police
Services best we can so that
um Tom Tariq and I had lots of
conversations about
um helping Peter succeed through this
unprecedented event and and doing what
we can to uh through resourcing through
equipment through advice any which way
we could to help them get through this
situation
thank you and uh
if I could ask clerk to bring up PB NSC
can 408042
and scroll down to page two if I've got
the right document there should be a
comment by Whalen what is his objective
there we go thank you
now we can see from the uh
extract above that you were a
participant in this uh
teams chat again can I take it correctly
that you are in a team chat monitoring
uh I think it's in an SSE meeting yes
and uh
do you understand what Alice and Whalen
meant by what is his objective Beyond
getting us to take over can you scroll
up a bit Mr Clark could you give
commissioner lucky the context there
yeah tourism
three
I'm imagining again I'm speculating
because there is a lot going on I don't
know who he is in this reference but
obviously it's somebody talking uh I'm
imagining one of the ministers uh or
somebody in that meeting about what are
the next steps if in fact
um
Ops needs further assistance I'm not
exactly sure what it means
um what she means by that
um but I'm just wondering
um
if there was any she's asking is there
any other options besides us taking over
well let me ask you more directly then
rather than through what we have to
agree our our difficult deciphering so
long ago
uh choppy
text messages but uh were you having
discussions with senior officials or
your minister about the possibility of
the RCMP actually taking over policing
in Ottawa yeah I think there was a
misconception because people
automatically assume the RCMP being the
federal police agency that that's what
our that's what our responsibility was
so there was a bit of education on that
in in us saying of course when people
were looking at Solutions one of the
solutions was well why doesn't the RCMP
take over we got to ask that quite often
we'd say well it's not our we're not the
police of jurisdiction we don't have
jurisdiction in the province of Ontario
there's a lot of other layers before
coming to you would never come to the
RCMP that's not our role but I think
there was an assumption because we're
the uh Federal policing or national
policing agency in Canada there was an
assumption that that's what that meant
and so we were trying to educate
um Deputy ministers and ministers that
you know our role is not to overtake any
police agency we're here to assist in
any way we can
and and were you getting input from
senior officials or your minister or
other ministers for that matter
uh to the effect of what more can you do
can't you do more couldn't you be in
there
with statements like that oh there was
uh things like what do you need
um what do you need any more resources
or any equipment you need is there
anything we can help you with that would
help Ottawa succeed in this uh in this
event because I was the touch point for
all police agencies so whether it was
Windsor Coots you know the Lower
Mainland it was always whenever any big
event happens I always get the same
questions do you have everything you
need is there anything you you don't
have that you need please come to us
so I get those same questions right the
the the the the question to you do you
have everything you need is I think
substantively different than are you
doing everything you can or can't you do
more or
you know we've got a terrible problem in
Ottawa why aren't you in there helping
to solve it were you getting input like
that
um well we were again when they were
talking about us uh potentially and it
wasn't very lengthy conversations about
us potentially taking over there'd be
Snippets of that that would come out and
we'd have to correct that saying that
wasn't our role but obviously it was all
hands on deck on the solution uh problem
solving so people were asking you know
is there anything else that you could do
to assist that you're not doing
um is there how can we again when is it
going to end how is it going to end do
you need anything else anything to help
make it end uh those were questions that
were getting asked quite often but did
you get a sense that the senior
officials or the politicians
understandably concerned about the
situation on in Ottawa we're asking you
what you could do and not what resources
you needed but what you could do to
solve the problem problem in Ottawa
um not specifically in in those terms
but we would they've asked us are you
giving you know are you able to give
them the resources that they're asking
for that was one big question because uh
between the mayor and the minister there
was lots of talk about resources and we
were explaining that a lot as you
mentioned earlier the confusion over the
numbers and we were we told them we were
giving them everything they needed and
then and when they're ready to enforce
if they require additional resources
over a an enforcement plan we'll be
ready to assist but there was not
nothing specific like what how you
mentioned
and uh I'll ask this question generally
uh did you ever get a sense in the input
you had either from the the
senior officials your Deputy minister or
others uh or the ministers your minister
or others
uh that pressure was being put on you
that you if I can I think you'll
understand that if I put it this way
that crossed the line in terms of the uh
propriety of officials and politicians
giving you Direction about how Ottawa
should be policed
uh absolutely not there was a lot of uh
uh we I didn't feel the pressure
um from our point of view because we
weren't the police of jurisdiction but I
did feel the pressure internally
um because we wanted to do everything we
could to help
Ottawa Police Service but as far as from
the politicians uh providing direction
or for pressure
um there was in general wanting to find
an End solution to this of course within
our own organization especially uh on
the gold silver bronze when they all
came together everybody was rolling up
their sleeves trying to figure out how
are we going to end this and how are we
you know how are we going to deal with
this so we were putting a lot of
pressure on ourselves from an
organizational point of view
um and I would say that the politicians
felt the same pressure of wanting this
to end and of course there you know like
you said they're asking you know are we
doing everything we can to help them and
our answer would be the same their
leading it it would be and and often I
say it'd be like Chief slowly going to
uh Edmonton City police and telling them
you know what to do there's jurisdiction
and there's jurisdiction for a reason
and they despite even at the final days
of enforcement
Ottawa Police Service had the lead in
that and that was very very important
that they there always has to be
somebody who's taking the lead and it's
uh the police of jurisdiction
so coming coming back to this point
about uh I think it might have been you
but somebody used the expression the
line between church and state
which whether that's what you meant in
the context we've all assumed means the
line between
uh the political side and the policing
side and all of the both jurisprudents
and Analysis that's been done on where
that line should stand so my question to
you is where does the RCMP look for
guidance on where that line is and I'm
just going to insert parenthetically
we've had a lot of information about how
the Ottawa Police Service
has between it and the city council the
Ottawa Police Services Board and the
same will be true of other police of
jurisdiction of various places
we don't see the same between you the
RCMP and either the senior officials or
the politicians so where do you where
does the RCMP look to help find that
line between what we're calling church
and state
well for me it's it's uh pretty clear
anything operational we're advising
what's happening but we're not taking
Direction on how to do things
um and we've never been we've never been
provided Direction on how what we should
do and it was actually interesting I
think in one of the um uh meetings
because normally when I brief I brief uh
generally speaking the minister of
Public Safety and sometimes now that
they've split the minister of emergency
preparedness in this case there is
additional ministers and so I think it
was maybe the first IRG or maybe even
the first Minister meeting where I
believe it was uh Minister meningino
advising these ministers uh that you are
not to provide direction to the
commissioner they remind themselves my
ministers don't need to remind
themselves because we deal with them on
a daily basis or regular basis but with
the new ministers there was even just a
reminder because sometimes what happens
is when you're into problem solving
problem solving can sometimes translate
into you know we should do this and we
should do that and could we do this and
could we do that and sometimes that uh
people might uh feel that that's
Direction I don't consider any of that
direction direction to me is something
that you specifically would turn to me
and say commissioner
um we need you to do this or um don't do
this that's Direction that's
interference we don't get any of that
it's it's strictly a exchange of
information for the most part
okay thank you for that is there some
institution or body though that stands
between you and your minister the way
that one might analogize to the Ottawa
Police Services Board standing between
city council and the Ottawa Police
Service no we don't have a police
commission we've just we've just brought
in a uh in the last couple of years a
management Advisory board so sorry
repeat that I missed it uh in the last
couple of years we just brought in what
we call a management Advisory board but
they are uh there to provide advice to
to the commissioner uh they do not uh uh
they don't uh they're not the filter
between us and government right
and so if uh if your minister or a
minister were to cross that line
it's simply a function of you having to
say you're over the line uh Minister uh
or otherwise defend your
your own jurisdiction so to speak
there's there's there's no institution
that protects you from that everybody is
just expected to follow the rules or you
call them out
yeah there's no um there's no
institution in between the two of us but
we definitely have our policies and our
procedures uh and our Direction and
under the RCMP act
um I am uh in charge of the operational
command of the RCMP I can get
ministerial directives from the minister
but it's in in regards to administrative
matters but I I won't get anything for
example if I was to get a ministerial
directive I'm just hypothetically
speaking uh that I felt crossed over in
the operational uh uh domain I would
bring it to my legal advisors and say is
this crossing over you know so I'm just
trying to as I'm talking I'm trying to
think of somebody that would would act
as that and the only people I can think
of is probably uh legal advisors that
may in fact if I felt that happening but
I've never had to uh in meetings I've
never had to really you know tell
everybody to stop and your Crossing line
because it's it's it's they're very
cognizant of it and they're very
protective of it because we have similar
countries in the five eyes that are are
struggling with this and they actually
come to us and ask how we do it but it's
it's it's basically uh from previous
testimony at the mass casualty
commission I'm I'm because I've been
asked this question several times I
think it's time that we put something to
writing
um that outlines uh the what you can and
cannot do from both the commissioner's
perspective and the politicians
especially from a rotational point of
view there's a lot of different
um uh you know politicians change so
that they are understanding because
we're not the only operational
um uh entity in the federal government
there's uh Corrections there's
um
Border Services so I think it's time to
clarify it because it's been a topic of
conversation
I'm glad you went there because that was
the the next question I had because the
provincial and Municipal police forces
have already run into problems with this
those problems of generated commissions
of inquiry that have made
recommendations and given some guidance
and perhaps this commission will add to
that body of material but uh
how would you envision their this
further or better guidance and you might
have noticed that uh Deputy Minister
Stewart made the same observation
yesterday that that there was room for
development on this point but how would
you envision that what would it be
contained in some policy guidance
document and is there work on this now
well actually I think one of the members
of parliament has put in a private
member's bill on that very subject and
said it won't be difficult to do because
there's many police agencies who have
examples of what needs to be put in in
text to make this happen because it's
already out there and I'm just the name
is escaping me but there is a private
member's Bill to discuss this very issue
thank you and and and to be clear you I
I I I heard you say that this wasn't an
issue with respect to the Convoy or the
blockade but it is a topic you believe
should be addressed is that fair well
absolutely because in the last six
months I've had to respond to it on
several occasions and so my hope is that
my uh replacement won't have to so we
need to clear this up thank you
um
want to come back on a particular point
of interest that has attracted some
attention already uh uh before the
commission and and that has to do with
um well perhaps I could ask Mr Kirk for
you to call up WTS
6068
and if you can get to page 10 of that
yeah no you you had it there uh and uh
I recognize that handwriting
not much Deputy Commissioner
um this question is for you because am I
correct in identifying that as your an
extract from your notes that's correct
uh and perhaps you could first reads for
those of us who who haven't learned to
decipher your handwriting uh read the
two asterisk uh points that are in your
notes there yeah the the first one is
Peter referring to uh the chief chief
slowly from Ottawa Police Service said
he's going to ask double of what he
needs and the second asterisks is
planners from our shop integrated
planning cell uh what resources are
required because we're talking at that
point have an integrated planning cell
what type of expertise do we have to
bring
and this these notes stem from on a page
before that I believe it was
um uh Steve Bell that was briefing us
provided an update and there's a comment
that was shared by Steve Bell okay I was
just going to take you to that if you
look in the the type text below your
written note
uh you you uh describe roughly what you
just said that the note reflects a call
with deputy chief Steve Bell of the Ops
concerned the ops's request for uh
resources
um
this is your note of
what Chief Bell told sorry deputy chief
Bell told you exactly
and if I if I could have the page before
that because I don't have my notes but
I'm quite certain it reflects a call
with Chief Steve Ellis it's written down
below yeah
uh
I can pull up your notes if you want no
that's right I can confirm for you that
that is what you you have indicated
earlier
no I'm okay with that okay
um and if you can help us with this and
and you're not the first one to speak to
this uh this uh statement or comment uh
what did you understand uh Deputy uh
Chief Bell to be meaning when he said
well first of all Peter's Peter slowly
is that correct that's correct uh she's
going to ask
double of what he needs can you
understand what explain at least what
you understood Chief Deputy Chief Bell
to be saying so the way I interpret it
the numbers that were provided publicly
and through the letter that went to the
minister to the 1800 uh asked is is that
really reflective of the needs because
again I go back to what the commissioner
said earlier throughout this process
there was no plan to support or to
demonstrate the organization what skill
sets and resources are required to
support an operational plan and to
support the auto Police Service so I
took it when this was briefed to me the
first time the 1800 police officer a
thousand police officers 600 public
order teams 100 support staff I I took
it that is that what they're asking
considering that Deputy deputy chief
Steve Bell says he's asking the double
what he needs so I wasn't sure if that
was an ask and it was it was it was
starting to sound like a broken record
where without a plan both us and eopp
were kind of struggling as to what what
types of resources do you actually need
to to to assist in in addressing the the
issue in Ottawa
foreign
that an integrated planning cell which
we've sometimes heard called the IPC was
established by the RCMP and the opp on
about February 8th is that your
recollection uh uh around that date
where we brought the smes the subject
matter experts together to start
reviewing what what they had and start
building a plan
and
as I understand it the purpose of the
IPC was among other things to review
such planning as had been done to date
and to further develop the plan to deal
with the situation in Ottawa is that
right that's correct
did that effort that is the
establishment of the
integrated planning cell
uh
allow you and presumably the opp but
allow the participants in the planning
cell to put a finer point on the
resources that would be required to deal
with the situation in Ottawa
that was one of the objectives is to
nail down what was required for Ottawa
um
I'll ask this question in an open-ended
way uh
do you feel that the February 8th time
frame by which that integrated planning
cell was established
uh do you feel that the situation in
Ottawa could have been handled more
effectively if that integrated planning
cell was established earlier in the
process
it wouldn't merely be speculation on my
part how it could have been handled if
this was put together sooner uh could it
have could have um could have come to an
end sooner perhaps but I I'm not in a
position to say that it would
considering everything that was going on
so fair enough and and the other thing
to factor in is
is it's one thing to look at the plan
but again I go back to what I mentioned
earlier when it comes time to mobilize
resources from across the country it's
it's not only challenging but sometimes
resources don't get in the next the next
day it takes a couple days before you
get there so
if I could also add not being
intimately familiar with what what Ops
was doing they could very well have been
in negotiations with protesters and we
always say in public order if you're in
Syrian protests if you are in
negotiations with the leaders or various
people
in in these protests while you're still
having the conversation it's not you're
not going to go into enforcement so not
knowing that we could only speculate
that that they could go into enforcement
when they might in fact be in the midst
of negotiating a peaceful resolution
so did you view the integrated planning
cell as strictly an enforcement and a
mechanism to organize enforcement no
because part of that when you're dealing
with protests you have
taskings going to your police liaison
teams who are dealing with the leaders
of the protest group uh from what I
understand it was a little bit more
problematic because generally speaking
you have one leader in this case there
were several leaders so obviously it
makes the task a little bit more
difficult when you're dealing with uh of
quite a few different people but
um it's it's all about having those
conversations about how to find a
peaceful way to get an illegal blockade
back to a peaceful protest thank you and
we'll come back to that very point but
just so I understand correctly what
you're saying is you don't mobilize your
public order units right away when
there's still a viable option of a
liaison solution to the situation
um not necessarily it depends on the
Dynamics because if you are negotiating
and there's
um there's problems where people whereas
Public Safety is at risk you may in fact
have your you may be in negotiation and
still have your public order teams
staged uh at a location so you still may
need them just in case in the event
every protest is different
um
I'd like to move on to another topic now
and for that purpose uh Mr clerk could
you call up OPP
five zeros one five one and the topic
here is
uh
not everybody Monastery monitors these
proceedings as closely as some of us do
but what we're calling the engagement uh
proposal
I think you're familiar with that I
think at these from our interview with
you commissioner lucky so I just want to
ask you some questions about
uh
uh about your involvement in this and
and maybe I'll just throw it out to you
to describe uh how you first
learned about this possibility what your
involvement was with with Deputy
Minister Steward and and connecting him
uh yeah to Marcel Boden Etc so if you
can just begin at the beginning and tell
us what you can about that so there was
conversations about the protest groups
wanting to talk to a uh an official like
a
um a
politician or an official of some sort
and nobody was sure if it was at the
provincial municipal or federal level at
that point and so I believe that Deputy
Minister Rob Stewart was tasked with
looking into the possibility of having a
an official speak with the protesters
and he wanted to know how that works
with the liaison teams and how they
negotiate what they're doing as far as
negotiations with the um protesters
because we weren't involved with all of
that I reached out to Tom Creek and and
Tom Creek advised me that it was in fact
the opp police liaison team that was
leading the negotiations with the
protesters and so I asked if I could
connect the lead who the lead was of
that team and if I could connect them
with Deputy Minister Rob Stewart so he
could get more information and really I
my role was as a facilitator and I
introduced the two of them so they could
talk later on he was coming up with this
protest engagement strategy I think he
asked what you know what we thought of
it I sent it back to my team who deals
with the liaising we have a different
structure but same idea but different
structure I gave it to them to say is
there any red flags on on these
documents or is there any advice we can
provide Deputy Minister Stewart I think
we provided him a bit of advice on that
I think as well like I've I included
um
uh asking Mr inspector Bowden what he
thought of uh what I had said but then
I'd already realized that he had
reviewed the document I think so it was
just a matter of uh connecting Deputy
Minister Stewart with uh inspector
Bowden on this protest engagement
strategy as one of his tasks
uh now we we did hear from from Deputy
Minister Stewart about the
Evolution and ultimate demise of this
proposal but uh
in terms of your uh
observation of it from its conception
through to the end uh did you hear it
discussed among uh either officials or
at the IRG did you have input on it to
the IRG as to whether you thought it was
a viable proposal not me specifically it
was Deputy Minister Stewart who is
leading that and any any thoughts I had
on it I would have provided to him
actually
I can switch gears here a bit on is this
a good time actually uh Mr commissioner
this would be a very good time to break
yes okay so we'll take the morning break
for uh 15 minutes I'll see
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
oh yeah
foreign
order a lot
the Commissioners we can win the
commission on April
go ahead thank you
foreign
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner we
understand from the records we can call
them up if uh if it's helpful to you but
that on or about February 13th
you got a sense that uh the plan that
your integrated planning cell and she
slowly had been working on
had come to a state of fruition or
maturity is that about the right timing
February 13th yeah that was when it was
completed and
Ken we've heard some evidence about this
from the other police agencies but just
for your perspective on it this was a
team effort so to speak by planning
experts subject matter experts from the
RCMP the opp and the Ottawa Police
Service yes
and uh as I understand it uh you in
particular uh commissioner lucky and
perhaps the rest of your team who looked
at it were generally satisfied with the
plan as an operational plan to deal with
the situation in Ottawa
yes both myself and commissioner karik
were briefed on the plan the Friday
um the Friday before that like um I
think it was around February 11th uh we
got an actual briefing from the planners
on on the plan
and yeah we yes we were satisfied with
the plan
and is and would it be correct to say
that on your observation of the plan
uh it was developed in Reliance
exclusively on your existing legislative
and common law authorities
uh yes but they also did take into
consideration because around the same
time the Ontario Ontario had put in
their emergencies act so there was a
talk about how that would affect the
plan or not
and going forward there was talk of the
emergencies act which nobody really knew
what that meant and just that a
recognition that if in fact
um any other legislation or authorities
came through we'd have to adjust the
plan but it wasn't taken into effect in
the planning of it well thank you for
for uh
drawing uh I'll say carving out the
Ontario emergency plan but if I can be
more refined then with my question your
the plan as you understand it and
commissioner Creek under understood it
was drafted without any Reliance on any
of the powers that might uh be available
to the enforcement forces from federal
emergency legislation yes
and did any of your subject matter
experts involved in the integrated
planning cell that is uh
uh the RCMP experts on that team
express any concern for you that the
plan was deficient because of gaps in
existing authorities
uh not at that time no
now
you uh we're now going to move into a
time period that ends up being densely
packed with meetings and and activities
and the development by you and your team
of key messages and everything this is
the the 12th 13th and 14th the days
leading up to the invocation of the act
and uh and I understand that on February
13th you attended you commissioner lucky
attended I'm going to insert
parenthetically there when we say
attended a meeting sometimes this would
be virtual sometimes it would be
physical or was it always virtual well
both depending on the deputy Minister
The Minister's meetings were generally
virtual many of the irgs were in person
thank you
and on February 13th if I can refresh
your memory there was a democ at around
noon and a briefing with Minister
Mendicino and Blair at about 1pm and IRG
at about four and a cabinet meeting at
about 8 30 is that right yes and the
subject matter of all of these meetings
was the Convoy and blockade situation
across the country is that right yes
we have uh
a number of your key message documents
that you uh developed for presentation
or delivery to these meetings and I'll
I'll just give you the the sort of big
question we're trying to get some
elucidation on here and then we'll break
it down in as many parts as you think
would be helpful and you remembering
what went on in those probably very
densely packed days but the question
we're trying to get to is how much of
your key messages got delivered to the
dmoc and the IRG and cabinet because
we've tried to follow the sequence of
events and we do this
forensically by watching your team's
chats and trying to figure out as you
folks are watching the meetings going on
whether you ever got a chance to speak
at a given meeting or whether your
points were ever discussed Etc so rather
than me trying to recreate that whole
forensic
analysis as to what happened on the 13th
to to your efforts to educate the irgn
cabinet on your views about these events
maybe I can just put it over to you and
say if you remember those days the
development of those key messages and
how if when you were able to deliver
them in those various forums pretty well
um I don't want to say 100 but pretty
close at the beginning of each of those
meetings after they uh brought up the
agenda I would be generally the first
person they would go to and I'd give
that situational overview and
literally be reading those key messages
so most all of the information that were
in those key messages were delivered
I there might have been some exceptions
but very minor nature
um
uh
let's let's call up the key messages
document to see if we can uh see what it
is you were
hoping to and as you just described it
in in some cases able to communicate and
this would be SSM
can
NSC four zeros 2906
now we've seen several I don't know if
the drafts or variations of this do you
know of different documents were used in
different contexts or if they are just
drafts of a single Doctrine sometimes
what happened what would be
um a very similar document was delivered
at The Minister's briefing and then
there might have been slight amendments
because the situation changed but that
would be the only reason why it would
change but generally speaking the uh uh
at dmoc ministers meeting and the irgs
for very similar messaging
and if we could just scroll down uh what
would and as as we're looking at this uh
commissioner lucky is this something
that you would read from or jump through
how how did your presentation I'd read
through it I would read through it thank
you yes and and you you would uh uh use
with their PowerPoint or P did was this
piece of paper distributed among those
who are in attendance no so these were
just your speaking notes my speaking
notes thank you
you mentioned that you would be among
the first to speak at these meetings
were you in effect cabinet and the irg's
window into the law enforcement
situation uh for the purposes of
those bodies understandings of the
Convoy and the blockades yeah I was
representing uh for the most part all
law enforcement so we would gather up
the information from the various uh
protests whether it didn't matter which
place was the jurisdiction I would
report on behalf of police
which is often what happens when there's
a national event
right so today
so to the extent that uh
the Ops or the opp have information uh
about the status of the protester
blockades in their various mandates that
came to cabinet or the IRG or the dmoc
through you yes
um
if you look uh if we scroll down the
page to The Heading additional supports
it's uh
I think page six of this document
now can
can you explain what this section of
your speaking notes is about
um well it's in reference to discussions
on the implications of the emergency Act
um
and that's where I'd mentioned earlier
about uh being consulted as to whether
the any of the authorities that they may
provide us would would we would be able
to enforce if there was any uh
challenges to that enforcement and it
was it doable so to speak from a law
enforcement perspective we were also
consulted on potential authorities and
so we've created a little list of what
we thought would be potential
authorities early on
and and in here you see there's a few
examples of additional tools that would
be useful
no uh
did you consult other police agencies
in the course of compiling this list of
uh possible other authorities at that
point I don't believe so I think we we
did consult internally within the RCMP
where um like BC is BC Alberta and
Manitoba especially because that's where
um some of the protests were in our area
I don't believe
um I I don't believe we reached out to
all of the other agencies
like all other police agencies I I
wasn't I I don't think because of
possibly we weren't uh to reach out
outside of the RCMP on this because it
was uh part of cabinet
so there might have been obligations of
conf excuse me confidence that prevented
you from Consulting outside the icmp
yeah I'm guessing I I don't know
specifically but I I don't believe that
we uh reached out to other other police
agencies but there were there could have
been talk at the planning level like
through the national capital region
Command Center or the uh integrated
Command Center they they may have spoke
about it but I you'd have to ask Deputy
Commissioner Mike to him because I
wasn't involved in in that command
structure
to my knowledge sir there was not no
consultation one because of the
confidence aspect because the drafting
uh uh they're looking at putting
measures into the Act and the other
thing I'd like to highlight is the we
had a very short turnaround time to get
these uh recommendations or what we
thought would be useful for law
enforcement uh so it was it was uh as I
recall that it was done strictly
internally
of the RCMP
um
Aaron can we scroll down further Mr
Clark in this document
uh
it's uh
the paragraph that begins that said the
one that's up there and I'll I'll
I'll I'll read it and you can read it
with me and then I'll ask you some
questions yeah these are
your notes and presumably what you said
to the IRG and cabinet on the relevant
occasions
that said I am of the view that we have
not yet exhausted all available tools
that are already available through the
existing legislation
there are instances where charges could
be laid under existing authorities for
various Criminal Court offenses
occurring right now in the context of
the protest
Ontario Provincial emergencies act just
enacted will also help in providing
additional deterrent tools to our
existing
toolbox and then the bullet below that
these existing tools are considered in
our existing plans and will be used in
due course as necessary
as I say this set of speaking notes had
been
in various iterations and also ended up
in an email that you sent to Mr Jones
the ministers chief of staff
was this point that you mentioned here
in your uh
addresses to the irgn cabinet was that
also something you had expressed to for
example uh Deputy Minister Stewart or
chief of staff Jones before these uh
speaking points were distributed or
before your email on the topic I'm not
sure the timing I know that there was an
email exchange with the chief of staff
so I don't know if it was before or
after this meeting if it helps you it
was short it was in between the IRG it
was if you look at time stances right in
between the IRG and the cabinet meeting
uh you sent in effect these points
including sorry your speaking points
including these two uh bullets here
had you had these discussions about your
views on existing authorities with any
of the officials before the circulation
of these notes yeah I think we would
have been uh exchanging verbally like a
Deputy Commissioner Durham said it
happened so fast uh there was uh Deputy
Minister was working on this we weren't
in the working group we were just
brought in as subject matter experts on
on various authorities that potential
authorities but we weren't uh in the
drafting of any of this that wasn't our
role so
um
this uh would have been provided
um probably verbally we would have
spoken about it and then obviously
because I was asked in an email it was
provided in writing
if I can ask
the clerk to call up PB NSC can 408041
this is another one of the teams chats
and if you look at the time stamp again
allowing that these are stamped five
hours ahead of the time zone that we
would have been here in Ottawa
uh you'll see the date is February 13th
and if you just look from the first page
to the last you see it it covers a
period of time up to uh looks like 6 35
pm at the very end are you able to if I
ask the clerk to scroll ahead to the end
of the document just so that
commissioner Lockheed can see the range
of the discussion okay
they are
um
the point I wanted to draw your
attention to in in this particular
team's chat uh commissioner Lockheed is
at page
well it's page 19 of this document Mr
clerk maybe if you can find that
um
if you go down to the first yeah there
we are
now if we look at the time stamp at 10
21
PM this would actually be
if I understand correctly 5 21 PM is
that right
and now you're nodding there
commissioner Lockheed but the defense or
whatever will want to hear yes or no
thank you
um
and again just to so the uh
parties and viewing public can
understand what's going on here this is
a discussion that you and your team are
having sort of offline these aren't
actual comments in the meeting your uh
well were you present at this IRG
meeting I believe this was the IRG
meeting of the 13th uh I believe so yes
so have you got your your phone out and
your and you've got your team watching
it on their computers in their offices
perhaps uh
um I may have been there in person I'm
not sure I I think the team was actually
there no the team wouldn't have been
there but um I might have been there in
person or it could have been on videos
there was a couple on video right so I
don't know which one you might you might
get some insight as we go through your
your comments here because you you're
asking somebody in the first entry here
whether you are the next up on the
agenda
um someone suggests you're not uh
and then someone says
situate situational updates Etc the next
is you
and so and the question we're wondering
we then it then goes over to uh
it's just Mr clerk if you can just
scroll down the page
uh a point where uh
and there's a entry under Flynn mark on
page uh 20.
that's it
situational update
and then it says under number two
Minister Mendocino may turn to
commissioner Brenda lucky
uh and I guess since these are from your
notes you may
also asked to speak Etc do you do you
figure that that's where you got asked
to give the situational update with
respect to Ottawa uh possibly uh there
was always usually a spot for a
situational update
um sometimes
on on the ERG there was always
usually a spot for me to provide a
situational
update depending as they got closer to
the
uh there was one that I didn't I believe
I didn't provide much of an update
because there was a discussion mostly on
the on the uh emergencies act so it
wasn't about me providing information it
was just them discussing the emergencies
Act
Jesus
could we have 80 41 brought up on the
screen uh sorry PBS PB NSC can
four zeros eighty forty one
that's what this is
oh I'm sorry
right on P then it's page 12 of that
document I'd like you to look at
[Applause]
and in there's a section under Mark
Flynn
and uh
I'll just read it for you Ops just
confirmed the plan is finally reviewed
and approved their Planning Group will
integrate here
with our group
um
and paragraph sorry parenthetical
comment this came from Carson and
figure that's Carson party yes
um
were you able to update the uh IRG with
that development when it came in on your
phone I don't believe so
I think though in that the IRG from
February 13th I did provide some
information on the plan in general but
not that with this latest development
now if we could turn up Ops
00014
five six six
and uh
I don't know if you recognize these uh
commissioner lucky but if it helps you
they're described to us as as the notes
from Chief slowly scribe of of a meeting
and we'll get to a point uh if you um
if you scroll down Mr Clerk
to the point where there's a meeting
with commissioner lucky it's about two
pages down
there we go
so that's uh again if you
understand these to be the notes of uh
then Chief slowly this is a meeting
between him and you and commissioner
Creek of the opp
uh the point that I'm interested in in
light of the conversation we just had is
uh the second bullet under the redacted
section
where I Chief slowly again this isn't
your your notice his observation of what
he he understands you to have told them
did not get the Prime Minister briefed
on the plan
uh can you understand why why Chief
slowly would have had that impression
I'm not sure because this was on the
14th uh I believe that's right yeah
because I I believe in my in the IRG
notes that I provided I did speak about
the plan
so I'm not sure if if that in fact I
um why that was put on there
commissioner may I just yes have any
assistance my friend it may be that
the interpretation is the opposite that
these are commissioner Lucky's
statements to the meeting that are
recorded by that scribe I'm not certain
that those are those are slowly's words
to her oh okay sorry
that's even more helpful then so yeah
they're not like
I don't know I've never seen these like
these are my notes or anything okay
but
some uh
The Scribe has recorded you as saying
that you didn't brief uh the Prime
Minister on the plan and you're you you
don't have an explanation for why
that would be there do you do you think
you said something that would have given
the Scribe the impression that that was
what you were saying ah
no idea because I I would assume because
in the IRG of the 13th I briefed them on
the plan so I don't know why on the 14th
um
it says that is it is it possible that
at the IRG on the 13th you didn't get
reached on the agenda or you didn't get
a chance to say what you wanted to say
about the plan uh anything's possible
but generally speaking uh I always was
turned to at the beginning of all those
meetings and with the speaking notes
um
so I'm not sure about the discrepancy
um
Mr commissioner if I can just have an
Indulgence here because I would like to
see if I need to pursue that point any
further uh
spicing if I have a different version of
the February 13th
IRG minutes
now I will move on I think page 20 of
the uh the previous uh
document 8041 indicated that the
commissioner didn't get reached so that
may be what you're looking for thank you
maybe maybe uh Mr clerk if you can put a
8041 back up
thank you yes I see what's happened
a little further if you go to page 20
down to towards the bottom of the page
you make the comment commissioner lucky
so doesn't look like I will be reporting
on anything
and what we were wondering is if that is
why you said to Chief slowly the next
day that you didn't report to uh the
Prime Minister on the development of the
plan
anything's possible I don't want to
refute the the notes of the Scribe if
that's what the Scribe wrote the only
thing I would say is
um
I would have to look if they had if
there were any notes on the IRG that
were shared then I would be able to
compare that if I did in fact because
usually when I was briefing in the IRG
that would have been showing
well so that again because I want to be
fair to you here just to make sure you
have the best direct selection you can
of this February 13th meeting because
you can see you here saying doesn't look
like you'll be reporting on anything uh
Andrea Howard observes that they are on
the last item which I'll infer was the
last agenda item then at the top of the
next page Mr clerk if you can scroll a
little further
uh he may not go to you
uh is this during is that the time frame
just just to be sure this time frame of
1754 is when the IRG was going on well
the the time frame uh
on the time stamp is is 10 55 which
would be 5 555 in the afternoon which
would have been when the IRG was sitting
okay and then uh
I'll I'll just I think you inserted a
bit of uh uh
exasperation or humor into this
discussion that the if you scroll down
further
with the hypothesis that you uh did not
get reached you say please do not invite
me to cabinet
um so with with that uh recollection and
I thank the commissioner for taking you
back to that document does that help you
recollect that maybe you didn't get
reached at that IRG meeting it it would
indicate in all likelihood I wasn't uh
but I I guess right I'm just going by
these notes it appears that that's what
it's it's right leaning towards yes uh
in In fairness to your recollection
there was another there was a cabinet
meeting the same uh night do you know
whether you uh spoke at that
um I don't think so I think I was
invited to support the minister but uh I
didn't speak at that okay
I'll ask you then to go with the
hypothesis for now acknowledging that
your memory is just based on these notes
that you prepared the speaking notes in
which you made uh roughly speaking two
points there was a we didn't take it
through it but it was a description of
the of the status of the of the Ops
RCMP OPP plan
that you wanted to had intended to
present to the IRG
it was your point that you believed that
there were enforcement options still to
be exhausted uh and that the plan had
been developed without Reliance on any
special measures and you had those two
points
you weren't reached out on the agenda by
hypothesis if these teams chats are
accurate and that would also explain why
you might have said to Chief slowly the
next day I didn't brief the Prime
Minister on the plan if I put all of
that together to you does that help you
accept the proposition that you didn't
present your key messages to the
government on the night of the 13th and
that is why you told Chi slowly the next
morning that the plan hadn't been
briefed to the prime minister
yes and if I was to brief on the planet
it wouldn't have I wouldn't have briefed
them on the plan I would have just told
them of the existence of a plan to go
forward right but not the nuances but it
would from what you're saying and like I
said there's five or six meetings a day
um it it sounds like that's how it might
have occurred okay
but but I want you to concentrate on on
that scenario then
cabinet is on the verge of invoking the
emergencies Act
you are their window on law enforcement
you told us this earlier your update to
Cabinet as it is deciding whether to
invoke the emergencies Act is that the
police now have a plan
they pull it together
and that you as the commissioner of the
icmp
consider that plan to be workable
without the authorities of the
emergencies Act
and that doesn't get delivered your
messages don't get delivered to Cabinet
when they then deliberate on the
invocation of the ACT you appreciate the
significance of that scenario
uh yes and no because we had spoken
about the fact that we had an integrated
planning cell that we were bringing
together a plan an enforcement plan to
go forward so there was talk about a
plan and that a plan was in progress I
reported on that I believe in in my
previous IRG so it wasn't a Brand New
Concept
um but yes in fact the fact that we now
had a plan I'm not sure if it was signed
off either as of that point because we
were having difficulty getting it signed
off we didn't realize it needed to be
signed off but I know that um on that
same day like the I think it was the
Sunday that would have been I'm I'm
guessing the that was the 13th I had
actually I think reached out to Chief
solely about signing off the plan I'm
not sure the timing on that but
the existence of a plan was known just
the fact that it was official or not
official wasn't uh reported on okay
um let me summarize what you're saying
and then put a question to you as I hear
what you're saying though you didn't get
a chance to present either the plan or
your view that the invocation of the ACT
would be taking place before law
enforcement
tools had been exhausted even though you
didn't get a chance to deliver those
messages at this meeting
you feel that in general those points
had been briefed up to your the
officials that you reported to is that
what you're saying
yeah because I believe in the the second
IRG which was on the 12th I had spoken
about the integrated command
um
a center had been stood up that a plan
was we brought in planners they were
um in the Pro in the process of doing
the plan I believe I reported on that
I'd have to see the notes though
um but I didn't officially go into your
point that you know that could have uh
that wasn't reported that the plan was
that now officially signed off or
officially in place okay so so
acknowledging that there might have been
some some less precise messaging to the
officials into government before the
meeting where you didn't get called
nonetheless you appreciated the
significance of those meetings that were
taking place on the 13th and you
appreciated the significance I I assume
of the fact that you hadn't got a chance
to give those key messages that we've
looked at before did it did it occur to
you that you should make sure that
government was aware of your views on
these points before it came to
land on the invocation of the
emergencies Act
I guess in hindsight yeah that might
have been something significant honestly
um there was so much information going
back and forth I'm not sure you know
where they were at in in the invocation
as such I know they were talking about
it but
um it was very very fluid it obviously
it it I'm not sure if it would have
changed anything in the sense that these
were even like now I'm going to use my
hindsight the plan uh ended up those
those authorities ended up to be useful
with the plan
um if I use my hindsight because it
wasn't whether or not we didn't we were
still we would have uh still been
looking at enforcement but we needed uh
ways to reduce the footprint so we were
using some of the authorities obviously
under the Ontario emergency act we
weren't incorporating anything on the
Federal Emergency act because it wasn't
in place
um but we didn't uh we didn't have when
exactly that plan was going to start uh
or we knew it had to be starting in the
weekdays as opposed to the weekends so
now the plan was in place and the
implementation would have been
um uh the next exact when we were going
to implement it that's that's fair
enough and I won't ask you to speculate
or hypothesize about what might have
happened if you had had a opportunity to
deliver these two messages but I I think
as I understand what you've said knowing
the gravity of the issues that we're
facing the IRG and cabinet on the 13th
you prepared your key messages with
those two points that the police
services had come together with a viable
plan and that you considered that there
were still law enforcement tools to
exhaust before emergency legislation was
necessary correct
yes thank you
now if we move on there's a there's a
another
constellation of events happening on the
14th so we're going to go over to the
14th
and
the uh
this involves us a series of
crisscrossing emails and I'll ask the
the clerk to First Call up PB NSC can
four zeros 84.85
and uh
I'll I'll ask first of all uh
because this is a name that's that's new
to the cast of characters uh
so far
um a name it's not gonna we're not going
to see it right away but just so that we
can understand when it comes into the
picture who Adriana polos is and I think
this is probably a question for you
Deputy Commissioner yeah Adriana polis
is responsible for our
Intel and international uh policing
program so the impset I referred to
earlier on ideologically motivated
criminal intelligence it reports into
her uh to her program perfect thank you
um now clerk if you could scroll down on
this a little bit
um
there's a series of
emails by which there we can stop there
um
this is sort of
Deputy Commissioner and commissioner I
don't expect you to have seen this email
other than you might have in the course
of preparing for this hearing that is I
don't expect you to have seen it at the
time perhaps but just to set up what is
going to come at you so you can
understand the context this is an email
from Jody Thomas and we all know that
she's the National Security intelligence
advisor to the prime minister
uh and it is February 14th and uh
I don't know if that's a reliable
email uh
timestamp but if assuming it's just a
normal email time stamp it's about
midday on the 14th and
uh
that's probably going to put us
somewhere just after the first
Minister's meeting or just before anyway
right in the context of of that event on
the 14th and we have Jody Thomas saying
and I'll just read it out so that uh
so that it's on the record uh she is
writing to Mike McDonald and we'll learn
later on who he is but he's another
person in uh in the PCO intelligence
apparatus and he's copied Rob Stewart
who we saw yesterday uh as the deputy
minister of Public Safety and Ms Thomas
says this is about a national threat to
National interest and institutions
by people who do not care about or
understand democracy we are preparing to
be violent sorry who are preparing to be
violent who are motivated by
anti-government sentiment
and and uh
hey can you scroll down to the a little
further Mr clerk on that and then
uh
again we're all going to have to be a
little bit detectives figuring out
what's going on with these emails
because this is a sort of Orphan email
from Jody Thomas not obviously to
anybody but is attached to the one that
we just looked at
where she where she says I need an
assessment for Janice and I'll just ask
you to speculate with me that that's
Jenna schurette the clerk of the privy
Council
about the threat of these blockades the
characters involved the weapons the
motivation
clearly this isn't just kovid and is a
threat to democracy and rule of law
could I get an assessment please
David is this you it is a very short
fuse please call if you have any
questions Jay now again you're perhaps
wondering why I'm reading you emails
that aren't to you or from from you uh
but what we'll see and this will be the
next email is that that the request for
an assessment gets directed to Adriana
polis which is why we talked about her
so on that point could I ask the clerk
to pull up uh
TB NSC can four zeros 3462
okay and we may just to get the sequence
correct let's go down to the to the to
the bottom of this or at least to there
to
if I'm understanding correctly maybe
mr2m since you ended up getting copied
in here you would uh be able to help us
with this it it looks like the request
from Jody Thomas
got directed by some means perhaps by Mr
McDonald but or perhaps by you if you
can help us with that got somehow
directed to Adriana polis is that how
you interpret that
uh yeah the request would have gone from
directly probably from Mike to Adriana
on this one right and that's because
it's going roughly speaking from the
National Security intelligence advisor
and her directorates down to the rcmp's
intelligence people right correct and
they were probably looking for
additional information because the
Strategic threat advisory reports that
were being shared with government were
also being shared for PCO so those eight
documents I mentioned earlier might have
been a follow-up on what was in one of
those documents so what you're saying is
PCO is used to getting intelligence
briefings from Ms Polo's department or
at least a department that reported to
her the document was shared with them
yeah
um and then uh again Ms Polo's writing
back to Mr McDonald
and gives an assessment and we're not
going to read to the whole thing but it
appears to be and Mr clerk maybe you
could just scroll slowly down so the
audience can get a gist of of what's in
there as I say
we don't have time to read the whole
thing the documents available to parties
if they want to look at it in more
detail but it's a description we see a
reference to three percenters to Diagon
to Canada first
Etc to various uh
uh movements or individuals that could
be implicated in in National Security
matters and then a reference to imve
groups and then finally uh in the
penultimate paragraph there reference to
blockades at the international uh
borders
so uh let me ask the the sort of chain
of command or institutional flow
uh question here to either of you a
commissioner or Deputy Commissioner how
does it happen that when the nsia wants
a security threat it doesn't go through
one of you but goes directly to somebody
in an intelligence directorate that
frankly none of us had seen before we
saw this email
it happens based on some relationships
that are built uh that they reach
directly into the units uh preferably
there should be uh one stop for all
requests that come in so we can have at
least a an idea of what's going out but
it happens
uh where they reach in directly to the
person and that person will either CC me
on the message or brief me about what
the request is so
right and
the point about briefing you is the one
that intrigues me this wasn't just a
request for a threat assessment by
somebody who happened to know somebody
in your department as I think everybody
understood at this stage
the nsia was giving advice to the
government on the invocation of the
emergency act for the first time it had
ever been invoked and that threat
assessment goes straight past everybody
to Adriana polas and then straight from
her back to the nsia
and is is that how you would have
expected things to happen if there had
been more time or or more attention to
Conventional channels so I I honestly
had to go through document in its
entirety because I think I'm not quite
sure for referring to a threat when I'm
looking at this Adriana is explaining
some of the signs that we're seeing from
imv groups across the country flags
posters stickers
um but I'd have to go through the entire
document and it's possible that Adriana
would have briefed me before sending it
out but I I think one thing that we have
to understand is the nsia the RCMP is
only one organization that's providing
criminal intelligence to the NSA you
have the service itac also has a role to
play so the NSA is getting information
before she forms an opinion an idea to
brief
whoever she's getting information from
other departments as well so we're
really the RCMP is really in the
criminal uh space when we provide that
Intel
that's fair enough and I as I think we
saw this was a very time pressured
situation Ms polis was asked to turn it
around very very quickly Ms Thomas was
interested in a very short order so it
might be understandable that coroners
were cut or or direct contacts were used
as you said I I'm just trying to figure
out you ended up getting copied on this
uh Deputy Commissioner did you
appreciate the significance of the fact
that people under your command were
giving a threat assessment or at least
they'd been asked for a threat
assessment whether that's how you would
describe the product they delivered as
another question but will you alert to
the fact that this was a threat
assessment going from your people to the
privy Council Office in connection with
the invocation of the emergencies act
yeah like like I said I I don't recall
if Adriana briefed me beforehand and
when I'm looking at it they did produce
a product with regards to imves that I
see some of the paragraphs are coming
from that product so did she cut and
paste the information from product that
was already provided just to remind here
the key here the here are the key uh key
messages or or was it a completely
different one but uh yeah no so I
wouldn't be able to
to confirm if she'd brief me or other
than just being cc'd on a message but
I'm led to believe that it's a cut and
paste from the document that they had
produced in the past
okay well I think that's as far as as we
can take that unless you have in
retrospect any any was there any
follow-up by you after seeing this or
any further involvement of Ms polas in
this process that we should know about
uh no no okay thank you
now we'll we'll switch gears uh just
briefly though quite uh significantly uh
to talk about protests outside of Ottawa
and I'll just ask us all to remember
which means you can remind me too that
uh Deputy Commissioners LeBlanc is
waiting and we don't want to steal all
his Thunder uh talking about that work
of K division in Alberta but I just
wanted to talk briefly about uh
the work that the RCMP was involved in
with respect to the blockades and
protests outside of Ottawa
and the uh
the first of these I wanted to ask you
about was Windsor
and
in the interest of time we won't go
through the whole sequence of events
that led up to you getting involved in
Windsor but as I understand it you
received a request
for assistance in Windsor and can you
begin by telling me where that came from
that is from Windsor or from Opp or from
Ontario
I go ahead and I'll cover that
commissioner
um so no important note when that
request came in I was sharing an office
with Deputy Commissioner Chris Harkins
who's part of the goal command with me
and the request went uh to my knowledge
of request went directly in from Windsor
Police Service to our folks in Ontario
for a public order unit or a tactical
support group and with everything that
comes with it so the first deployment of
members and this was to assist with the
um with the blockade in Windsor we sent
a total of uh 64 members initially and
then another 50 members to help contain
the grounds once they started moving
with their tactical support group so and
it was led entirely by I believe the OPB
thinking OPP
thank you and
can you describe uh
some of the differences between the
assistance you were able to provide in
Windsor I'll say at that relatively
early date compared to the ultimate
deploy deployment of your public order
units in in
Ottawa a week or so later uh
why first of all one obvious thing is
you had units as I understand it
available in Ottawa who could be
redirected to Windsor is that correct
yes yeah that's correct so they didn't
have to be brought in from the other
side of the country that was just
logistically easier to do correct it is
and and faster because they're already
mobilized with all their equipment in
one single area right uh and uh
was there any difference in your
expectation of the ability to work with
and integrate the Windsor Police with
the Windsor Police Service and the opp
relative to the situation you're facing
in Ottawa that allowed you to
immediately deploy this unit to Windsor
I think what I'll mention what's
important to note is that early on the
opp commissioner
took uh control of all the public order
teams in the province and they would
decide what priorities were each public
order team would go because there was a
lot of things happening in different
areas so he sort of he had denounced and
I think actually you were Mike might
have been on a meeting at that time
where he talked to all the chiefs of
police in the or the majority of them
and said that he will be do not deploy
your public order teams we will decide
what the priority is and and we will
deploy as and when necessary so that
request came from Opp at the time there
was no active enforcement going on in
the Ottawa area so we felt because we
had a team that was originally from that
area although I and they might have even
been back in their area in in Ontario
that we could redeploy them to Windsor
and and at the time you made the
decision uh to that it was appropriate
to deploy the these uh resources to
Windsor
did the Windsor Police Service or the
opp have a plan for their uh deployment
or uh I mean of the same type that you
were waiting to see in Ottawa
uh we didn't get into the you know the
specifics of the plan the fact that the
opp commissioner was uh
um deploying the various
um public order units and the fact that
he was uh sort of taking the
not he was in charge of the what was
happening in Windsor
um and and they had this enforcement
plan we we had uh advised that we could
provide that public order team
so
so the absence of a plan
before the fact needn't be an obstacle
to you deploying or at least sending uh
resources to be deployed by another
police force well there's always like
even in the early days of the
Ottawa Convoy we gave you know 30 to 50
Resources with the idea that there was a
plan for those resources
but we didn't get into the intimacies of
the plan in in that instance nor did we
do that with the Windsor the fact that
they were going into enforcement we knew
that we knew that they had an
enforcement plan that they were going to
go what we call Kinetic and actually
move the protesters we knew there was a
plan so that's why that's a specific
type of resource it wasn't a Frontline
group that they were asking for they
were asking for a public order team for
enforcement purposes thank you I'll I'll
leave it to others to see if the that
should be pursued further I'll I'll just
ask you
um was this a situation in which Windsor
was a higher priority than Ottawa no
yeah
I should add though like
they were going into enforcement action
and on the ground in Ottawa they were
not so
I wouldn't ever say that one was a
higher priority than the other they were
just at different stages
right
um
I want to talk about move us over the
hump and talk about the operations the
RCMP post invocation we are gonna
Circle back on some orphan topics later
on but just keeping in chronological
order here
um
if the clerk could call up OPP four
zeros
sorry 50788
now this this is uh February 15th so the
emergencies act has been invoked but uh
enforcement action at least in Ottawa
hasn't uh
hasn't commenced on the level that
resulted in the clearing of the protest
but uh if you can uh
do I do you recognize these notes of uh
do you recognize do you remember the
meeting that these are notes of
um yeah vaguely remember the meeting yes
I I don't know these aren't any notes
I've seen before sorry I I vaguely
recall the meeting yes but I don't
recall the notes I did I wasn't given
these notes
um if you look at the first statement
there
you are attributed with saying uh and
I'll just ask you to for before I ask
any questions about a make sure I ask
you if you agree that this is what you
said
um we all need to succeed need to get
credibility and maximize the regs we are
here to help in any way we can
um
first of all is that
does that Accord with what you wrote
them or at least the message you
remember giving at that mass at that
meeting oh my goodness
I I don't think people appreciate the
amount of meetings we had I could have
very well said something to that effect
we were now going into enforcement that
was the beginning of the enforcement
stage so it was you know what this is
time for us as police to get credibility
back
um for not doing anything for many days
and we only need to succeed so let's
um you know use the rigs and and and
anything we can do to help it would sort
of been just a a little bit of a pep
talk but you know what to ask me if I
recall if that's exactly what I said I I
honestly couldn't tell you and and then
acknowledging that you're you're at the
limits of your recollection here uh the
expression that that I wanted to ask you
about was uh maximize the rigs and uh
can you tell us what you if that well
it's all about like I said reducing the
footprint so that when we go into
enforcement there's as few people as
possible so not because we had the uh
the invocation of the emergency act
let's not have people come into the uh
protest area let's make sure there's no
kids there let's make sure there's
um you know motivating and incentivizing
people to leave so that we can get
um down to the minimum amount of people
in the footprint so when we enforce it
will be much safer for everybody
involved
uh
and that was kind of the essence of the
plan
so if I can paraphrase we've been given
some new tools let's use them as fully
as we can
yeah if they obviously if they're
applicable and they're they're things
that we can use yes most definitely
thanks
and and Mr clerk if you could call up
now SSM NSC can
five zeros 408
.
this uh we will see when they come up uh
IRG minutes
and uh Mr clerk if you could scroll to
page seven
um and if I can go and draw your
attention uh commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner whichever of you might be
able to uh answer this question the left
sorry right hand column the first row so
where the word law enforcement in Ottawa
you see that
it says law enforcement Ottawa comma
have been able to secure perimeter
successfully without a need to employ
any designations through the EA
can you explain uh what that indication
there is
what what date is this
um this is the February 23rd IRG meeting
okay so so that would refer to on
February 18th the nearly hours of the
morning before activating our
operational plan we were able we I say
the gold silver bronze able to set up a
control access Zone uh which is a
perimeter uh and um
Ottawa Police Service had the lead on
that and used existing authorities when
they put it in so we did not use the ACT
specifically for for the control access
Zone they do it during the candidate
they did they do during other uh events
in Ottawa so they use existing uh
authorities to to uh to put the fence up
to put the perimeter up thank you that
that's very helpful
um
you're not going to get off the stand
without talking about tow trucks
uh so if I could just ask you a few
questions about that
um
as I understand it commissioner lucky uh
you were under the uh
measure regulations past pursuant to the
emergencies act empowered to instruct
tow truck operators to make their
services available but did you ever
yourself or did the RCMP ever exercise
that power in the province of Ontario no
we didn't I I delegated it to uh
commissioner Tom Creek
okay and if you can just help us
understand what that means you have the
power but you you are able to he says
you would have understood it lawfully
hand that power over to commissioner
Creek is that right yes I was allowed to
delegate it so in the event let's say we
didn't use it in RCMP jurisdiction but
if the command if Commanding Officer
Curtis the block he needed that
Authority I could have delegated it to
him which I I didn't because he things
were solved before that happened but um
because we were going into enforcement
action I delegated that authority to OPP
commissioner to the opp commissioner
um other than delegating that authority
to the commissioner of the opp were
there any other delegations you made of
that power
no and you didn't exercise it yourself
no
and so to the extent that power was used
at all it was used pursuant to the
delegation you gave to commissioner
Creek yes and this was primarily because
I have no knowledge of the tow truck
situation in Ontario each police agency
has that they know they have that
knowledge so for me to use that
Authority in a place where I have no
jurisdiction wouldn't make any sense so
I would have done the same in Quebec uh
if they had needed that because it's
we're not the police of jurisdiction
that makes sense
um
the the the the challenge that it poses
not not for you for for commission
council is that when we try to trace
what happened to that power you've
handed it down to commissioner karik and
so does that does that mean that you've
thereafter lose visibility of the use of
the power
oh I have no idea it's the first time
we've ever had that power so there
wasn't a Playbook on what to do with
that you know I delegated it uh to him
so that he could uh use that Authority
uh I would assume that
um they would take you know uh account
for that Authority
um but it wasn't we didn't have a
conversation I know there was an actual
delegation document I signed it may have
had some instruction there I can't
recall right I'm just wondering that
that delegation Authority did not it
seems include some requirement for the
opp commissioner to report back to you
on the extent to which he'd used those
Powers not to my knowledge
you well then I'll I'll ask you to bear
with me on the next question and see if
you can you can assist with it uh were
you aware at the time
there's been a lot of information since
but I'd like to know if you could try to
remember at the time
uh
were you was it your understanding at
the time that you delegated the power to
commissioner Creek that the opp had
already been able to uh secure the
assistance of some tow talk tow truck
operators without the need for the use
of that power I wasn't aware of any of
the details of the tow trucks okay so
you can't assist us with with that issue
as it relates to your delegated power no
um it was just if in fact they were
going to use that Authority I would I
delegated it to them it wasn't it wasn't
I wasn't sure if they would even use it
or not but it was delegated I was
assuming that they would need to use it
when you delegated the power let me see
if I can approach it this way when you
delegated the power were you aware that
one of the things that came along with
the exercise of that power was an
obligation on the part of the government
to compensate tow truck operators for
their work pursuant to orders yes okay
um
and has has that come back to you that
has the bill come back so to speak yes
okay and can you give us any information
about that
uh it was a big Bill it was a big Bill
um
have in the in the context of processing
that bill for example and I'll you'll
see why I'm trying to tease this out of
out of you and if you're not the right
person to answer it we'll just have to
live with that but uh were you
self-conscious of the fact that you were
giving the province a way to hand the
costs of the towing back to the federal
government
um under the emergency act yes yes you
realize that that was one of the
implications of giving them this power
yes and you probably realize that one of
the implications would be that whether
or not the power was needed to compel
the use of the tow trucks it would all
be processed that way so that the we
come so that the compensation could come
back up to the federal government well I
I assume that if they had to uh compel
tow trucks under the emergency act that
we would in fact the federal government
would pay for that but if they had the
ability to get the tow trucks on their
own that it wouldn't be under the
emergency act and we wouldn't be paying
for it and and and would it surprised
you then if some of the tow truck
operators decided to go the route where
they got paid by the feds and Ontario
decided to process it that way even
though they'd been secured before the
emergencies Act was declared I have no
idea okay I guess it's an Integrity
issue
thank you
um
Mr commissioner I do believe I'll finish
by lunch there's uh
one other issue I wanted to pursue or
there's a number of issues that are
going to have to fall off the agenda so
to speak uh here because of the time but
uh I I just there is one other issue one
other topic I wanted to explore before
we break for lunch if I may I realize
I'm a bit over my time but may I take
that
okay well yeah you're a bit over your
time but uh we'll let you go to lunch
um okay
what's priority in your
um
prioritizing here
um
Mr commissioner
yes
um is it possible that uh the
commission's council could be given more
time without taking away time
from parties
there was other records discovered last
night for example
being 113 pages of the Deputy
commissioner's notes that are extremely
important
I don't know if my friend is wanting to
deal with those I'm guessing he probably
does
subject any of the party's objections
as long as I didn't lose the 20 minutes
we have
I would be happy for my friend to keep
going it's a very important issue and
these Witnesses are probably two of the
most important Witnesses this commission
will hear from during this entire
proceeding
there was never a question of shortening
cross-examination time
as anyone goes over I don't take it from
anyone else unless there's been a
an agreed upon trade if you're willing
to give up your time to the commission
that's that would be the only way you
would lose it what I'm saying is is I
think the commission Council should be
given as long as he needs in order to
complete what he needs to complete not
remove things from his agenda that's all
I'm concerned about I I appreciate Mr
Miller's concern and Mr commissioner
I'll say to you and and through you to
Mr Miller we though those notes did just
go up
on that particular database commission
council did have access to those notes
and as a matter of fact I'd recommend to
parties that they review the interview
of Deputy Commissioner Dum the the
witness summary as it's called because
that summary was specifically for the
purpose of pursuing those notes so with
that in mind Mr Miller might be able to
focus his conversation on the parts of
those notes that he considered is
important to you
okay thank you
um
if we could pull up
the team's chat
which is at uh PB NSC cans four zeros 80
40.
and uh we're gonna have to ask you uh
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner to
try and
recreate this in your memory again
acknowledging that a lot was happening
at this time it's February 12th putting
the
time stamps five hours ahead
it's uh
earlier in the morning at the beginning
but when we go down to page two we'll
see a time stamp for uh
Mr Kirk can you scroll down to page two
uh timestamp for
uh
a heading a heading to suggest that
there is going to be a meeting with uh
Mr slowly can you just scroll through
till we find that yeah there we go so
you you are advised uh uh commissioner
in the course of this team's chat that
you are going to have a meeting with
uh Chief slowly uh at 2 p.m and if we go
down to page five of this document
at 6 37 in the time stamp so I think 137
in real time
uh
now we're all going to have to contend
with this none of us gets to see what's
behind the black well you did at the
time but you're not going to tell us now
I wouldn't remember
um but you come in at 6 37 uh with this
statement disregard as OPP commissioner
advises there is a pretty
straightforward way
in that the minister goes to the Ontario
police commission
can you tell us what you were talking
about there
I would be
sheer speculation
I honestly don't I would say that it's
about
um talking about if and
if they needed to go to the Ontario
I don't even know Ontario police
commission in In fairness to let me let
me take just some more of this and maybe
when you see some more context you'll be
reminded of what that statement about Mr
clerk can we
uh take the take us down to page 16 of
this chat
and there's the statement I don't get it
I didn't get it and
I'll read that out if this is you you uh
commissioner Lockheed speaking
uh I don't get it
are they going to the province or not
regarding PS which you'll probably agree
with me as a reference to Peter slowly
um no it could be I didn't get it I
don't know if they're talking about the
mission statement I didn't get it
that's how I'm sorry I didn't get it
correctly yeah in other words you didn't
hear what they were talking about or you
didn't understand what they were talking
about or I didn't I I'm looking at the
mission the modifications of okay
mission statement
um
am I saying I didn't get it I didn't get
the mission statement I'm not sure are
they going to the province or not
resorting
I see
um
can you scroll uh yes please Mr please
scroll up to help the commissioner if I
can jog something in my memory and and
maybe scroll along so that she can
follow
the context of the point that I just put
to her integrated planning
so can you scroll down a little further
I'm not sorry down so she can follow
them
I don't know it
what he means by the modification is
simply at the high political element of
the plan
I didn't get it
um can you keep going
I am honestly I I have no idea what that
oh me like I I I can understand what
some of the comments mean but I don't
know the context
I I can't seem to put it into a contact
so you you can't recall
what uh the people you're listening to
you again your your
uh
as I understand it here listening to the
IRG meeting of the 12th and you are
somebody is talking and and that prompts
you to wonder whether they are going to
The Province or not regarding if that PS
is Peter slowly regarding Peter slowly
and that that doesn't trigger your
memory about what you were hearing that
prompted you to say that no not at all
okay I'm trying to put it together
that's that's fair enough uh and if we
go down to the scroll a little bit
further
we see the words maybe I tell him
I think
uh scroll up please Mr Clark so
commissioner Lockheed can see the lead
into this comment thank you
a little up further so she can see what
they need to land okay so again this is
a continuation of the discussion you
just saw
okay
and then scroll down please Clerk
something we need to land then you say
maybe I tell him and scroll down further
and yay or nay perhaps you're asking
your team what they think
and then Mark Flynn says maybe a
one-on-one face to face with the
minister
and then Deputy Commissioner here you
come in and say agree and the PM
so I'm guessing that this is something
pretty important because what is being
proposed here is that you commissioner
Lockheed meet face to face with the
minister
uh and perhaps the PM I think this is
about something completely different oh
well no I think uh and I'm not sure but
I think it's about Coots actually it's
about Coots
that that uh
answers that uh thank you for clarifying
that one last topic then in the five
minutes that I might have with the
commissioner's Indulgence could we go to
OPP four zeros 4583
this is a long document and perhaps Mr
clerk if you can find page 52
and the these texts have already been
canvassed uh somewhat in the hearing uh
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner but
this might be the first time you've
looked at them in recent memory can you
scroll down to the point where
uh
commissioner Creeks says with respect to
your comments
there we go
so
again to orient ourselves as I read this
the green is is commissioner Creek and
the blue is you
uh and
this uh
do you recollect this exchange and I'll
ask the clerk to scroll down so that she
can read the rest of her input to this
yes and that's that's you commissioner
lucky saying if if you have some no
sorry I mean that's commissioner if
saying to you if you commissioner
Lockheed have some influence it would be
helpful and then could you scroll down a
little further
before
and here you are telling uh
the commissioner that when you say had
DM Stuart are you is that you saying
that I commissioner Lucky had Deputy
Minister Stewart reach out to that am I
reading that correctly yeah because this
is up three hours later or four hours
later yeah so that's how I before I even
saw that that's how I figured because
um Deputy Minister Stewart was uh
speaking regularly to the
Ottawa city manager
so yes that's what it refers to I asked
I asked Deputy Minister Stewart if he
could reach into
Steve and I won't try to pronounce his
last name he was a city manager yeah
kennel office sorry okay that's the
Steve k
um because uh obviously we didn't want
to lose continuity we were just now
ready to uh do put implement the plan
the integrated Command Center was going
to take that integrated plan and
implement it so it was important that we
didn't since Peter Chief slowly wasn't
there and she the deputy chief Bell had
been involved with the plan and and uh
and ready and knew about the plan to
have somebody new come in because there
was talk rumors I guess that's they may
bring somebody new in and that would
delay us going into enforcement action
so we were hoping that one of the
deputies that didn't well Steve was the
obvious choice because he was taking the
lead it could have been uh Deputy Trish
McPherson I think Ferguson that could
also have taken the place but we knew
that it was he was going to be the
deputy he was a senior Deputy so so the
upshot is you and commissioner Creek are
talking here about your hope that the
new chief of police will be someone
who's already be part of the command
structure no it wasn't a boat who would
be the new chief of police I phrased
that wrongly I didn't mean that yeah the
the new person in charge of the office
interim by interim would be somebody
that was already in place by de facto it
was Steve Bell but it was could have
been Joe Schmo it was whoever was
already understood you wanted to
continue U.N commissioner continuity
with the work that have been done I
understand that the question I have
though is so understanding the the sort
of logic of the proposition
you you mentioned earlier both in the
context of these proceedings here and
other proceedings you've been in the the
division between church and state did
were any red flags going off in your
mind when uh this
dialogue took place between you and
commissioner karik that you would go to
Canada's Deputy minister of Public
Safety who would go to
an official in the city of Ottawa
to exercise influence about who would be
the next interim Chief it wasn't about
who was it
Deputy Minister Stewart had I never
talked to uh Steve at all he had uh they
had had communication regular
communication for me it was about the
relationship that they they had already
established and that because we were on
the verge of enforcement that it was
only about can we continue on with the
enforcement plan under existing
Personnel personnel and that was the
goal of that it wasn't about put Deputy
Commissioner Steve Bell in that position
so he can be the chief it wasn't
influencing them on who was going to be
the chief just the continuity of the
plan because that would have set us back
if we had to brief somebody new and put
somebody new in the position
um
I didn't I didn't look at it in in the
eyes that you're looking at it no no
acknowledging that that in for the
reasons we discussed before and your
structure in relationship to the people
you report to you wouldn't have been
familiar perhaps with the way that uh
uh the Ottawa Police Services uh
takes its direction uh but did it didn't
occur to you when you were putting in
place this communication from your
Deputy minister to an official a senior
official at the city of Ottawa that an
option would have been if such an
approach to be me were to be made about
the importance of continuity that it
would have been better placed to the
Police Services Board
um yeah like I said I didn't know how
how their structure worked at all it was
just a connection into Ottawa Police
or or that's the person that was that
they were dealing with I didn't
understand the board concept if I can
summarize you had an important message
to deliver which was that continuity and
command was important and you used a
connection that you knew about to
deliver that message yeah just that it
would be preferable But ultimately the
decision
Theirs to do what they wish but we were
on the verge of enforcement and it would
be preferable if we had somebody who was
already in the chair knowing what the
plan was so that we could move forward
because it was literally um what was
this the 16th which is on the uh
Wednesday we were full-blown going into
the plan and to stop that and knowing
that the weekend was coming we had
changed that plan was originally
supposed to be a four-day engagement
um plan into enforcement but because we
had a late start on it we only had two
or three days before the weekend was
coming so time was not on our side
right and so so the the message makes
sense and and as I say the path you took
you took simply because it was a
connection you knew already existed
between Stuart and Cadillac yes exactly
okay
thank you Mr Krishna those are my
questions for this panel
okay so thank you uh so we'll take the
lunch break and come back at two o'clock
the commission is in recess until two
o'clock
thank you
oh
foreign
hey good afternoon
oh okay we're ready to go then go ahead
for the record my name is Brendan Miller
I'm counsel to Freedom Corp which is the
corporation an entity that represents
the protesters that were in Ottawa in
January and February of 2022. uh first
both of you thank you for your service
and uh thank you for testifying here
today
so I just want to begin by doing sort of
a housekeeping matter from yesterday but
I'm going to use you folks to do that if
I can bring up document
ssm.can.000283 underscore well dot zero
zero zero one
laughs
okay and you had said in your evidence
in Chief uh commissioner lucky that
the RCMP in Ottawa also dealt with the
safety security
Etc uh for international diplomats from
foreign countries is that fair
Okay so yesterday we heard evidence
from the assistant Deputy Minister
security and emergent management at
Global Affairs Canada and she testified
that they were concerned about the
security and safety of foreign diplomats
in Ottawa and this document is a
February 4th email if we can scroll down
please
uh from Bill McCrimmon uh deputy
director of Diplomatic Security and
Outreach programs with GAC it's a global
Affairs Canada are you familiar with Mr
McCrimmon
no right and if you just want to take a
moment I'll I'll read it to you but in
that email he States on February 4th the
office of protocol has not been made
aware officially of any significant
concerns by The Diplomatic community in
the national capital region could you
just read a little floor please
linked to current ongoing demonstrations
downtown Ottawa the RCMP protective
operation assessment unit advised that
there is no particular concern at this
time for the Diplomatic Community some
foreign missions have requested that the
RCMP conduct security assessments
however no specific concerns have been
identified several missions having
formally raised issues and
inconveniences with the chief of
protocol that have been affecting their
operations related to limited access to
buildings block streets noise impeding
their work and the odor of diesel fumes
the office of protocol in Brackets
Diplomatic Security liaison unit close
brackets remains in contact with the
RCMP and will advise of any significance
concerns affecting the Diplomatic
mission
and can you agree that as of February
4th that was the assessment also of your
office
uh I'd have to see our assessment but if
if he's saying that the RCMP said that
right and I I take it that though this
is February 4th uh this situation as
described here remained the same
throughout the whole protest that it not
I I can't speak for sure I don't have
any of the documents okay and yesterday
the assistant Deputy Minister she
couldn't give us any other information
other than a blanket statement with no
evidence or information so is it fair to
say that if there was actual evidence or
information excuse me I don't think that
that's a fair description of the
evidence that was provided by the
witnesses I'll rephrase it so would you
say then that you would have no more
further information with respect to
specifics than the assistant Deputy
Minister did yesterday
I don't know what the assistant Deputy
Minister said yesterday but what I can
say is I would have to look at the RCMP
threat assessment documents or any of
the requests to know what the the threat
environment was throughout the Convoy
just to be fair okay now commissioner
lucky I'm going to ask some pointed
questions on the next following set now
commissioner lucky can you agree that
under the RCMP Act
it doesn't provide sufficient
independence from political executive
and political interference from your
office is that fair
well I assume it does but others don't
right and you know that from your
appointment as commissioner under
Section Five of the RCMP act that
appointment is what's referred to at
pleasure you understand that yes and you
understand that that means that the
government Council on a recommendation
from the political executive the Prime
Minister cabinet uh can remove you at
any time at will without a reason right
and this is different than what's
referred to as an appointment of good
behavior you understand what that is
yes not intimately but and an
appointment of good behavior you at
least understand requires actual grounds
of misconduct to remove you kind of like
a judge
right you get that yes right and for
example I take it you're aware of the
former snc lavalin uh Jody Wilson
raybold Scandal uh with respect to the
director of public prosecution Services
of Canada
um they that public prosecution Services
director you're aware that they're
appointed at good behavior they're not
subject to being removed at will you're
aware of that no okay and
you understand I understand you have an
understanding of the snc lava when Jody
Wilson raybould Scandal though do you
not yes right and the issue with that
was is that the political executive
trying to use uh Miss raible Wilson uh
essentially tried to skirt the act with
respect to advising prosecution services
on how to conduct themselves is that
fair
ah yes I guess okay I'm not intimately
familiar with right and the problem with
that was is that act uh you know that
any direction from the political
executive via the Minister of Justice
the Attorney General
um that seeks to compel the director of
public prosecution services to do
something it has to be through the
legislative process and then whatever
they direct them has to be published in
a Gazette within six months are you
aware of that no all right
and you agree that your office of
commissioner has no such safeguards does
it
no
and you know that the common law in
policing is that you as commissioner and
other Chiefs of police
throughout the country and the common
law world really are to be 100
independent from the political executive
yes
and you agree with me that the political
executive I would say though we do get
direction on the administration side of
the policing but not the operational
side right and you can agree with me
that the political executive should not
be placing undue pressure on you or
directing you what to do with respect to
policing other than the administration
part yes right
and it's not true it's true and I'm not
trying to poke but it's public knowledge
that previously the political executive
has asked you to do certain things in
investigations such as release
information that could undermine an
investigation you remember that
you'll have to be more specific of what
you're referring to you agree that
happened when you're asked by federal
ministers to release the form of
firearms the RCMP and Nova Scotia new or
used in the mass shooting while the
investigation was ongoing
remember
but what are you referring to
specifically I'm referring to the issue
with respect to releasing the forms of
firearms for the purpose of furthering
the legislation there is no pressure to
do that right and but the minister asked
you to do it no the minister asked me if
in fact the information about the
Firearms would be part of a media
release right and when he didn't ask me
to put that in there right and when it
wasn't there's the transcript in the
recording with respect to that that you
had said to some of your colleagues why
couldn't this have been done the
minister asked for a small ask why
wasn't it done and that's not the
context in which that was taken okay now
I take it that uh would you agree that
the executive branch of the federal
government
both yourself and and you Deputy
Commissioner they tried to tell you what
action to take during the protest didn't
they
sorry they asked us to what they tried
to tell you what actions to take in
policing during the protest absolutely
not did they not ask you they wanted you
to take it over
no right so the clerk of the privy
Council
and you uh assistant commissioner did
not have a phone call on February 3rd
2022 recorded in your notes
where they said that we need to take
this over
yeah but but saying it and doing it is
two different things right can I take
you uh can we please bring up a document
pb.nsc.can.0008073 underscore Rel dot
zero zero zero one
and then
okay now this is a copy of your notes
sir
um there's been a few there's two copies
of your notes the one that my friends
had been referring to in your summary
statement
so you're aware that's document 8073
this is the other set or it's that was
document eight zero seven four there's
another set and there's some
highlighting that you've made in these
notes and I'm going to take you to it
beginning first
we'll go right to the February 3rd note
which is on my apologies
I believe it's 19. if we can go to page
19 please
all right so we'll begin at the top that
says February 3rd that's the note for
the day if we can scroll down
a second here
foreign
just keep going oh
I can just have a moment
sure
and so just for your understanding this
was the record we found that was
deposited over the weekend that's why
I'm having a little trouble navigating
it
thank you
okay
great there's actually a second one it's
on page 19.
I believe
that's the men's call
well we'll start with this one and this
is The Minister's call
at
and scroll up
right so 12 30 and that's The Minister's
call and I take it that uh the master of
Public Safety and the minister of
emergency preparedness is on that call
with you
uh I would have to check the minutes but
I just have ministers called normally
you would be Minister melanchino
sometimes algebra and I see Blair a
little further down that's correct right
so uh and there it states question
mendocino's observations
and non-policing response seeing uh way
more or seeing way can you tell me what
that says in way more traffic
um
can't make out the last word all right
and way more traffic
and uh does not seem to be a plan
uh must start with enforcement so it
tells you that
yeah right and then Bill Blair of course
that's the ministry of emergency uh
preparedness he's the former Chief of
Police of Toronto is that correct
uh that's correct and he says the PM is
increasingly concerned about how the
city will deal with this is that right
according to my notes uh correct right
and so you agree that you know as a
police officer you're trained to take
notes right yeah and you take notes of
the conversations and investigations
contemporaneously to the investigation
correct and you write down relevant
material matters that you want to
remember
later in time right key points that I
want to remember brief up right so it's
fair to say that these things that you
wrote down this is what was said to you
by those two ministers correct
yeah okay and if we can scroll down to
the next page please
and this was already put in the other
set of notes but there I see that uh
Minister Mendocino he says to you that
his colleagues feel unsafe going to the
hill
they feel is that harassed yeah yeah
short handwritten yeah and then what is
it uh the second uh concern of Ottawa uh
Central citizens essential care
counter protest outer protests right
okay
so if we can keep scrolling down
actually I think I've understand uh why
I had it wrong the date I had with
respect to when you had the meeting with
the clerk of the privy council is
actually the ninth
so I'm going to take you down to
February 9th
let me just find that there
foreign
page 41.
or yeah so at the top there you see
that's the date the 9th and it says call
with clerk 800 and that's the clerk of
the privy council is that correct I
would assume so right and they you were
there flushing out financials uh
financial compensation employees
business and PS are you referring there
as Peter slaly or Public Safety
uh let me just read it here
I'm not quite sure if that was Public
Safety or Peter slowly well it says
guessing if it was the clerk is because
it's Public Safety right so feels
organized
um what's that word right after the
period you know Ambassador Bridge
Ambassador Bridge uh one just read it
out for me
um feel organized Ambassador Bridge
stretched OPP incremental success so PS
working at incremental very small things
Chief 48 76 hours to gather the troops
right so at the time at least in
February 9th I'd take it that you
thought the Ops was doing an okay job is
that fair
uh that would remind me of that date
that's February 9th
uh not necessarily saying that they were
doing a good job right but they were
making incremental uh well that's that's
what we've been shared right but still
it was difficult to to understand what
those
incremental gains were very small things
that were done and the clerk responded
to you that we need to take this over do
they know what this means
uh no and I'm not quite sure there's
probably other people on the line I just
said the clerk said we need to take this
over and not necessarily speaking to me
rarely do I brief the clerk alone uh we
need to take this over do they know what
this means and and again I think there's
a lack of understanding of how it works
when you're looking at jurisdiction when
a comment like that is made just like
women right right but the the clerk of
the privy council is the highest ranking
civil servant in the civil servant the
entire Federal apparatus right they're
the equivalent in provinces as What's
called the DM the deputy Minister she
she answers to the Prime Minister and
the Prime Minister alone
right my understanding and so on
February 9 she's telling you that the
federal government and yourselves the
RCMP have to take over
okay
and
then we'll scroll back up to the top if
I can I'm just going to go through this
in order
uh if we could go to page 11
so if you scroll down there
and this is another briefing to the
ministers is that right
I see Minister's brief uh 1300 hours
three points yet
is that not what you're informing them a
police operational plan
I am they are being briefed on
discussions that we've been having with
Ops so that Ops would share with us so
um one of the concerns the commissioner
said earlier how is this going to end
when it's going to end was asked
frequently for anything we had on the
planning side would brief up to the
ministers to to inform them that there
is something that we don't always have
access to but there's discussions that
there's plans ongoing
right and is it not fair to say that
throughout this protest that the
political executive and the executive
branch of the federal government
were asking you for operational plans
and even asking you to give the
operational plans of the Ops to them
so I will defer to the commissioner on
this one but my dealings with the deputy
ministers and the ministers never once
that they asked for the operational plan
okay they we kept them updated on the
work that's been done commissioner not
quite sure we were never asked to give
any operational plans we did brief
generally that there was a plan
um but we never
went into the I didn't get briefed on
the plan until uh February 10th I think
it was or February 11th but we didn't
ever give them they never asked for the
plan and can I take you down now to page
25.
and if we can just go to the top page 25
the first thing what meeting is this
pre-meet SBE what date is that uh this
is from
the fifth
okay so it's pre-mute SSE assistance
with Alberta probably key things that we
had to uh look at for the for the
premium with SSE
um I I'm not sure if it was internally
or with uh Deputy ministers uh I'm not
sure right and if we can just scroll
down to where it starts with OPP
and it states here that OPP offered its
legal expert worked ipper wash hearing
that the Ops is priority
for political reasons
so
is that the offer from Opp they offered
the RCMP legal counsel because of
political interference concerns they had
no not at all that what that was is
trying to muster the people together
that had the expertise that had the
knowledge to have worked on several uh
key uh incidents and in this case is the
result of what came out of the upper
wash inquiry to help them right and
that's to help the RCMP no is to help
the Ops Auto Police Service okay so we
were an assistance to Ottawa Police
Service right and so the opp
had relayed to you that they had
concerns with political interference
yeah I'm not quite sure why I put the
pivoting for political reasons I'm not
quite sure why I put it there well the
upper wash the upper wash proceeding was
about that partly and it's like one of
the main things and as I understand it
one of the main reasons that the
political executive in Ontario wouldn't
get involved in this matter because it
was against the principal set down in
amperwash and police Independence so the
opp is offering legal experts to deal
with police Independence
and so what why would they do that if
they didn't have a concern with
political interference sir so I'm not
aware fully aware of the upper wash I
didn't read the report and what I can
say is that what was offered there from
the opp was just assistance with third
person who worked on the Empire inquiry
for Lessons Learned that's all I can say
I I can't go in for because of political
reasons all I know is they were offering
up resources for to test this
you're over your time already so sir
there's there is this is 113 pages of
notes I I would like a little bit of
extra time these notes were not dealt
with in the statement of the witness
because there's a they are a different
set than the ones that the commission
had dealt with which is eight zero seven
four uh these were not uploaded or
provided to the parties until
Remembrance Day and we found them last
night and I understand the commission
wasn't able in my view to deal with
these issues only because they were
using another set of notes and these
notes are a contemporaneous outline and
timeline of this witness's evidence of
what happened they are extraordinarily
relevant material and I would ask leave
to be able to finish the examination
they are the same notes I believe as the
other set of notes there's just a bit of
highlighting but it's the same text as I
understand it but now any event There
are 16 other people who want to question
this panel and it's a matter of
organizing your exam the
I should say I didn't interrupt when you
were examining about the proceedings in
Nova Scotia but right that was not
exactly relevant for this hearing right
if I could take then if I could ask this
I'll finish up
um
if we could go to page 38 of this
document
and so this is uh another meeting if we
can scroll down
and it says 12 35 M3 I take it that's uh
Marco um medicinal that's the ministry
you call him M3 yep okay and uh there
he's discussing uh about changing the
posture when it comes to provincial
engagement and what OPP contribute and
then Blair goes on that it doesn't show
uh how the chief will essentially base
it on not having a plan in his opinion
the chief is not going the chief of the
Ops is not going to get the resources uh
that he requires from the province is
that fair and you scroll up before that
before the minister Blair uh minister
mangino
okay
and the question sorry uh so is he
saying there to you that the plan from
Ops it uh is such that the chief will
not receive the resources he needs from
other Ontario Police Services that's
what he tells you
correct all right and if we can scroll
down to the next page please
uh who is the individual uh right there
with Seamus it says concentrated effort
to make this country look bad start to
midterms who is that who is Seamus for
the minister o Reagan Minnesota Reagan
okay so he tells you that I take it that
the Convoy and the protesters are a
concentrated effort to make the country
look bad
that's what I wrote down on comments
that were made yeah okay
and I'm almost finished sir
if we could please
uh go down to page 45 please
and scroll down and there you highlight
that the president will be calling the
PM pressure to seek additional resources
um is that who relayed that to you
that was in the call of the pressure to
release additional resources that's
something that I that I put down in the
sense that it was in relation to the
Windsor bridge where there's uh there's
concerns with the duration of the
blockade and I just put down seek
additional resources uh ready to give to
give to give the assistance required for
it so right and then just to page 49
please
if we can scroll down
so this is uh the meeting from the 10th
of February uh with the ministers
briefing again that's uh the minister of
Public Safety the minister of emergency
preparedness and I take it that the
minister of Public Safety states to you
that the Intel they're getting is not
sufficiently timely is not sufficient or
timely and to stop the protests and
setting this up uh view uh what is the
plan and uh different uh for Convoy can
you read that last sentence there uh
different phases coming to the
realization that we're not responding
fast enough and what minister manichino
is alluding to is we had these slow
rolls more specifically in the province
of Ontario that without having the right
information they were able to set up
before we we even knew that they were
going to do so and then Minister Blair
canvases you question if exercise some
jurisdictional change
is that speaking to the policing you're
taking on a role is that fair
I'm not I'm not uh it doesn't ring a
bell okay and if we can scroll down then
just to the next page
and this is the Intel overview
um is this your words here or is it
somebody else's can you just go up for a
sec
um
that would be from someone else okay and
is it from oh it says OPP on the side
would that would be fair say that's
commissioner Morris that would have been
the meeting uh I wrote down OPP in oacp
a meeting that I believe is a meeting
with the um that was chaired by the
commissioner of the opp with
representatives of the Ontario
Association Chiefs the Police
Association all right and was there
anyone from the federal government at
that meeting
uh other than the RCMP was present I'm
not aware of uh anyone else okay and the
intelligence that commissioner Morris
provided you there is similar to what
he's testified about for this commission
was that these were normal people and
they were essentially resentment to the
Trudeau government for covid measures in
multiple groups
Etc right
yeah okay
and
so can I take you down to this is
February 11th okay you're gonna have to
wrap up I've been so
I will go then
right to
if you can go to page
the one with I believe it's the 13th you
actually had notes of the IRG meetings
65 if we go to 65 please
well 64 first
and there Minister Blair discusses
throwing Ottawa under the bus
that was your note
uh that was my note correct all right
and I take it when you sing Ottawa he's
talking about the Ottawa Police Service
is that fair it's not the city of Ottawa
correct right so his plan
on that date is he's intending to throw
Ottawa under the bus being the Ops for
any failures that have been dealt with
with respect to policing is that fair he
could have made a comment during the
meeting saying that he was not satisfied
with the work that's been done by Ottawa
Police Service okay and then can I just
take you to most of these notes and not
word for word what was said something
it's just a quick recap of and if I can
take you up to uh page 62 please
and there you wrote comment PM I take it
that that's the prime minister
and it says regarding RCMP they haven't
done anything
yeah that was in reference to the
overall blockades that were taken across
that was going on across the country
there was
um there was some uh
they were not displeased but uh did not
understand the flow of speed and flow
and what it takes when you're dealing
with a demo and that came across that
they were not happy with how we were
handling the different demos right and
this would be the last note so uh page
67 please
and this is from the 14th at nine
o'clock this is the National Security
intelligence advisor that you're meeting
with I take it that's correct right and
that's Jody Thomas at the time yes it
was Jody Thomas right and I take it
there that uh for whatever reason you're
recording uh what she's saying uh
and they're on one of the points
measures put out draconian
uh they will turn to us everyone is
using their Authority that's been given
RCMP taking advantage of authority
what is what was that about yeah I'm not
quite sure what I uh what I meant by
that tell you truth measures putting out
sure
right and from the and just for you
commissioner lucky uh in ending this
it is the fact that excuse me um you're
not giving the witness a chance to read
the notes he said he's not what sure
what it says and he's trying to read it
and you're moving on to something else
right so if you're going to ask the
question the witness questions then let
him have a chance please I can wait go
ahead yeah no I don't have any more
comments on that I'm reading it and I'm
not quite sure what it was meant that's
how I understood uh the evidence as well
so commissioner lucky you were present
for both the February 13th IRG as well
as the February 14th cabinet meeting
e
yes I think there was the cabinet
meeting was on the 13th and well yeah
yeah and so the IRG meeting they
according to the text messages and the
messages that uh we've reviewed they
never even asked you to speak
um not on the definitely not at the
cabinet meeting and I don't I what I did
do I don't think I spoke it either
um I I thought I did because I had
speaking notes but I did brief the
minister before that meeting right and
the minister never asked you what your
opinion was with respect to whether or
not there was a section to cease and Sac
security threat is that correct
in respect to whether or not there was a
threat under section two as defined in
the thesis act if there was a threat to
the security of Canada no he would have
to ask thesis right and thesis you're
aware told him that there wasn't
that's what I've been told so you're
gonna have to thank you those are my
questions okay thanks
next is the Ontario Provincial Police
good afternoon commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner my name is Chris Diana I'm
counsel for the opp
we've heard some evidence from
commissioner karik that the commissioner
he worked very closely with you
throughout the the Convoy time period is
that correct yes and we've seen some of
the tax exchanges between you and him so
is it fair to say that you either spoke
with him or texted with him pretty much
every day during the course of this
event very often yes
and it's fair to say that you worked
together to help support former Chiefs
slowly and trying to manage the Ottawa
event correct yes
and in particular commissioner karique
had probably more kind of one-on-one
dealings with uh Chiefs Foley than you
did is that fair yes
and ultimately your Mutual cooperation
with commissioner karik helped lead to
the to the development of the integrated
planning team is that fair yes where
both provided subject matter experts to
make sure that there was a way to
resolve the Ottawa
occupation is that fair yeah that was
our goal
now I believe it's in your the
institutional report that at no point
did you ever ask for the invocation of
the emergencies act correct correct uh
but you did you were asked though what
tools would be useful correct yes so
we've already seen that document but I
want to bring it up again so if we can
look at
pb.nsc Dot c-a-n
four zeros three two five six
please
all right now we've seen this already
today if we can scroll to the bottom and
see what the Genesis of this was it's an
email from Mike Jones who I understand
is the chief of staff for Minister
Mendocino is that correct yes and this
is sent to you February 13th at 7 25 pm
and there's a section that's blocked out
there I'm not entirely sure why the
reason for the reduction is not entirely
made clear but my understanding is that
you were asked to speak about two things
you were asked to give
some information on what tools would be
useful and you were also asked
questions about critical infrastructure
is that correct yes I believe so
and as you can see obviously there was a
timing was important here
because as it says uh quick follow-ups
before cabinet now what was your
understanding of when that cabinet
meeting would take place
um
well 7 25 PM I thought I I'm sure I
think the cabinet meeting was that night
so
sorry I didn't can't hear you I think
that cabinet meeting was that night so
I'm not sure I thought it would have
already been
um in progress or obviously it wasn't
I'm not sure what time the cabinet
meeting was that day okay but regardless
your understanding was that this was a
very time sensitive request is that fair
everything was time sensitive yes sure
so we can scroll to the top
we'll see that you responded
at I guess 12 47 a.m so approximately
five hours later is that correct
I'm not sure this is one of those cases
where you need to subtract five subtract
five yeah oh thank you so I was gonna
say I'm never up past 10 o'clock so I I
advised I would have responded I I had
figured that issue out for the text
messages but okay so that applies to
this as well then for the if we scroll
to the bottom
I just want to make sure I'm clear on
the time so that says 7 25 PM is that
actually 7 25 PM or is it yeah yes it's
only where it has the plus zero zero
zero zero oh yes so in the same email
exchange we've got two different ways to
figure it's usually just the top email
you have to do it on all right okay well
thank you that's very complicated
all right so then let's go to the top so
the email was sent from Mike Jones 725
and your response is
at 7 47 then would that be so you
responded almost right away right away
yeah okay so I take it that in that time
period you clearly wouldn't have had an
opportunity to consult with other law
enforcement agencies about what tools
might be useful is that correct no we
had already consulted within our
organization to the commanding officers
I I'm not sure if we were able to
consult outside of the RCMP because of
uh cabinet confidence
okay well I want to get to that and yeah
but let's backtrack a little bit because
I want to ask about the initial request
from Mike Jones you were being asked for
advice on what tools would be useful was
it your sense when you got received that
email and either from that email from
conversations you had around the same
time that they were waiting on your
advice on these issues or was it your
sense that they'd already made up their
mind that they were going to invoke it
I'm not sure what they were thinking
um but just given the time it was very
quick turnaround I would not have put
that together off the top of my head I
would have got that information that
information was already established if
you look it's quite detailed I wouldn't
have just been typing that off the top
of my head I would have got it from
somebody and the fact that it was so
quickly afterwards I I think that
information was already in the in the
queue somewhere else yeah I wanted to
ask about that because I haven't and
there are a lot of documents thousands
of documents and maybe I've missed it
but do you recall how that information
came to you this would have come through
my people probably uh
um I would have cast that through to uh
Deputy Commissioner Mike Durham they
would have uh gone to the especially the
commanding officers in BC Alberta and
Manitoba were three of the big protests
in our jurisdiction were because they
would have they were dealing with the
protests and we wanted to know what
authorities might be useful if they did
invoke the act all right now we've heard
from commissioner karik and he was very
clear in his evidence that at no point
did anyone from the RCMP reached out to
him to ask him for his advice on what
tools would be useful and you have no
reason to dispute that no I was actually
kind of surprised because in my mind I
thought that we had but um obviously if
he says that then we probably didn't
right and so if he and he said it very
clearly I can bring up the transcript if
you wish but no no I and certainly
there's no documentary evidence to
suggest that you ever consulted with him
but you would agree I take it that
because the opp was involved kind of as
a lead in Windsor they were very
involved in leading the integrated
planning team in Ottawa there were
issues all throughout Ontario that the
opp had an important interest in what
tools to be made available to it correct
yeah absolutely
and that in retrospect would you agree
that it would have been a good idea to
have consulted with commissioner Curry
so he could have given you his opinion
on what may have been helpful and and
like I said I didn't um
if I did not obviously according to uh
commissioner karik uh consult with him
but I I in my mind I thought there was
consultation done with OPP and Ops not
at my level
um because I wasn't doing the
consultation in my own organization that
some other people were doing that but I
I assumed wrongly obviously that when I
asked for a consultation with the
various agencies that that was that they
were included in that unless we weren't
uh allowed to do that yeah and the
reason I find it odd is because you know
you would communicate with them by text
by phone call you could have simply just
picked up the phone and said well Tom I
just got this email uh you know keep it
on the down low but because we don't
because there are confidence is involved
here but are there any tools that the
OBP would find useful here no I assumed
this list was was the consultation of of
police that's honestly I thought this
this list where it came through my my
like obviously my chain of command but I
assumed that that was part and parcel of
consultation right so somewhere there
was a breakdown in the communication OBP
should have been consulted but they
weren't unless there was reasons why
they couldn't I'm not sure okay and I
know that whether it's you or the deputy
I think they mentioned there were two
possible factors one was timing but of
course that could have been done very
quickly with your relationship with
commissioner correct yes and the other
issue was was a matter of confidence but
we all know when policing that
confidential information between Police
Services is shared and I take it that
you would have trusted commissioner
Creek enough to have that conversation
with him correct um it depends like
cabinet confidence is quite uh like
policing information is one thing but
because it's our information so I can
say that I can share that but when it's
not my information I'm I'm I'm not at
Liberty to share right but you could
have done it another way you could have
said
commissioner
there's some consideration about the
emergencies act yeah so what are your
and so I don't because you would
mentioned the emergencies act several
days before
so you could have said that as a
hypothetical if cabinet was to invoke
the EA are there any tools
that would be useful you could have done
that right
yeah I absolutely could have
except I might be breaching cabinet
confidence so I don't know if I would
have okay but you referenced emergencies
act possibility I forget the day maybe
it was February 5th yeah and back then I
called it the emergency measures act I
didn't even know what it was right
now I might Circle back to this I want
to make sure I don't run out of time to
make sure I get a couple of my points in
here I'd like to go to Towing very
painfully and I've heard your evidence
that you weren't directly involved in
that aspect but I think you know there's
been some back and forth and some
question but there's a document that I
think needs to go into the record that I
need to put to you that I think will
help clarify the issue do you know the
name Sergeant Kirk Richardson from the
opp no all right he was one we've heard
from Carson party that he was one of the
subject matter experts on the integrated
planning team who was responsible for
Towing
if you can clerk Mr clerk put up the
document PB dot NSC Dot c-a-n
.40577
.
all right so you can see that there's an
email exchange here between some folks
in the rcnp Kelly Bradshaw Deputy
Commissioner who Kelly Bradshaw is yeah
yeah Kelly Bradshaw was the RCMP member
responsible for financial crime uh uh
unit and I believe there's already been
reference to Mark Flynn now if you can
scroll down please so we can get the
context of
of this email exchange further down
all right so stop there you'll see Kelly
Bradshaw this is to the uh an email to
Kirk Richardson from the opp hi Kirk I'm
B and asked the following question did
opp use emergencies act on tow companies
yesterday in Ottawa
so if you can scroll up for the response
and this is from the subject matter
expert that was dealing with this and
you can see its response on February
20th
he writes hello the tow contractors used
for the operations to clear the protest
areas for approached to see if they
would provide service the heavy tow
providers two companies both are
contractors with the MTO
the light duty toes were arranged by
Ottawa Police I am not sure what the
arrangements were related to cost I do
not believe the EO was used to make them
tow but it was referenced in relation to
protection and compensation of damage
occurred related to the protest
oh I take it you wouldn't have any
information to contradict that from the
subject matter expert
this is the first I've seen this
information
and you have no reason to doubt the
accuracy of that
I I can't I can't uh refute it or accept
it I have no idea I've never seen this
information okay that's fine
can we I want to take you to your
witness summary
please and the reference for that is I
have it written somewhere
if we can go to the RCMP witness summary
which is WTS 69
and go to page 24.
and again this is just another loose end
that I want to tie up because it's
important to have all the facts before
the Tribunal
you'll note that there's a reference to
the theft of about approximately 3 400
firearms from Peterborough area do you
remember that incident yes
now your witness summary doesn't make a
reference to the fact that those
Firearms were recovered about two days
later you will recall that correct yes
and so I think it's just important for
the record that we hear acknowledgment
that uh well that was a significant that
was a matter of significant concern at
the time it was resolved within two days
correct yes and that in fact you told
the incident I'm not going to bring the
minutes up unless you want to see them
but because it was an important issue
you made sure that you told the incident
Response Group the next day
that the guns had been recovered do you
remember that I I believe so yes
because you did not want to leave the
mistaken impression that there were
three thousand odd guns out there and so
that was important to make sure you
cleared that up
correct yes all right it wasn't in your
witness summary the conclusion I wanted
to make sure that was on the record
[Applause]
now if I can go to
going back to the consultation piece of
the female a few more minutes yet
one minute is the way I have the count
but uh
sorry David if we can go to page 22
second paragraph next paragraph down
okay so it says commissioner Lockheed
sought input and other police agencies
here you talk about seeking uh input
from different divisions you've spoken
without already and one of the questions
and the question that I really wanted to
ask is that when you consider the
extraordinary nature of the emergencies
act do you agree that it would be useful
to keep a written consultation record so
that when we go back and look at how we
use the emergency Powers we're able to
identify who we spoke to what and what
they said about what tools would be
useful do you agree that that should be
kind of clearly set out in writing so we
can keep a record there was a thousand
things going on that we could have kept
record of absolutely you can never I
guess you can never over record but it
wasn't kept no but I mean I think that
it's and I asked a question because it's
not entirely clear who was consulted
when they were consulted and what they
were said and again for future reference
it would be helpful wouldn't it to have
that because we have a consultation
report filed by government of Canada
that talks about consultation with the
political leaders but what I'm putting
to you is it would also be helpful to
have that kind of record on law
enforcement consultation yes I would
agree it would be helpful
all right well thank you I appreciate
your time
okay next I'd like to call on the Ottawa
Police Service please
uh good morning uh or good afternoon uh
commissioner lucky and Deputy
Commissioner Duhan my name is David
mijikovski and I'm a lawyer for the
Ottawa Police Service
um commissioner if I can start with you
um you are on record as saying that you
do not view the invocation of the
emergencies act as a failure of policing
is that fair
did I say that again uh that you're on
record as saying I do not view the
invocation of the emergencies act as a
failure of policing
no I agree if I said yeah right you
agree with that and that's because as I
understand it this was a very unique and
fluid situation and what happened in
Ottawa was very different from what was
seen across the country correct yeah it
was the first of its kind
and I also understand commissioner that
you are a trained Pou Commander
yeah dated but yes and um although you
have a very lengthy history in law
enforcement I think um this was the
first time you saw a protest such as
this one as well is that right yes
um in one of your key message updates
and I won't turn it up um but I don't
think it's contentious but it was your
February 3rd key message update uh you
talked about the um convoys returning
for the weekend which we know was a
phenomena that occurred and there was a
discussion of farm equipment and you
said at the time look there's no bar on
farm equipment from coming into the city
and that there have been convoys in the
past with farm equipment downtown in
Ottawa in the past correct yes
um
Deputy uh uh duhame I understand
um that the nrcc or the
ncrcc I apologize uh was stood up for
this event correct yeah it was stood up
around uh January 28th I believe
and the RCMP was part of uh that uh
ncrcc correct the RCMP and many other
partners
and it is used as a hub for intelligence
that goes on for the event not just
intelligence it's a coordination it's a
it's a command center that ensures
coordination uh with different partners
throughout the table as I mentioned
earlier you could have Ottawa city a
transport that's there paramedics uh
fire department so visit possibility
gets no
and other partners that are there so
that there's a coordinated approach
every time there's an action taken uh on
the scene but included within that I
believe was a hub for intelligence
that's correct
okay
um commissioner lucky my understanding
is that the RCMP followed the convoys
across the country and in fact provided
on the ground information to the opp
when the Convoy crossed from Manitoba
into Ontario yes and that information
then was funneled through a jig a joint
intelligence group yeah or a Sig I don't
remember which one
um and uh Deputy uh to him you indicated
I believe in your witness statement that
the Ops had the same intelligence as the
RCMP correct through our combined
intelligence group
that's my understanding and um I believe
um
you also indicated Deputy in your
witness statement that when it became
clear that the Convoy was coming to
Ottawa Police agencies began to share uh
intelligence including that through
project tendon correct yes and I think
the sharing started actually before that
but I I believe it started before that
uh commissioner you uh were and both of
you I guess were part of a panel that
was interviewed uh by the commission and
I think there were uh several of your
colleagues that joined you Deputy
Commissioner uh McDonald Deputy
commissioners of Lockheed Deputy
Commissioner uh Brennan and uh Liam
price the director General correct yes
and there was a discussion with your
colleagues I see in that summary about
the social media messaging of the Convoy
and the statement to the effect that
there was some social media messaging
saying that they wouldn't leave until
the mandates were lifted and Deputy
Commissioner Brennan stated that the
RCMP had concerns about the reliability
of that messaging because many protest
groups use social media messaging as a
diversion and you didn't disagree with
that correct yeah it's it's his opinion
on that I had no opinion on that and you
didn't disagree when he said that did
you
yeah I was agnostic
uh in fact you said in response that
there were different groups here as part
of the Convoy and they were not all on
the same age correct yes
um
I believe um commissioner lucky and
Deputy Commissioner duhane you both
expected you indicated in the witness
summary that some protesters might stay
in Ottawa until the Monday January 31st
which is when Parliament was returning
to session correct yes correct
and um
initially and I can take you to the
document if it's necessary but there was
a PCO call on uh January oh actually it
might be helpful if we turn up the
document
um Mr clerk it is SSM
dot c a n dot NSC 402591
and if we could please go to the first
page
and if you'll see the um
third bullet under four lanes of uh work
uh peaceful event
do you see that yeah
and if you I'm sorry actually if you go
down to the third large bullet where it
says non-threat
uh just underneath that yes uh
sergeant-at-arms PPS Ops RCMP all seeing
peaceful event no indications otherwise
but watching the chatter correct
and that reflects what you knew at the
time
I don't know what date this is sure if
we can go up to the top I believe it was
January 27th
yeah the Convoy hadn't even arrived yet
right yeah oh okay within our events
yeah as it was crossing yes apologies uh
Dave Trooper for the government
candidate again it's the minus five
hours thing so I think we're the 26th in
the evening okay
thank you
um yes so it's uh again if we can then
just scroll down again
and if we can go to the second page so
this would be the evening of the 26th so
if we go to page 2 the first bullet
you'll see just at the top blocking of
intersections protesters say they're not
going to do that but it's a lot of cars
which is what you understood at the time
as well they were not planning to block
intersections
where is this I'm sorry this is an
audible yes because they're not even in
Ottawa yet
I'm sorry like from what I understand is
that January 28th the convoys that's
that's correct but based on what you
knew on the 26th in the evening you
understood that they were not planning
on blocking intersections in Ottawa
correct okay that I don't know but
can I just add something here sir this
is the first time I see this document
I've never seen this I don't know who
participated on the calls uh I
understand reading through the lines of
the RCMP but this is the very first time
I see this document okay
um are you disagreeing with it or you
simply don't know I I wasn't there and I
I I don't want to question what's in
there but I I wasn't there some of the
things that I see I can validate it
through other Intel that I had from
another picture but I don't even know
who the representatives in the RCMP was
on this call okay you had no information
to suggest at that point in time that
the protesters were planning to block
intersections is that fair
foreign
not at that time
right thank you very much
um
um and I believe again I can turn up the
document
um uh commissioner
um but um
I understand that as of just a couple
days before the demonstration
um there was some discussion at the RCMP
about it was unknown how long they were
saying but there were some social media
saying that they might stay until
January 31st which would be the Monday
when Parliament was supposed to resume
the session correct
um again I wasn't intimate like I wasn't
into the details of the intelligence
um and maybe uh Deputy Commissioner
duhamem would be better suited to answer
that um I can show you the document if
you want uh Deputy
um unless you're in no no I do recall
seeing document saying that they were
planning on staying until the 31st okay
and there's another document that I'm
not quite sure if it's before they
arrived or after they arrived that they
didn't leave they didn't want to leave
them unless they met with the prime
minister so I'm not quite sure if before
they arrived or after they arrived okay
so um just for the records it's um
pb.nsc dot can uh four zeros8069 9 which
I believe
was the 25th
which is a uh for indicated that some
social media were saying uh that they
would stay until January 31st
um and if uh I could ask you a Mr clerk
to please call up PB NSC dot can uh four
zeros one two two five
and um if you uh you will see if you go
to the bottom of this email
but you'll have to go to the third page
and then just so you can see what it is
um yeah so you'll see it's um something
that was sent to you hi Brenda he just
shot me these questions and then if we
go above it we'll see uh you ask for
some bullet points uh and you'll see
anything you can give me would be great
and then you get some information in
response so this is January 28th okay
and so you'll see question 3A at the
bottom
was latest on what if scenarios what if
truckers leave Vehicles parked on
Wellington Beyond Saturday
and a series of other questions you're
asked about what if it turns violent Etc
and so if you go up to the first page we
see the answers
to those questions so you'll see uh
sorry if you just go to 3 a at the
bottom
uh
Ops uh I'm just on the third line
uh
Ops has reached out to the hotel
industry in the uh NCR who have
confirmed that accommodations are fully
booked through the weekend but appear
back to normal as of
2201 uh 31 so as of the Monday correct
yep
and so Ops it sounds like we're saying
that they've checked the hotels contrary
to some other evidence we've heard
they're reporting that in fact the
hotels are back to normal on Monday
correct yep that's the information we
received and then if we look at the c
um if we go to the next page
um
in the event that the protests are in
violence then there's a Pou team
available the Ops has one OPP has two uh
Pou teams I believe Toronto was there
and some of the other Municipal Police
Services were there that we can as well
with a Pou team in case correct yes and
uh fortunately those were not needed
and then if you go down uh to just below
the redaction we see that Ops and OPP
PLT are continuing to work closely with
the organizers of the events and it says
collaboration between all security
Partners in the NCR remains strong and
that would include the RCMP as one of
the security Partners correct yes
um Deputy Jaheim I I know that on
January 30th if we could please turn to
PB nsc.10
six zeros33
you'll see on the January 30th uh
Intel update this is an RCMP update
OPP PLT you're now reporting have it
reported chatter that the end date of
the event could be February 2nd correct
so that would be the Wednesday that's
correct
um you would agree with me
um
um there were obviously very many trucks
uh on the streets and some of them we
know traveled great distances to get to
Ottawa correct
that's my understanding of the group
that were in the downtown core and one
of the things we've heard from various
police Witnesses and law enforcement
officials in this inquiry is a certain a
concern about taking actions which can
inflame a crowd and cause danger and the
need sometimes for police to show some
restraint at the time and that is I
understand it uh is a standard practice
in policing
E I would say yes every situation is
different but there comes a point that
you have to assess and reassess your
positioning and and uh and and plan I
should say sure and so if I can ask you
I just want to get your reaction to this
if we can um call up uh
pb.nsc dot can
four zeros one one five four
and it's page seven
um commissioner I wonder if I might have
an extra five minutes
I'll give you a few minutes but thank
you
go ahead
um and so if we can please go to a page
seven the second to last uh bullets and
so I want to get your reaction uh open
sources are this is uh it did not occur
but open source reports are suggesting
police are setting up roadblocks
roadblocks outside
Ottawa and such reports seem to fuel
some truckers agitation
um
and so you see uh
that can uh cause you can see how
something like that can fuel truckers
aggression if they believe that correct
yeah can I know what the document is the
entitlement the title and the date or
I'm I'm just asking to just get your
reaction to the statement it could a
police action sometimes could generate a
reaction sure and I also saw there was
an email and it's ont 5099 from the
provincial security advisor and one of
the things he noted at that time uh
under uh his assessment he referred to
the possibility of police stopping
trucks from entering the city and noted
that that could result in increased
support or participation for the Convoy
does that make sense to you as well
deputy
it could but it's also speculative okay
you would agree with me that it could be
a risk and it could inflame the crowd
correct it could like it could not
inflame the cloud so it's it's it's one
of the other it
um the RCMP you told us um was part of
intersect
um and was also part of the NCR CC and
in that context would have access to the
Ops traffic plan correct
yeah that's where the coordination takes
place and you're aware that the plans
that the traffic plan and the
instructions that were sent out to the
Convoy participants clearly showed that
there would be some Convoy staging areas
on
um uh Wellington correct I did not see
the the plan as it was rolling in okay
you're not disagreeing though that that
information was available to the RCMP
just as it was to the Convoy organizers
and it showed that there would be uh
some staging of vehicles on Wellington
correct
uh what I will say is that when I was
initially briefed on the file I wasn't
aware of any stoppage in the downtown
core more of a slow roll and if that's
changed over the course of the
negotiations with the organizers I
wasn't made aware of it but I will agree
that any any intel any intel on the
situation downtown would be shared at
the under the ncrcc and the combined
intelligence group
okay um if I can just ask you um now to
go to
pbnsc dot can
uh four zeros two four seven six
and just while that's being uh called up
uh Deputy Jaheim in your gen in your uh
joint witness statement on page 10 the
second last paragraph you talked about a
call on January 31st where Ops stated
that it wanted to launch aggressive
enforcement between January four uh
between February 4th and 6th and you
felt that they didn't have the resources
or the plans uh to support that do you
recall that I recall the conversation
and it was reported to me not that it
wasn't briefed it was briefed to me but
I forget who but they were attending on
launching an operation on the weekend of
the fourth and the concern that was
brought to my attention is that it
doesn't seem to be a plan no one's aware
of what's going on and there's no
maintenance after there's no maintenance
portion after you've done after you've
cleared the area that's what was
reported to me and the concern about uh
enforcement I'll show you this document
is on February 9th
um if we go to the second page
um there is the uh there is uh actually
I guess if you start out the first page
uh so you'll see um just so that you can
see where we are
uh just if we could go up please yeah so
you'll see under background uh or uh
February 8th RCMP were advised that the
opp was attending Ottawa to assist uh
then third bullet February 9th uh OPP
and RCMP superintendent Lou attended to
Ops to assist in the development of a
plan and then uh the at one o'clock at
1300 there was a concept document that
was provided and then if you scroll down
um and then go to the following page
you'll see
um just at the top and so this is again
the concern about prelimit taking
enforcement action when it may not be
appropriate and it says continuing in
the meeting with less than 24-hour
notice to Pro partners and against the
advice from the RCMP and OPP the Ops
Chief announced that enforcement action
was to take place on February 10th
beginning at 6 and then set out what it
was and then current situation you see
that it was then delayed there was no
kinetic plan and so under the analysis
we see uh RCMP expressing concern about
it not being a viable plan do you
remember that
I do recall uh being briefed on that
correct
um and I guess over time now thank you
um I'll just um finish off I guess that
concern about the um absent about taking
action before there's enough before
there's a full plan and the absence of a
plan was something that I continue to
see um Deputy
um uh duhammed and commissioner Lucky in
both of your notes where you uh
throughout your key message reference
there isn't a viable plan here up until
the very end when the integrated cell uh
becomes involved is that correct we were
not ever shared a plan
um so I couldn't say if there was a plan
or not
okay certainly you reported
um at your key message meetings and I
don't have time to turn it up but the
documents are in the record that you
reported that there was no plan that you
were aware of and that was never shared
with you yes
and you did as well definitely yes
correct and it's in your notes as well
it is thank you very much I do have more
questions but I am out of time thank you
very much well over time it gave you
more than five so you're uh you've done
well
um
next uh we'll I'm calling on former
Chief
slow lease Council
who generously gave up part of his time
that commissioner lucky Deputy
Commissioner that that is this
commissioner's warning that I'm not
getting that back
so I'm Tom Curry let's see if we can
what we can do in the 15 minutes that we
have together
um
this was difficult problem
yes yeah yes I agree
um more difficult uh problem than either
of you have faced in your policing
careers at least of this kind
you agree I I agree
yes Mr
had a lot of difficult problems but not
this kind yeah this one this one is
uh well we you've touched on it when you
speak about the emergencies act or the
its predecessor the first time in your
careers either of you where
the government of Canada has had resort
to legislation of this kind right
obviously
now
um
I want to speak for a moment about the
circumstances that face the city of
Ottawa and the Ottawa Police Service
because you were both
involved in among other jurisdictions in
dealing with the problems that were here
um
the uh you had you knew Chief slowly
before this the before he took this
command is that true yeah not
very well but we had occasion to meet
yes and did you know Deputy no I didn't
uh cross paths was that okay slowly did
you know either of you did you know of
his work in the city of Toronto as in
the Toronto police service or or
internationally I heard of his uh his
work with Toronto Police Service okay
and he like the two of you he's uh he he
came to this role with a very long
experience in policing you knew that yes
and um
he came also you knew presumably just in
watching the the uh police services he
came with a change mandate you knew that
I wasn't aware of his mandate when he
was okay
commissioner you know that yes and a
change mandate that was fixed at least
in part on issues that were challenges
for the Ottawa Police Service in terms
of racialized communities community
policing and the kinds of things about
which he was very experienced yes I
didn't intimately know but I knew that
they touched on some of that and
um because you've probably had enough of
these kinds of challenges in your own
command that makes uh leading a Police
Service uh an extra special challenge
correct
yes and in the circumstances in which
um
Chief slowly found himself
I think you've both touched on this
there was enormous pressure brought to
bear upon Him leading this service at
the time of the Convoy protest correct
You observe that I I originally would
say I can't imagine the pressure he was
under but I could and he was under a lot
of pressure uh to succeed yes and
obviously Deputy you saw that too
because he had the worst possible
position if you think about it
every person in the country had an
opinion about what he should be doing
first of all some of those elected
office elected office holders you
reviewed with my friend Mr Miller some
of the notes that came to you
through the the federal cabinet cabinet
ministers were themselves frustrated
about what they thought was inaction by
the Ottawa Police Service in the first
few days correct
yes
correct and the provincial uh provincial
government uh felt similarly to your
observation
yeah I think that was the General
consensus and obviously here in Ottawa
the elected officials of the Ottawa city
council the Police Services Board the
residents
similarly felt enormous frustration that
their city had become the site of this
particular protest against the federal
government's mandates right without and
it was also obvious wasn't it to at
least to you as experts in policing that
there were no solutions that could be
had
at least within the resources of the
Ottawa Police Service right it was
overmatched
within the existing resources yes I
would say that's correct commissioner
obviously yeah I I'm just thinking it
through because I'm thinking from the
beginning through the end of the Convoy
depending on
situations but generally yes yeah I mean
well you can do the count it took uh it
took
um essentially a doubling of the more
than doubling of the police or the
entire Police Service to make this work
and it would have been obvious if the
protesters particularly because as
you've described it ebbed and flowed and
the protest grew and gathered momentum
the Ottawa Police Service did not simply
did not have the human power to deal
with a public order operation to remove
the protesters is that obviously true
again it depends on what what part of
the protest I look at because early on
depending on if there was a different
plan I don't I I'm just surmising I just
when when you're asking me to say that I
don't know the makeup of the Ottawa
Police Service okay that's fine Deputy
you knew that they didn't have the
numbers
based on what was there on the weekends
the numbers of people that are there I I
think is to me it was clear that they
needed additional resources right based
on the numbers we saw in the weekends
and she slowly identified that issue
early on and put up his hand to ask for
help
correct
yeah he requested resources and he
requested them from the province of
course and he requested them from the
from the federal government through the
to the RCMP obviously yes and there was
you agree uh a period of time
where the the province and the the
federal government
uh were uh seemingly at odds about who
should be the first Port of Call for
resources
right you knew that
I wasn't privy to that I know at the
beginning uh the the requests were
coming directly to us which was was no
issue
um because that's how we operated so it
was no issue for those requests but we
don't have unlimited resources to keep
um providing resources unlimitedly right
and so so the the resources that
um am I right though that The View that
you had or maybe it was the the minister
had was that the first Port of Call for
the Ottawa Police Service should be the
Ontario Provincial Police
yeah I don't think anybody thought that
at the beginning it wasn't unusual that
we gave resources and it was anything we
could do to help it was a big event
coming to the city so we weren't
thinking in terms of that it wasn't
until maybe the second week that we that
I was even privy to the order of Affairs
under the Ontario Provincial Police act
so when the when the chief identified
and and had the support of the community
the community leaders to identify that
there were eight approximately 1800
additional Human Resources required
um
then
when that request was made were steps
taken immediately by RCMP to coordinate
with the Ontario Provincial Police as to
how that that number of Human Resources
could be mobilized to assist here in
Ottawa well there was definitely
discussion
I know there was a general
letter but
no if it meant that you know uh 1200
were coming from Ontario 600 we didn't
know what that meant so we had to get
more clarity right and did you seek that
Clarity from the opp
um I'm not sure who we
um sought the clarity I know it was
that's for us to get the clarity was to
look at the plan
um what what the plan showed and what
kind of resources they needed and I
understand it wouldn't been your job as
a commissioner to look at a plan you
never saw the plans that the Ops had
right you yourself no I did get briefed
on the final plan right only because it
was integrated yeah Deputy you you were
also not it's not your role to to to
part through plans in the Ops I did see
the last plan that went forward okay uh
but at the goal command structure within
the incident command response did see
the plan right so were you aware were
you made aware by your own people
that the Ontario that the Ottawa Police
Service rather had plans from the
beginning to the end including plans
that that superintendent Liu of the RCMP
used as part of the integrated planning
process
did you know that superintendent Lou had
built on the Ottawa Police Service plan
or no no I'm not aware of that okay
commissioner didn't know that okay
so that the idea that that the Ops
um
and had plans I'm not going to show you
them in the time I have
um would have been left to others in in
within your command who had that
responsibility
yeah Fair
okay now
the the of course uh others have heard
the Commissioners heard evidence about
what happened in Windsor and obviously
the Windsor Ambassador Bridge blockade
was a significant national security
threat you agree
I wouldn't Define it as a national
security okay threat okay National
Security event yes okay and and um when
that occurred am I right that
um both the pro The Province and the
federal government
uh joined hands and mobilized resources
immediately to Windsor to help relieve
the Windsor Police Service problem you
knew that
sorry say that again yes the federal
government and the province agreed
to mobilize resources to Windsor
immediately
to relieve that blockade well it wasn't
really the federal government it was the
RCMP
oh okay can I just show you the I'll
just show you one thing if I could Mr
registrar s s m c a n
6068
and then the suffix is Rel
0001 and it should be page two just for
your benefit panelists and earlier you
asked me if it was a national security
event it was an event
um it wasn't an event of National
Security okay
others have had their opinions about
that I just wondered where you were
that's fine
um
so page
two
um
and just to just to orient you this is a
a
summary a a transcript of the
um
of a call between the Prime Minister and
the
and the premium
concerning resources
and
um the Prime Minister makes a comment
about the
uh just scroll down maybe hold on just
one second there please
[Music]
it's further down
thank you
yeah there it is
there it is RCMP do you see it second
last paragraph RCMP told me
they don't have jurisdiction and said
they need to get asked and they need
something in there I told them to be
prepared to respond to any ask
and if they need more resources we need
to be there at whatever cost Premier
says I agree I'll check with the
solicitor general I understand they
passed a regulation to have the RCMP act
as local police
they did it for Ottawa I'll check to see
if it applies to the whole Province I'm
not sure what that last part is but did
you understand from the from the prime
minister
uh or indirectly from the from the
government of Canada that the RCMP
should do whatever is required
to respond to the blockade in Windsor no
they never came out and said that to us
and and yet the the you those resources
were mobilized by our RCMP resources
were mobilized even though no plan had
been developed by the Windsor Police
Service or the OPP at the time you were
asked and so you know we were told there
was an enforcement plan by the OPP
all right two things sir uh this here is
is uh we're not I'm not aware of any
political discussion at that level
um when we got the requests to have
rcmp's tactical support group to head
down to Windsor we were told that there
was a plan and they were going to
initiate the plan the following day I
believe for the two days so we the
request actually went directly into our
folks who are in Toronto and we
mobilized The Troop that was up here in
Ottawa to get them down there to assist
right but that but that's the point you
you were told they were working on a
plan nobody at the RCMP saw a plan but
you mobilized and the suggestion is
surely you could have done so in Ottawa
no it's a completely different situation
this was 50 resources that we had within
the province under the federal mandate
when we go outside the province and
gather up 10 from each province there's
a lot of work that is done with that
there's a lot of requests that go with
that so when we're asked for when the
number 1800 came up that was when we
said what kind of resources how long do
they need to be here with the Windsor
plan OPP was in charge of all public
order teams and they asked Windsor is a
priority can you move a public order
team from the RCMP there so that was a
it was a different Dynamic I understood
it that and I could I'm sure we all
understand I'm sure Canadians will
understand why it takes more time
to get resources from one Coast to the
other into Ottawa but but don't we also
understand that they were needed here
yeah it wasn't a question of what how
much time it took it's just a question
of what day do they need to arrive how
long do they need to be here because
we have to backfill those positions
where they are we have agreements under
a contract with the provincial entity so
we have to make sure we respect those
agreements we can only take like I said
10 percent so what kind of resources how
long are they going to be gone when is
the plan going to start when is the
suspected end date because we have to
account for
um rotation of resources and rotation
when you're dealing with planes and
trains or what however it's it's a lot
of logistics so it's not as easy as us
taking one of our public order teams
that's based out of Toronto that was
temporarily deployed to Ottawa to go to
Windsor
two different scenarios I understood
very quickly that can I just go to the
issue of of Chief slowly and the and the
plan that was the integrated plan there
has been a suggestion in this hearing
from time to time that he delayed
somehow the approval of the plan uh am I
right that you understood that he had
approved first things first he didn't
have to approve it but suffice it to say
that there was no question but that the
plan had all the approvals that were
required by the 12th of February in the
afternoon
um no I was given information from
Ottawa Police the deputies not I didn't
create this information when we got
briefed on the plan on the Friday night
of February 11th we were um I believe
Deputy Commissioner Bell Lazer and he
said we need to brief um uh the chief on
this plan and he needs to approve it I
said great off they went the next day
somebody followed up with him and said
okay is the plan approved no we haven't
Bri I don't think they briefed him they
might have briefed him later on in the
12th when we asked about it I was told
on the 13th that
um we were asking why aren't we starting
the plan and he said because the chief
has not signed off on the plan and I
said well when is that going to happen I
actually reached into Chief slowly and
said are you going to sign off on the
plan and he told me I don't need to sign
off on the plan yes so I was given
erroneous information obviously got it
that's what I was just going to clarify
so whatever whoever told you that by the
time you reached the chief directly
there was no issue about that is that
fair yeah and that information was from
members of the Ottawa Police Service not
somebody from here understood can I just
show you PB that one of the things that
my my friend showed you from commission
Council PB NSC
c-a-n
8040
and it should be page 15.
um this was a document that you saw
earlier I just want to clarify because I
think
at that time you had confirmed you had
the approval
um
scroll down if I think
just stop there
yeah perfect so do you see at at and I
don't know if whether this is the actual
time I think it's minus five hours
integrated planning cell met with Chief
slowly and some of his team for a
briefing on the plan he approved the
plan however they are still working on
blending their new mission statement and
other aspects of their ops plan with the
goal of setting it back just scroll down
please
the modification do you see Mark Flynn
the modification is simply at the high
political element of the plan mission
statement other Witnesses have told the
commissioner that was not uh that had
nothing whatever to do with uh with I
don't even know what that sentence
slowly and then commissioner I just have
one last question no three minutes over
your time uh I will be finished thank
you thank you okay thank you thank you
uh ccla please
good afternoon uh commissioner lucky and
Deputy Commissioner Jim my name is Eva
creevska and I'm Council for the
Canadian civil liberties Association
um I'd like to start off first with
respect to
um the consultation that the chief of
staff of the public safety Minister
Mendocino did with you commissioner with
respect to your requests for under the
emergencies act and this is document
pb.nsc.can dot
403256 it was up earlier where he
emailed you and asked you what the what
the RCMP May request and you provided a
list and I just I I the document is up
for your reference but I just want to
confirm that many of the requests that
you made were restrictions on the right
to public assembly correct that was kind
of the the main those are the main
suggestions that you're asking for
cabinet to consider I think some of it
also had to do with tow trucks and
making sure that there were no children
in the area
and
um
that's correct you're right you also
asked for tow trucks and you also asked
for cell phone disruption and my
understanding is that other than the
cell phone disruption question all the
others were put into place under the
emergency's orders would that be fair I
think so not maybe in the exact way we
said it but yes
and you understood that when you were
making these suggestions or providing
this advice that the Declaration of a
state of emergency does not suspend the
operation of the charter correct
yes correct
and you understood that to the extent
that any of these uh suggestions would
limit any Charter rights those limits
had to be carefully tailored and not
disproportionate to the objective of the
measures
oh
I would say yes those are complicated
um and commissioner lucky you did not
provide or the RCMP did not provide any
suggestions with reckon with respect to
the economic measures that were enacted
no
um we may have been consulted our
financial people may have been consulted
on process wise but not I I refer to uh
I think we might have been part of the
consultation process I I'm not 100
certain
so you may have been also consulted with
respect to the economic measures that
were enacted as well I believe we were
but I'm not 100 sure
and if I take you to the economic
measures that were enacted and their
implementation I understand that Mr
denibo Dwayne was kind of the the person
at the RCMP that took the lead on that
issue that's correct
and we have his notes at
pb.nsc dot can dot
408065 Mr registrar I'm sorry if I could
ask you to put that up on the screen and
I can repeat it if necessary
um his notes uh and I'm gonna just go a
little bit back in time and go to a note
on page three of this document there's a
miss Mr budwein's notes and this is a
notes from a call on page three this is
before the Declaration of the emergency
uh February 9 2022 call with Finance
first bullet they want to enact law to
be able to seize money from protesters
looking at Privacy Law second bullet we
explained that right now monitoring
fains
mcpos is looking at specific on the
ground offenses they ask if law was made
to be able to Share info of the banks I
explained that if I need an order to
execute seizing assets total name RCMP
should not be the only law enforcement
body with new legislative power are you
familiar with Mr budwin's consultations
with the with the Ministry of Finance
uh not exactly all the intricacies of
his meetings as I said earlier I I
believe they're involved in the
consultation process early on uh this
demonstrates that they are but I'm not
aware of all the meanings they had I
would have been briefed I would have
been briefed every second day of some of
the progress that's gone that's that's
going on
and but you agree
advice to two friends at the time that
the types of powers that Finance was
requesting required court orders or
court orders for them to exercise those
types of powers as at February 9th 2022.
uh the way I'm reading it is currently
we need to execute uh judicial orders to
seize any fundings
currently the way it stands before the
invocation of the ACT
correct but the ACT wasn't seizing right
no the Act was freezing oh
it changes anything
I think that's uh that's I think that's
a legal question yeah but I'm not sure
but at this time to seize or I think
even if I would suggest even to freeze
assets even to freeze assets the RCMP or
the bank would need a court order to do
that
I I don't know I know for sure seizing
um but I'm not sure about freezing
okay
and
uh once the economic measures were
implemented after the Declaration of the
emergency you'd agree that the RCMP
became the central focal point for
financial institutions and for as a
conduit of information to financial
institutions with respect to information
about designated persons
uh correct we were the conduit of
information from the Ops and OPP to the
financial services
and Kelly Hughes at the RCMP who are the
primary contact persons with financial
institutions to provide them with
information
my name is Kelly Bradshaw
correct anybody was a primary I'm not
aware of Kelly Hughes but I'll take your
word for it
okay and
um and the RCMP as you said Deputy
Commissioner the RCMP would collect
information including names license
plate numbers and other information from
both Ops and OPP and provide that
information to financial institutions
correct there's two or two processes
here the RCMP would obtain in
information from Ops and OPP on relevant
criminal investigation that they have
and would submit those names
to the financial services and the other
one is that the Ops and OPP provided
some license plate numbers some names of
company that our team had to validate
and validation process was no different
in investigation go through the data
banks so we can assert that that vehicle
that belongs to whoever is still there
and the person is still there and then
the information would be sent to the
financial services another step to
confirm the identity of the individual
is when we were able to call the
individuals to let them know that we do
have a license plate we know they're
here and that the information we passed
on Financial Services
we did that when we could some people
responded that they didn't want to leave
the names went forward some people
responded that they couldn't leave
within which their names did not go
forward to the financial services
and have you reviewed the Canadian
banking association's witness statement
ahead of this hearing no I haven't
okay the Canadian banking witness
statement provides that it was the RCMP
who clarified that the entities
contained on the list were designated
persons under the emergency measures
order are you do you have any reason to
disagree with that sure we have the
responsibility to identify the
individuals and trans transfer the
information to the financial services
financial services it was up to them to
decide if they would freeze any assets
uh or in their Holdings
and the financial institutions also had
an obligation to report back to the RCMP
what uh financial instruments they froze
correct
I not quite sure they did but I'm not
quite sure if it's it's written in the
orders
well you can you could
dig there sorry I just want to clarify
that you are right in the sense that
anything they had in their Holdings they
were to inform the commissioner of the
RCMP that's in the actor
and if I uh I'll take you to an example
of a reporting letter from the Toronto
Dominion Bank this is
pb.nsc.ca n four zeros 8748
and uh this reporting
uh letter is to uh CPL I guess that's is
that Corporal or Captain Hughes dated
February 18th 2022 sorry we're just
waiting for it to come up on the screen
Mr Rochester need me to oh now we got it
okay so this is that would be corporal
Corporal thank you very much
um and if we scroll down
um they're reporting pursuant to the
order and they list
by a name and the type of accounts they
froze and if we go to the stack if you
just look at the types of accounts they
would freeze both checking accounts
savings accounts if you go to the second
page
um joint accounts business accounts
RSP accounts and HELOC accounts of any
uh person who was found to be a
designated person uh
and so
I just I want to ask you are you aware
that financial institutions asked
the RCMP whether they could
um they Sorry financial institutions
expressed concern to the RCMP about the
breadth of the orders were you aware of
that
uh no I'm not aware of aware of it and
we did not write the order and the
responsibility of freezing any assets is
the responsibility of the bank we don't
tell them what the freeze or or how to
go about it
and okay well you understood that Mr
Bourdain Miss Hughes held multiple calls
with the representatives from financial
institutions to uh explain to them how
the orders would operate and to answer
any questions they may have
yes because the order when the order
came into effect there's no procedure or
policy or ways of doing things so it was
left up to the rsmp working with the
financial services to try and figure out
and that's why with the documents that
were disclosed there isn't that next
there as to the form that we would use
to submit to the banks
right and the based on the the calls and
the notes of those calls that have been
produced in these proceedings the
financial institutions questioned
whether the freezing should apply to
joint accounts they asked whether there
should be a threshold to act I.E whether
you know if someone had a de minimis
amount of their account they asked
whether this applied to donations and I
think were you aware that
uh they asked about the question of
whether it applied to donations and the
RCMP said that they should not be
pursuing donations
uh not aware of the conversation of the
exchanges but I would imagine that the
financial services would reach out to
their legal uh Team to determine what's
in scope what's not in scope just as we
would do if we're not certain with a
certain element of the order uh we would
be reaching out to our legal team to see
clarification
and you're aware that the order arguably
also applied to credit unions and
insurance companies it it did so in
insurance companies as well correct
and that the RCMP exercised its
discretion and not to provide
information to insurance companies
it did and we have to be mindful that
our folks the team had less than 24
hours to put everything together
and when you look at the timeline for
the Convoy the very first packages that
were provided the service Financial
Services was I think on the 17th and on
the 21st we informed the financial
services that there's nobody left so it
was only on a stretch out on four days
very little time to get organized and to
get a proper process in place so that
both financial institutions and any rsmp
did the best they can came up with
something that was suitable for both
okay and the primary purpose of these
Financial measures uh was uh used to
disrupt and pers as a method to disrupt
and persuade people to leave Ottawa is
that how the RCMP used this this uh
these measures
that's correct this disrupt uh and and
and what not Journey it was such a short
time frame uh it was primarily used to
deter the people and disrupt
okay and uh pivoting now uh Deputy
Commissioner duhammer if I can take you
back to the notes
um your personal notes from the freedom
Convoy this is
pb.nsc Dot c-a-n
four zeros eight zero seven three
um if I if we can go to page 58 of this
document
this is a note from February 12th
so this is before the invocation of the
emergencies Act
if you scroll down there's a note at 10
19 a.m there's a note
Deputy Commissioner sorry if you could
just read it out so that I don't
um mistake your handwriting
uh there is enormous frustration and I
might mistake my own mind writing but
there's an enormous frustration with law
enforcement whatever
promises were not fulfilled and then
um
not quite sure move around uh protests
move around I'm not quite sure what I
meant by that
all right and then and the side of the
the next bill that separate
State and police although the lines were
across several times
can you are you able to provide any
context with respect to this note who
was communicating to you that who first
let's start with who is communicating to
you that there is enormous frustration
with law enforcement or is this your own
observation no This was
um these were notes taken from a meeting
and when I said separate State and
police although the lines were crossed
several times what I meant by that was
not by by elected official but more uh
having representatives from Public
Safety portfolio not at the elected not
at the elected level people from PCO
reach them directly to the chief of
police saying what we could do and I
just didn't think that I think it was a
law enforcement matter and anything to
do with briefing Public Safety or the uh
the uh or PCO would be up to the
commissioner and keep and keep the the
Departments out of it
and so so you said PCO you'd be the
privy Council Office reached out to
commissioner lucky or to commit to to
Chief slowly uh it was one meeting that
they reached out to we I attended the
commissioner attendant and and it was
with uh Mr slowly as well as other
people on the phone I just thought it
blurred it blurred the communication
lines and and what you see is you saw
the American letter directly to the
minister of medincino and and the
questioner resources or assistance
should be dealt with at the policing
level and then we bring it up to our
respective uh governments if needed
so you were expressing and you were
noting concern in your notes that
certain members of the federal Public
Service may have been crossing the line
between church church and state or well
sorry State and police with respect to
these issues I don't say I use that term
but I I
it would be more relevant if it was an
elected official which wasn't the case I
just thought that not to blur the lines
of communication it would have been best
if the uh the commissioner and this is
my opinion that the commissioner was
appointed contact for any government
federal government Department to brief
okay uh thank you and my my last my last
question is to commissioner uh lucky uh
commissioner you mentioned in your
examination and chief uh by commission
Council uh uh you were taken to the
February 13th um IRG meeting and I
understand from the the minutes of that
meeting that you you attended the
February 13th IRG meeting correct yes
and you had speaking notes for that
meeting that included a statement that
in your view or the rcmp's view all
available tools and legislation had not
been exhausted including charges that
could have been laid under the criminal
code correct yes
and
the IRG group is a group of Select
ministers brought together by the prime
minister to help with the coordination
of a of an incident that is occurring
whatever it may be correct yes the
ministers that are relative to the
incident I should say
relevant with relevant expertise to the
issue correct yes
and commissioner would you like the IRG
Met has met for other incidents prior to
these events correct yes
and would you have felt
um
free to speak up at that
do you feel like you would be able to
raise issues at those types of meetings
or is it the type of meeting where you
feel you could only be called upon to
speak no um if I needed to speak I could
raise my hand or I could just simply uh
walk over and talk to usually I was
sitting next to the minister so I could
raise it through the minister
and that's the minister of Public Safety
Minister Mendocino yes and so do you
feel like it was important at that
meeting on February 13th to inform those
Ministers of the fact that in your view
existing legislation had not been
exhausted it was already brought through
to them to minister managino through his
chief of staff
um and it was in my speaking notes
obviously which I don't believe now that
I was uh that I was able to speak to
um but it was already brought forward so
but do you feel like it would have
carried weight you're well over time so
you're gonna have to wrap up does it I I
uh commissioner I really appreciate the
Indulgence you provided with me and this
is my last question uh commissioner
lucky would do you not feel like it
would have carried weight for the
ministers who are considering their
their response including potentially
considering invoking the emergency side
to hear it directly from you
it may have but it was only part even
when I gave it to the chief of staff it
was only one portion of information
amongst many information that they were
dealing with in the invocation of the
emergency act and when I brought it
forward the first time it was mostly for
them to have all of the information when
they made their decision and having
already given it through uh given it to
the minister I felt that even though I
didn't get the opportunity at that
meeting it was already passed on
okay thank you very much commissioner
lucky and Deputy Commissioner um and
thank you commissioner rule for the
Indulgence
okay next is the city of Ottawa
good afternoon my name is Anne hardif
I'm one of the lawyers representing the
city of Ottawa uh Mr clerk can I ask for
us to pull up OPP
50601
commissioner lucky this is an email
exchange that you had with an officer
out of BC
and if we could scroll to the bottom of
that first page to start off with so a
little bit lower yeah there we go this
is an email from John Brewer with the
RCM py tickets out of BC to you dated
February 2nd do you see that there yes
and if we could scroll now to page two
and it's the last second to last large
paragraph in that email there we go
right there in the middle of the page
thank you Mr clerk do you see there and
Mr Brewer is explaining to you that
these types of protests leave very
limited capacity for for police to solve
this situation without some movement by
government to allow protesters to have a
quote unquote win of sorts and he goes
on to explain what he means by that in
the interest of time I won't read it all
into the record do you see that yes and
if we can scroll up to the first page
keep going
right there thank you you respond again
on the second and you say thanks for the
great response I already used a few of
the items when I was breaking briefing
some of the ministers today thanks a ton
uh did you brief the ministers I'm
assuming these are the ministers at
least of Public Safety and emergency
preparedness is that fair and sometimes
the minister of transport and the
minister of intergovernment also okay
um did you brief them with respect to
that concept the concept of uh the fact
that the solution might require a
potential Outreach by government to
create a win of sort for protesters I
don't know I'd have to read the whole
email to see there might have been other
things that I brief them on it might
have not been that because it's quite a
lengthy uh it is and I'm afraid I just
don't have the time pinpoint if it was
just that sorry is it a reasonable
proposition can I put that to you no
because I there's a ton of information
in there and I when I have already used
few of the items it could have been any
of the many items in there so I'm I'd
have to refresh my memory I appreciate
that I'm no longer asking that I'm
saying is the proposition that I read
out not did you brief it but is the
proposition that I read out is it a
reasonable proposition it depends on the
circumstances in the protest but yes it
is yes it is depending on the
circumstances yes okay thank you sorry I
don't have the best hearing so no that's
okay if I that's why
um you explained uh you both explained I
think primarily you explained
commissioner lucky that in Ottawa the
RCMP went from about 30 to then 50
officers per day correct initially yes
and that obviously is over a period of
shifts so if it's a two shift you might
have 25 officers in the day ship 25 in
the night shift correct I don't know how
they were deployed perhaps Deputy
Commissioner duam can assist it varied
it varied from shift to shift okay some
of them might have been all days and
then in the initial instance we didn't
get into that okay let me put it this
way I the Ottawa Police Service has
prepared and we've seen in evidence a
chart of deployment numbers that has a
total of RCMP forces per day hovering
around 50 to 60 per day and not getting
anywhere close to not hitting that 200
number that you were talking about into
your evidence
until after February 12th does that
sound reasonable yes yeah okay thank you
I won't bring it up in the interest of
time
now you explained earlier again this was
commissioner lucky that you did not need
or that the RCMP did not need to see an
operational Plan before sending public
order units or Pou units to Windsor to
to assist with the opp LED operation
there you recall that
no partly because it was a specific ask
right and it was explained to us what
they were going to be doing and what
what um type of resource they needed and
a public order team is unique because
it's the size of the public order team
so it's not uh we need
um yeah I understand that am I just
asking if you recall you recall that out
yes right and did you listen to Deputy
Minister Stewart's evidence Yesterday by
any chance no well one of the things he
told us
um uh and and one of the things he
reported to the SSE Committee of cabinet
was that the ops plan was subject to
review and verification by the OPP and
others and that was the case right when
we became integrated with the integrated
planning celius it was uh it was
integrated so all of them participated
and and that was really from the
integrated planning cell that was really
from February 8th on that's the evidence
we've heard of when they arrived in
Ottawa so from that point on yes subject
to verification by OPP and others Fair
yeah we well it wasn't verification we
had a briefing I wouldn't call it verif
I wouldn't call it verification from my
point of view maybe others uh like
Deputy Commissioner Doom but for me I
was just briefed on the plan so if I may
add something uh the question of getting
the right people together to review
what's been done
stems from my ask that came out for 1800
people and that's when their smes came
together said okay let's get together
let's have a look at the plan exactly
what we need how many people we need
what skill sets we need and that's
that's when that's when and then the ICC
morphed in but one of the reasons was
exactly as to what resources they need
based on the plan they have so the
February 7th request for approximately
1800 officers resulting in what you just
described Deputy Commissioner a process
where we got smes together from the opp
and the RCMP and of course the Ops to
see what was really needed verify the
requirements and that resulted
ultimately in setting up the intimidated
Command Center on February 12th correct
yes and I'll go to what was said
previously is that there was a number of
those thrown out 1800 no one knew where
this number came out and no one knew
what skill sets were required what type
of of individuals were looking for and
they had a thousand police officers some
Pou units but what type of police
officers that you need that's what
prompted a review of of that that task
and the plan itself fair enough and I
think you've explained that several
times I guess what I'm asking is the
RCMP wasn't going to fulfill that
request until it had the information
that you've just outlined Fair we were
already mobilizing some of our folks
because we know this was going to be big
but we wanted to wait to what the ask is
from that plan from the plan and from a
verified plan verified by yours in the
opp subject matter expert it was a
collective effort of smes subject matter
experts and I don't think it's we
wouldn't we couldn't we didn't know what
resources to call up okay
um
can we see how much time I have
all right commissioner lucky you
described earlier today that the
ministers the federal ministers were
checking in to see what other resources
were required and we're generally
offering to provide whatever assistance
was needed to bring the occupation in
Ottawa to a resolution right
yes and during the Convoy you provided
regular briefings to ministers Deputy
ministers
um and to Cabinet correct yes your wool
was to provide accurate briefings right
yes and you couldn't provide them with
all the information for a whole host of
reasons but you wanted to make sure they
had the key facts right yes and
commission Council put to you that you
reported on a number of occasions that
the RCMP was fulfilling all ops asks you
recall that yes and then he also took
you to the February 7th request for 1800
officers right yes and you've already
explained some length and I won't take
you through it because I definitely do
not have time
um the process involved before you could
send additional resources for
enforcement purposes in support of the
integrated operations so you've
explained that
um but I think we can agree that the
RCMP did not fulfill
that February 7th ask or request until
the enforcement plan was approved and
almost ready to go is that fair
um we did start increasing the resources
uh in because we knew it was coming as
uh Deputy Commissioner duhamem referred
to we started bringing people in but we
didn't get to that big number until
um we knew which day that we had to know
which day the enforcement was going to
start because if you recall on February
7th I think it was did you say February
7th was a request yes there was not even
a start date uh in in that plan so we
didn't uh maybe the start date was
February 13th so maybe we did fulfill
that request
because I'm not even sure what the start
date was
okay on the on the ask of if you're
asking for 1800 resources on February
7th my first question is when do you
need them and if they said right away
well I need to know what what shifts
like I said right and I think you both
have explained that several times my
question is a bit of a different one you
told cabinet and the ministers that
um the RCMP had fulfilled all ops asks
and what I'm asking you is whether it
perhaps would have been more accurate to
say that you had fulfilled all requests
for Frontline officers and were
assessing uh the latest Ops requests for
resources yeah that probably would have
been more accurate right
um I think I have one more minute
and with that I'm just going to conclude
on do I have one more minute I'll give
you one minute oh I was out okay you
were and I won't obviously take them up
but you were taken um to your team's
chat commissioner lucky Deputy uh
commissioner you were taken to your
notes several references
um about in your case commissioner lucky
uh whether they were going to the Pro or
whether there was a decision to go to
the province with respect to Peter
slowly in your case uh Deputy
Commissioner uh a comment by Minister
Blair querying jurisdictional change and
that didn't trigger
um any recollection you couldn't recall
neither one of you the context for that
um commissioner lucky on February 15th
you had a meeting with OPP
representatives in which you said that
you had lost confidence in achieved
slowly and you indicated that you didn't
want you know it might be time to look
at a command change at that point you
didn't want this and you didn't think he
wanted this is that Fair well we were at
the point it wasn't specific to Chief
slowly it was
specific to we have this plan we're
coming up to the weekend we need to work
on this plan I was told that it wasn't
signed off if we don't get this we
haven't got the plan signed off it's
time to move it's time to enforce
um I can't keep I can't keep bringing
resources in I can't keep going across
the country to get resources we need to
move and literally as I was speaking
about that to uh OPP commissioner Tom
Creek in another meeting uh Chief slowly
had resigned right and and I take it
that it's both your eminence that none
of the federal ministers ever discussed
uh and none of the federal ministers nor
commissioner karik prior to that ever
discussed a transfer in command of the
operation for Ottawa no they when they
were first discussing the emergency act
emergency at that time I was calling it
The emergencies measures actor people
were saying
um if they can't do this enforcement can
it go to the RCMP because again there
was this misconception that the RCMP
being Federal and National that the next
if if they couldn't do if they didn't
have the capacity to do it would they
bring somebody else in and that's when
we were explaining to them that's not
how it works we're not here to we had no
um interest in taking it over it wasn't
in our jurisdiction it the whole
Province we have no jurisdiction it's
not our job to do that we will assist in
any way we can to ensure that Chief
slowly and his crew succeed and that was
my main priority
thank you very much and thank you
commissioner for the Intel thank you
okay thank you next is the province of
Saskatchewan
good afternoon commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner my name is Mike Morris and
I'm counsel for the government of
Saskatchewan
commissioner I think we've established
that you did not speak at the February
13th IRG meeting or at the cabinet
meeting on February 13th is that correct
it appears so
and I'd like to show you an email that
indicates someone else was substituted
in for you at cabinet registrar can we
pull up PB
NSC can
four zeros three two one six
this should be an email
at 7 51 PM with the subject line there
it is minor changes to reflect and
others presenting on behalf of you slash
RCMP read TPS talking points for nsia or
Minister and it's from Allison Whalen I
understand this is somebody that works
with you commissioner yes
okay so this email then contemplated
Jody Thomas for Minister managino
delivering remarks instead of you then
is that correct
sorry Jody Thomas representative story
as the nsia yes well you're saying that
she was asked to
sorry just if you can repeat the
question well I'm just asking if there
was a decision that either the nsia or
Minister Mendocino would be delivering
remarks that you would have given on
behalf of the RCMP at the cabinet
meeting yes
okay and I'd just like us to scroll down
a little bit uh right above the word
Windsor on this first page
keep scrolling and it's the bullet right
above Windsor it says all the
information I'm sharing below is current
as of 5 PM this afternoon so that would
mean 5 p.m on February 13th correct yes
and I'd like us to go to the third page
then
and just scroll about halfway down
and there's a bullet in the middle of
the page that says RCMP and OPP
assembled the foremost experts to
develop a strategic plan do you see that
yes
so this is information that was provided
presumably to the nsia and Minister
Mendocino then is that correct yeah
these were my original speaking points
that I would have passed on to uh
um
Miss Thomas
I guess my point is these speaking
points reference the operational plan
the February 13th operational plan
um for either the nsia or the minister
but I take it that plan wasn't discussed
at cabinet was it
and like in detail the plan no what what
you see is what excuse me Donna for the
government if you're asking what the
ministers were discussing at cabinet
that's obviously covered by cabinet
confidence and the witness couldn't
speak to that
okay so she she's unable to say whether
the plan was mentioned by anyone at
cabinet not deliberations regarding it
but just rather whether it was a subject
of discussion
is that the government's position the
discussions as between the ministers are
covered by cabinet confidence
okay the agreement is that the
discussion is not but inputs I.E
material that was put to the cabinet is
disclosable
and does that include an oral input to
then commissioner
hi
how can look to the government but I
believe so it's it's just the
deliberations that are not so just to
guide the witness and you and your
questioning
I don't want to know about liberations I
just want to know if there was any
mention that the RCMP and the Ops and
the opp had a plan in place that was
approved at the February 13th cabinet
meeting that's all I want to know
yes
okay thank you
um commissioner you've been referred
several times to an email you had with
Mike Jones Minister Amanda Chino's chief
of staff that was shortly before the
cabinet meeting on February 13th you
recall that
which
email is it the one we
right right
what that you haven't exhausted all
existing legal authorities okay and then
that's that's the next question I want
to ask you
did anybody say at the cabinet meeting
that the RCMP and other police had not
exhausted all existing legal authorities
can you answer that for me I'm not sorry
once again just the wording of the
question is problematic because you're
asking if anyone at the cabinet meeting
said something and if it was said in a
discussion between ministers that would
be covered by the cabinet confidence
if it was said by someone providing
inputs to Cabinet then it's not was it
said by somebody providing inputs to
Cabinet that's what I want to know
I can't say for sure
um
obviously I wasn't uh speaking at that
meeting I would have to look at maybe
inside these notes that you have up on
the screen
um if it's inside there it may have been
provided because these were given to the
nsia but I can't I'm trying to scroll
but I
yeah okay I understand
I'm going to move on and I want to pull
up another document it's PB NSC
can four zeros eight zero seven four
and just these are Deputy Commissioners
notes uh just for reference
and I'd like to go to page 104 please
of the PDF
uh Deputy Commissioner these are your
notes correct from February 14th 2022.
that's correct
they reference a meeting with the nsia
at 9am is that correct uh that's correct
okay
uh who called that meeting
uh I would I I I would say that it was
probably called by PCO rarely do I uh
Engage The nsia unless there's an
ongoing matter that has to be briefed up
but uh it would probably was probably
called by PCO
can you explain uh the words inevitable
outcome at the first arrow and what
that's in reference to
all right
um I uh I'm I'm trying to remember what
I I meant by that because it's going
backwards some time ago but I'm just
wondering if it's not with regards to
the use of force that would be needed uh
to bring this tenant and I'm just I I
like I think it might be that but I'm
not 100 sure
uh from your recollection that the nsia
know about the operational plan which
had been developed as of 9 am
I don't recall ever briefing her uh on
the plan uh with regards to the
Interventional plan because even on the
14th
uh we were brief on the 13th it was
still not officially signed off until we
had the final plan as we were moving
closer to the weekend of the 18th so I I
did not brief the nsia with regards to
the operational plan I can add that
there was nobody there was a briefing
that of the existence of a plan but
nobody was briefed on the details of the
plan
okay
um I want to pull up another document
it's Ops four zero or three zeros one
four five six six
these should be
um notes of chiefs slowly scribe and I
understand that um commissioner you had
a meeting I don't know if it was virtual
or in person with Chief slowly at 10 A.M
on February 14th so if we can just
scroll down a little bit please
okay there we are 10 a.m meeting with
Commissioners karik and lucky
and where I need us to go just a little
bit further down just scroll a tiny bit
further okay please just stop now we
have a bullet which says lucky did not
get prime minister briefed up on the
plan prime minister will be enacting the
emergency measures Act
advice for legal to review what the
measures are what's the process now
commissioner my question simply for you
is it's a fairly straightforward one did
you tell
um former Chief slowly at this 10 a.m
meeting that the emergency Act was going
to be invoked
um you know what I
do not have a recollection of that
um I think I may have because it was
inevitable on that I think I was brief
that it was in fact going to be invoked
and so I probably would have uh
mentioned that but I I can't say for
sure my I'm going back to my memory
um but you have no reason to dispute
what's noted here then that's what
you're telling me is that fair
now what time is that meeting at 10 a.m
10 a.m yeah there it's very likely
because I was meeting with both uh Tariq
and uh and uh commissioner Creek and
chief souley it could in fact be true
like I can't refute it
okay
um I'm not sure how much time I got left
I've got two areas and if I can only
cover one maybe I'll I'll start with
with that I just want to touch briefly
on the freezing of bank accounts
um my understanding is that the RCMP
provided a list of names to financial
institutions but that it was up to those
financial institutions to do with that
list is that fair correct we were the
conduit of information for Ottawa Police
Service and the opp it's it was a
financial services responsibility
to decide if they were going to freeze
or not uh based on what we gave them
okay but would you agree with me that if
they had a list for a designated person
you know not freezing a bank account or
a credit card on that list could
constitute an offense
uh I would I would I'd have to go
through the measures act but I I think
face value like that it but it is but
again it's at their discretion as to how
to proceed if they're not comfortable
with the information that we provide and
here's an example we could provide
information that we believe that the
person is there but if this person has a
Visa card and is somewhere in Canada all
of a sudden we have to go back and
double check and validate what we have
so the responsibility rests with the
financial services to decide if they
freeze or not right it's an offense to
make funds available to somebody
participating in a demonstration covered
by the emergencies act fair enough Fair
okay and then that's a little bit of a
heavy onus then on these financial
institutions because they're facing
potential charge if they don't freeze
accounts Fair
I didn't write the legislation or the
orders we just applied that
they're well out of time uh you've
well exceeded your time so you're gonna
have to wrap up
I have I have one last area then yeah
can I have two minutes commissioner or
not if if not I understand I I don't
want to take up all the time no you're
you're over I'll we'll go on to the next
thank you sir thank you for asking my
questions much appreciated thank you
next is the National Police Federation
good afternoon my name is Nene Jones and
I act for The Police Federal in the
National Police Federation
sorry I've just had my
iPad closed up of course
I'm going to ask you a couple of quick
questions just to start off about the
swearing-in of RCMP officers under the
Ontario Police Services act so very
quickly because we have heard a lot of
evidence about that over the last number
of days you're both aware I'm sure that
in order to permit our CMP officers to
enforce provincial laws and Municipal
bylaws they need to be sworn in as
special constables under the police
services act yes that's correct and
you're aware there's an equivalent sort
of provision in Quebec as well
uh the I think I believe there is one
yeah I'm not an expert on that so I'm
not going to try and wade into the
specifics but are you aware that in
Ontario prior to the Convoy our members
were required to take a short course and
write a test before being sworn in
uh commissioner I see that you are not
aware of that no same here I'm not aware
of the full process other than they had
to be sworn in okay were you aware so
anything about a course or a test is is
okay
um
so I know that both of you in your
witness statements said that the
swearing-in because it was essentially a
paperwork exercise was not a significant
deterrence or hurdle
is that right
I there's nothing that was brought to my
attention that it was stalling the
process if you wish my understanding is
that things were going smoothly when it
came to the swearing in process
and are you aware that there were still
some challenges for example in Windsor
where our members had to use a buddy
system
no I'm not aware of that so being
deployed with either an opp officer or a
winter officer along with the the RCMP
officers no I'm not aware of that okay
would you agree then broadly speaking
with me that looking at this issue might
be something that uh this commission
could do or make a recommendation in
respect of
we're talking about it in respect
especially in the the two provinces
where we have no jurisdiction if there'd
be a more streamlined process that would
allow maybe all all uh for all regular
members to have that in advance
um if if in fact they needed it or some
form of process that would satisfy both
the police act and ourselves
thank you commissioner
um
at the end of your witness statement uh
you were both asked about
recommendations or thoughts you had
emerging from this and you talked about
commissioner you particularly talked
about protests like the freedom Convoy
uh not going away
uh and I think we've heard some evidence
over the last few days about this being
a paradigm shift a new model of protest
is that something you both agree with
yes yeah I see I see the landscape
shifting correct okay Deputy
Commissioner I want to pick up on some
evidence that you gave earlier about not
really that long ago when the RCMP had a
bigger footprint here in Ottawa correct
and uh you talked specifically about I
think when the RCMP were the police of
jurisdiction in respect of the
Parliamentary Precinct
and how planning worked for big events
oh you recall that evidence
specifically you said that there'd be
joint planning the RCMP and the Ops
would plan together correct and so
um I'm sure you're familiar with the
witness statement of Dennis Miller and
Steve Madden neither of you have had an
opportunity to review it Mr Miller who I
think you may know I know Dennis
farewell thank you uh talks about how he
policed three previous G20 Summits
um and that the RCMP directed protesters
to park at a distance from the summit
location
yes the usually when there's a summit
you have to identify a location where
people can can demonstrate and be heard
and that they would then arrange buses
to transport them to those uh in some of
the major events they would yeah it's
different from one major event to
another and commissioner I see you
nodding that's a practice
sense
20s Jesus
the RCMP has significant experience with
large events right yes and so in
circumstances like this one would you
agree with me that it would have been a
benefit to revert to those
um I don't I want to say old ways of
doing it although it's really quite
recent where the RCMP was an active
participant in planning around
Parliament Hill
um I I would say that since the creation
of the Parliamentary Protective Service
who has a mandate of Parliament Hill and
the 34 Precinct buildings they've been
working hand in hand with Ottawa Police
Service since the withdrawal of the rsmp
on the hill and and it's been going fine
and Ottawa Police Services managed
several large-scale events throughout
the years where uh you'd have a hundred
thousand people in the streets on Canada
Day you look at the work they've done
with that they did with rolling thunder
when it came in afterwards it did an
excellent job there so I I don't
necessarily agree it's it's an
organizational issue law enforcement law
enforcement I I I think I think it's
been shown throughout the last couple
years that it's it's been working it's
been working and I'm not convinced that
if we were there things would have been
different we and I I wish to remind you
that our initial our initial
participation when this all started that
we were really we were involved in the
planning process but looking at it from
our protective lens and not necessarily
the demo lens right so sort of that
Federal policing lines was the lens you
brought to bear not that front line or
Community Based policing not my mandate
okay but you talked earlier about in the
this prior period when there were 120
RCMP officers available in the
Parliamentary Precinct right yep and
everybody here already knows that I'm
always asking questions about the
Parliamentary Precinct I know that you
were the first director
um but you know so in fact you know
probably better than anyone that the PPS
security officers are not uh it's not a
law enforcement agency
right correct and that they are not uh
they can't exercise police powers
they do have powers to arrest but not
the same as a police officer right and
in fact if they do arrest they have to
call the Ottawa Police they do or the
RCMP
uh most of the times is the police
jurisdiction because Ottawa is a police
of jurisdiction for any criminal matters
in in Ottawa but if for example if it
was a terrorist matter they would be
different that falls under our mandate
right
and um in fact the police of
jurisdiction whether that's cops or the
RCMP under their mandate have to ask
permission to be invited into the
buildings for policing purpose right
inside the buildings yes yes uh even I
would say even
they would need permission from the
speaker of the house if they have to
enter any part of the buildings I
believe I believe and so the full wind
down of the RCMP out of the
Parliamentary Precinct really just
concluded in about 2018.
right
the wind on of the organization
decommissioning I think is the language
you used in your I'm not quite sure if
decommissioning but but to your point is
is and you've said that because it's not
a law enforcement role
that's why I initiated the review in
2016 and started looking at okay I think
it's time to reduce our footprint
because it's not a law enforcement
responsibility it's a security
responsibility that PPS is doing very
well at and that's what prompted us to
reduce and as I mentioned earlier in my
statement under legislation the
director's position is an RCMP member
but other than that it's it's uh that we
have no one else they report up to the
speakers they report up to the speakers
initially when it was created because we
had 120 people there the mou that I
believe is still in effect had a roll of
the RCP would Overlook at the
integration portion of the Securities of
the different security units that are
there but I'd say the integration is is
fully done it's been seven years now so
uh everything is reported to the
speakers right now
so
um just to be clear during the Convoy
um
this group of a few hundred uh maybe a
bit more security officers at you
probably have a better sense of the
numbers than I do I I don't know what
they had uh footprint wise when this was
going on I'm not aware of the exact
number
so they have a witness or sorry an
Institutional report
um it's PPS IR is a number of zeros and
then one and they say that they played
uh no active role in yeah let me just
make sure I got it not they were not an
active participant nor a contributor to
any tactical policing uh planning in
during the Convoy
and that's at page eight in the document
but we can pull it up if you need to see
it but yeah that makes sense no you
don't I I know they were in the ncrcc
during the entire event uh that was
again to coordinate anything that needed
to be coordinated on the hill but I'm
not quite sure of their involvement uh
with regards to the planning process I'm
hinting more towards no than anything
else yeah OC trans suppose in that
Center as well right there's a lot of
partners that are in there lots of
people are in that who don't play a
policing role not necessarily okay so in
terms of these few hundred security
officers or security guards
um we know that uh they put in an RFA uh
request for federal assistance seeking
rations were you aware of that uh not
aware of Russians and that's some of the
information that doesn't always make its
way up to me yeah um just in case I
think they wanted to make sure they were
supplied and they also stood up their
own crisis Management Center yes they
did inside uh but actually the RCMP and
the opp had to deploy public order units
to those buildings right they do not
have they do not have any uh I would say
tactical teams like we have and and we
did provide a public order unit to
assist and are you aware the opp did
also I think we yeah I think there was
two public ordering teams involved and
I'm not quite sure if coppr simply had
one of them and I think I think it's OPP
or Europe but I'm not sure so the opp
and the RCMP were responsible for
providing that security during the
Convoy to these physical buildings uh my
understanding is that the rsmp and the
opp had a public order units on standby
ready to deploy if required inside
pardon my held out inside on the grounds
or inside okay and you'll agree you're
just about out of time so you're going
to have to wrap up I'm absolutely about
to wrap up thank you and you'll agree
with me that probably my tail is a
frequent Target for protests uh it is
you'll agree with me that Parliament
Hill is a frequent Target of threats
including a violent threats uh the hill
itself I'm not quite sure and or the
people in it I'd say the people in it
the people who work there more than hell
and would you agree with me that having
a distinct organization and I understand
as someone who helped build this
organization this may be a bit of a
difficult question for you but that
having a distinct organization with its
own Command Center its own communication
processes and its own people can stifle
that flow of information that's so
crucial in events like the Convoy
can yes but that's the reason why you
have an ncrcc or an integrated Command
Center where people from the different
organizations come together and the flow
excuse me the flow of information is
shared there and then bounce back to the
respective organization
okay and then may I ask one last
question if one last question I
apologize thank you
um commissioner lucky we've had a lot of
questions about the availability of
bodies and boots on the ground in
responding to the Convoy uh in the early
days but frankly all the way through it
would you agree that 120 additional RCMP
officers at the Parliamentary Precinct
would have been useful in responding to
this event
I if is that directly to me it's to
commissioner lucky but I would certainly
all lead off uh you got to be mindful
that even if you have 120 resources we
do have a primary mandate with regards
to protective policing and Hill so it
doesn't mean that you would have 120
resources at your at your availability
to deploy it elsewhere you still have to
maintain that Mandate of course and if
it takes 75 maybe you can take 10 or 15
people away from that they're on their
days off but that exact number uh I'd
have to dig a Little Deeper now
ditto right you'd agree 10 to 15 would
come in handy though right any
additional resource always comes in
handy okay I I think it's been uh pretty
long so far it's a little uh unusual but
I think we can take a break uh for 15
minutes because we're unfortunately not
through the list so I'll take the
afternoon break now 15 minutes and then
we can come back
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
okay ready to go
at your disposal commissioner okay
next is the Democracy fund jccf
good afternoon commissioner Deputy
Commissioner
my name is Alan honner I'm a lawyer at
the Democracy fund we share standing
with the jccf and citizens for Freedom
although we are separate organizations
can we just pull up
from TV NSC
.can.40s 5820
so um commissioner this is a question
for you if we can just scroll down to
the top of page two
what we see here is that um
there's an email here from Jody Thomas
you have to look down to where it says
original message
and then is dated February 21st 2022
and Jody Thomas the National Security
intelligence advisor says good morning
Jeff has put pen to paper
and see that do you see that
no Okay so
sorry scroll down just a little bit more
my apologies
a little bit more
um
top of page two
uh scroll down more
okay I'm sorry scroll up
a little bit more
maybe the top of Page Three
let me just I'll just check to make sure
I have the right document here this is a
version of it
okay well let's say with this document
here
um commissioner do you recognize this
document no
do you know if there was if there would
be any reason why
um Jody Thomas would be asking you and
other people
uh for reasons to
um for comments on criteria for revoking
the emergencies Act
oh is that what it is okay so
you recall being asked about that
um I know that there was talk about as
soon as the the second the emergency Act
was invoked uh the next question was
when we when they undo that and so
um
they would have no idea obviously it
would be probably on a law enforcement
lead to say that okay we've
we don't need it anymore in in
cooperation with the people who put the
act in in the first place
okay but
why would they be Consulting you about
that
because I was the contact for law
enforcement and so I'm imagining they're
looking at
um
is what date is this the 21st so the
21st would have been right around the
time that uh that was when police
operations were just finishing up and
they were wondering if we needed any of
the authorities to continue so that's
probably why they were asking okay so
can we look at the um the top of the
page please Council if it's any help um
are you looking still looking for that
Jeff has put pen on paper reference
sorry can you just scroll up
uh on page four there's that reference I
think no no that's okay just scroll
please
okay so it there's an email here from
Brian Brennan and he's one of the Deputy
commissioners of the RCMP yes of
contract and Indigenous policing and he
makes a comment here about Rob Stewart
who says Rob Stewarts talks about
assessing the threat in terms of
violence versus truckers hanging around
not sure this is the best point of view
given that there was no serious violence
in Ottawa the main reason for the uh
emergencies act but there was such a
threat in Coots what was handled with
already existing authorities even though
we could have used the EA and Coots to
support the operation
plus truckers hanging around is how
bridges and points of Entry become
blockades do you agree with the remarks
of your Deputy Commissioner here
not in the way that he's put it no
um there's uh there's a lot to unpack
there so I can't say I agree with
everything that's being said
um so let me ask you about something
else then
um we heard earlier today that um
the integrated planning team presented
to unopp commissioner karik with a plan
on February the 13th and you told us
that you found that plan to be
satisfactory
yes we were briefed on that plan on the
11th in your witness statement I put it
to you that you described that plan
differently you said that it was an
amazing plan and you wanted to see it
action to promptly
yes okay
and your evidence today was that you
were the window to law enforcement for
cabinet
well I was the the primary contact for
uh the federal government right and so
I'm confused about whether you would you
actually attended the IRB meeting and
the cabinet meeting of February the 13th
I saw I thought you said in your your
evidence that you weren't sure uh if you
attended those meetings well no the
question was whether I was I spoke at
those meetings I know I attended okay so
you attended but you're not sure if you
spoke and my friend from the uh the
government of Saskatchewan brought this
to you but if we could brought this up
with you but if we could pull up the
cabinet meeting that's
ssm.nsc dot can
five zeros two one six
okay so if we go to page eight you are
not giving the situational report here
uh advisor Jody uh nsia advisor uh Jody
Thomas is giving that
um
that situational report why is that
because I thought you usually gave those
situational reports yes I usually did
and for I think because she would give
an overview on those meetings and I
would give an overview and I think they
just wanted to condense it so they asked
her to do it and so she has she had
normally given a bit of an overview so I
gave her my notes if she wanted to
incorporate anything in that okay and
let's go to the the cabinet meeting uh
sorry this is this is the cabinet
meeting that's c-i-r-g I think
um
this is 216. so let's go to
um
ssm.can Dot
5095
maybe six zeros
and what we're looking at here is uh I
believe it's
like
it's the incident Response Group leading
from uh February throughout the 13th and
if we can scroll down
um
to page five please
here we see the um the minister of
Public Safety
um is outlining the great progress that
has been made on clearing the Ambassador
Bridge he talks about enforcement
actions that are occurring
um at Coots and Emerson and he talks
about the establishment of the
integrated Command Center in Ottawa
he describes that as a significant
concrete action but what he's giving
here it seems to me as an update on law
enforcement do you agree about that is
not what isn't this an update about law
enforcement
um it's an update of the situation on
the ground that is by law enforcement
yes and that's something that you would
usually give but you didn't give it that
day no
okay and and both of these documents
that we just looked at they're heavily
redacted but I don't see you speaking on
either of those days although the
documents confirmed that you were in
attendance yeah um as per previous
documents revealed
um I think it was in an email it shows
that um I wasn't going to be speaking
and that the nsia was going to and right
no I saw that and do you think that you
were not invited to speak because you
had reservations about invoking the
emergencies act no not at all because
that the prime
purpose of that that day was all about
the emergencies act and I think that the
fact that they had us because normally
I'm just giving a situational report on
what's Happening
um from coast to coast I'm not taught I
wasn't going to be talking about the
emergencies act anyways what I'd
normally give is a sit rep so maybe they
were just in the economy of time
my friend from commission Council
earlier today brought you to a request
for a security assessment which was
directed to Adriana holles and not to be
RCMP and was that perhaps because you
had reservations about the invocation of
the emergencies act uh commissioner I
know I'm just about out of time I wasn't
aware of that uh request for a threat
assessment so it wouldn't have been
attached to a emergency act specifically
but in addition I think you've
mischaracterized the evidence she um
Miss Palazzo is with the RCMP
right okay so she she was asked like you
were not asked
I don't do threat assessments so she
would have been asked and but you were
not even notified about it no I didn't
nor would I be at my level you learned
that about that today yes okay and I
just want to show you um very quickly uh
the email of February the 14th uh this
is uh SW SSM Dot N S C dot can
um five zeros two one six
and it's this email in which you express
your reservations to minister Mendocino
about invoking the emergencies act
because there are other uh existing
tools
um at law that haven't been exhausted
I just want to show you
um the time of that email
I believe it's sent uh just after
midnight but if we're doing Greenwich
Meridian time that would be five hours
back yes so I think between seven and
eight o'clock
foreign
Council um I think was that the ssm216
that you just mentioned uh yes I
SSM NSC can 216 goes back to Cabinet
minutes okay that that's fine do you
recall you recall the email was showed
to you earlier today and it was dated oh
sorry it was time stamped just after
midnight
okay well
um would you take it from me that it was
uh that would it was time stamp just
after midnight or should I pull it up
okay
sure I I you know what I have no idea so
I'm okay and if we deduct five hours
that brings us between seven and eight
o'clock
um Eastern Standard Time
and you would agree with me that's um
that's shortly before the cabinet
meeting happened on February the 13th
sound like you've done your research so
I'll take your word for you okay
and so when you and so before that
cabinet meeting was held
um Minister medicino and others knew
about your position on the emergencies
Act
yes in fact if it was before the cabinet
meeting yes thank you very much thank
you
okay next is the CCF
thank you so my name is Jenna Nisha
maganathan and I am counsel for the
Canadian Constitution foundation and my
questions are for commissioner lucky
um so earlier today when commission
Council was asking you questions
he brought up discussions with Federal
ministers about RCMP taking over the
Ottawa Police Service and you responded
and said you know that was an issue that
you were asked about often and that you
had to explain that the RCMP was not the
police of jurisdiction in Ottawa you
recall that
yes but I think I'd have to correct
myself it wasn't often there it was
brought up a couple of times
sure and your the response was you know
the RCMP is not the police of
jurisdiction in Ottawa and nor do we
have any jurisdiction in Ontario for
that type of policing
okay so I want to just talk a little bit
about this this notion of jurisdiction
okay
um so I want to take you to the RCMP act
and Mr registrar that's ccf6029
and if I can take if I can ask to be
taken to page 20 please
just scroll down and just stop there
great
so um section 18 of the RCMP act 18a
specifically sets out the duties of
Peace Officers the duties of police RCMP
officers and what 18a says is um you
know it is the duty of members who are
peace officers subject to the orders of
the commissioner a to perform all duties
that are assigned to peace officers in
relation to the preservation of the
peace the prevention of crime and of
offenses against the laws of Canada and
it goes on to say and the laws enforced
in any province in which they may be
employed and the apprehension of
criminals and offenders and others who
may be lawfully taken into custody so
you'll agree that this is the provision
that sets out sir the powers of our CMP
officers
yes yes
and uh you know where it says the
prevention of crime and of offenses
against the laws of Canada that's part
of the federal policing Mandate of
enforcing Federal statutes you'll agree
um
not necessarily because anybody can
enforce Federal statutes it's not just a
federal law enforcement provincial and
Municipal Police Services can also
enforce Federal statutes like the the
Cana the cdsa the drugs and substance
act for example
okay so you'll agree though that RCMP
officers have the power to enforce the
criminal code for instance
yes
right and they always have the power to
enforce the criminal code it's just part
of what they're allowed to do
yes
right they don't need to be sort of the
local police in a jurisdiction this is a
power that they always have
yes
right and there's nothing in the
criminal code for example that says an
RCMP officer can't enforce the criminal
code in one particular place they can
enforce it anywhere in Canada
I'm not sure where you're going with
this but I think in fact like for
instance anybody can enforce if you find
somebody committing under the criminal
code so it doesn't you don't even have
to be a police officer
um but there is a jurisdiction where um
obviously if there police and Public
Safety is involved and you are standing
there you need to by you have to uh act
on that any police officer has to act on
that but including our CMP office yes
including RCMP officers okay so just to
use sort of a bit of a silly example if
we have an RCMP officer that's standing
on Wellington Street in Ottawa and they
see somebody committing an offense under
the criminal code they don't need to
call up Ottawa Police Service to arrest
the person they can go and arrest the
person themselves
yes
right okay and now we've heard a lot
about
um you know the appointments of special
constables under section 53 of the
police services act
right and what that does it you know it
gives an RCMP officer who's appointed a
special Constable the powers to enforce
provincial municipal authorities that
you know Ottawa Police Service would be
allowed to do
yes and this would be in addition to the
power to enforce their criminal code
which they always have
yes
all right and now you know it's it's
fair to say that you know during these
protests criminal code offenses were
being violated
you'll agree with that
there were some yes
some and
um I'm not sure if you're aware of this
but there was an injunction that was
granted in Ottawa in relation to several
city of Ottawa bylaws which include you
know open-air bylaws fireworks bylaws
noise bylaws are you aware of that
yes all right and you'll agree of course
that an injunction is a court order
yes
and section 127 of the criminal code
makes it in a criminal offense to breach
a court order you'll agree well with
injunctions though usually there has to
be an enforcement order attached to the
injunction
um that we would uh would allow police
to enforce the injunction
so I don't know if there was any
enforcement order attached to that okay
so if I was to say to you hypothetically
if there was an enforcement order that's
attached a police officer could arrest
somebody for breaching a court order in
this case an injunction I'm not sure I'm
really I'm not a lawyer
I I
honestly don't know the answer to that
question
so you don't know whether police officer
is allowed to under Section 127 to
arrest someone if they're violating a
court order no you weren't asking that
you were asking the RCMP in Ottawa and
it's not our jurisdiction so I would
have to refer to my legal people to ask
that question and we do that all the
time when it comes to enforcement
okay so if it fell within the Gambit of
section 127 which speaks to breaching a
court order and our CMP officer could
arrest a person for that right but I'm
not sure how the injunction was obtained
if it if it falls under the criminal
code and if it's it's an actual court
order that's breachable I'd have to I'd
have to do a little bit more research
sorry uh sure okay so
um leaving aside you know the research
you say you need to do if I was to put
you and I can bring up section 127 if
that would assist
um Mr registrar that is ccf6028
and it's page 230
.
so we see over there 127 says everyone
who without lawful excuse disobeys a
lawful order made by a court of justice
or by a person or body of persons
authorized by any act make or give the
order other than in order for the
payment of money is unless and that
talks about the punishment so you'd
agree though that an RCMP officer who
has the ability to enforce the criminal
code and always has this ability could
arrest somebody under Section 127 for
violating 127.
but you were referring to the injunction
and I don't know if an injunction falls
under the disobeying or an order of the
Court
that's fine but my question now is
whether an officer and our CMP officer
could arrest someone for contravening
Section 127 of the code
in all likelihood yes
all right so my question to you or I put
you that you know there's nothing that
legally prevented you from deploying
RCMP officers
to enforce the criminal code in Ottawa
but we aren't the police of jurisdiction
in Ottawa and so it is uh I don't know
if it's a common law or what Authority
it is
um
it would be like bringing Ottawa Police
Service and then putting them in
downtown Toronto and saying we're just
going to start policing
everybody there's a jurisdiction and and
there's a police of jurisdiction for a
reason and so if I find somebody
committing a criminal code offense and I
see them committing and it's under the
powers of arrest that I can in fact
arrest I I can arrest but um for this
for the purpose of this exercise we
would not simply walk in and decide that
we were the police of jurisdiction
um so could you imagine the Mayhem that
that would lead to if every police just
arrived and said we're going to be the
police of jurisdiction today
so I just want to sort of clarify you
know there may be a difference between
say tradition and respecting the
authority of local police and not
intruding on them or entrenching on them
but you'll agree that there is nothing
that legally prevented you from sending
RCMP officers to enforce the things that
they're all always allowed to do which
is the criminal code yes and we wouldn't
we weren't objecting to assisting in
that regard
so I I'm not that's why I'm not
understanding your questions all right
those are all my questions thank you
thank you okay next is the union of
British Columbia
Indian chief
good afternoon
is Cheyenne Arnold Cunningham I'm
counsel for the union of BC Indian
chiefs
and I will be directing all of our
questions today to commissioner lucky
Michener lucky did the RCMP consult with
First Nations governments or indigenous
groups or Representatives during the
Convoy situation
um I'm not sure no definitely not in the
Ottawa area as we weren't the police of
jurisdiction
um they may have done that in uh BC
Alberta and Saskatchewan I'm not sure
and generally speaking if there was in
fact
um indigenous involvement or if it was
on uh indigenous land they would have in
fact uh we have special liaison teams
for that
okay thank you actually would you mind
mentioning what the names of those teams
or or groups Maybe Who
take on the lead of consultation and
cooperation with local First Nations and
Indigenous groups each division has a
different name but they are divisionally
Zone teams or in BC I think they're
called the
ccg community
consultative indigenous groups or
something ccig sorry I I think it is
actually in John Brewer's email it's in
there sorry thank you so much that's
helpful are you familiar with uh bill
c-15 which received Royal ascent and
came into Force as Federal legislation
on June 21st 2021 to adopt and implement
the United Nations Declaration of the
rights of indigenous peoples also known
as undrip
yes not uh completely intimately but yes
I'm familiar with it
um I take it that you're familiar with
uh section five which mandates the
government of Canada to take all
measures necessary to align the laws of
Canada with undrip
yes
would you agree that andrit plays a
significant role in policing and police
policy in public order emergency events
um
if I and my understanding might not be
correct but
um if it involves
[Music]
um
um
indigen if it's indigenous protests I
believe that's where it connects itself
um so it might not be all protests but I
could be mistaken I haven't
intimately translated it into what it
actually meant
okay thank you
um your recent May 22
2022 mandate letter mandates the
acceleration of RCMP reform over the
next two years uh the union of BC Indian
chiefs uh is wondering if you could
explain what the RCMP is doing to ensure
implementation of undrip in the context
of
assembling demonstrations and public
order emergency events
that's a good question
um I know that there's been a lot of
work
developing liaison teams
when for example in some of the
indigenous protests that we have gone to
we've included cultural awareness and
and uh specific cultural training to the
area in which we're policing so that we
have a better understanding of the
impacts of our actions we have increased
obviously our training in general in
that regard
um the our liaison teams are specific to
um
protests on indigenous lands
which can be different than
non-indigenous lands for example having
a better understanding of the history
and the culture uh
thank you uh
actually earlier today of the management
Advisory Board as a recently established
body within the RCMP yes uh is there any
mandated First Nation civilian
representation on this board
um there was we had John Dom who was
representing us and we actually had um
uh Wally opal at the beginning but he uh
got put on a different uh
um mandate and we've had some vacancies
and so we're filling those vacancies we
don't I'm not responsible it's Public
Safety who's responsible for filling
those vacancies but part of that is the
diversity including indigenous
representation
thank you
and can you confirm whether or not
you're aware of the RCMP updating its
strategic plans and policies and
protocols to ensure alignment with
undrip or is that kind of work ongoing
it's it's ongoing in our initiatives we
have an in our contract in indigenous
policing we have many projects on the go
many of which are geared towards
reconciliation but there is also making
sure policies and procedures align
properly with
undrip and other recommendations that
have come out of other reports
okay thank you
um is policing response in a public
order emergency event different
depending on who is involved in that
assembly or event
uh no it's not it's not necessarily who
it's it's
um how I would say more how like um
depending on I think you have to have an
understanding of the issues uh and
that's what we spend a lot of time on
understanding why the protests occurred
in the first place trying to connect
with the organizers uh trying it's all
about you know we're all about peaceful
protests which we definitely promote and
we do everything we can through our
liaison teams to promote that peaceful
protest it's only when it becomes an
illegal blockade we can't on
unfortunately we you know when when
injunctions are brought to court we're
law enforcement we can't decide when or
or what we're going to enforce we don't
have that discretion but we do have the
discretion on how and when we enforce
but there's still the
duty to enforce uh if there's an
injunction in court but okay thank you
you
um if I could ask the clerk to please
bring up OPP
50601 and I'll just stay on page one of
that document
um commissioner lucky we've looked
actually at this email exchange today
already
um but on February 2nd 2022 there was an
email exchange between yourself
commissioner lucky and your subordinate
superintendent Brewer of e-division yes
and the email exchange Brewer notes at
the bottom of page one quote I slash we
do not presume to have all the answers
however we have been heavily engaged
with these sort of ideologically driven
protests for a while now
through hard-earned experience we have
managed to pick up a few strategies that
may help unquote he then refers to Old
growth logging Coastal Gas link and
other quote ideologically driven unquote
protests
you replied to his advice to say thank
you for the great response and you
referenced that you had used these
points
in your briefings of superiors like
ministers
the union of BC in the union of BC
Indian chiefs would like to know if
indigenous peoples advancing their
rights through public assembly and
awareness strategies would be considered
ideologically driven protests in the
same way or the same manner as the
freedom Convoy was considered
um I'm not sure I
have an opinion on that in the sense
that I think if somebody has
um
uh an opinion or they are uh um wanting
to uh hear their their voice in a
certain ID ideologically way it doesn't
mean that it's a negative thing when we
say I ideologically motivated towards
something
um like I said it's about
um it doesn't matter what the cause is
it's just making sure it's peaceful and
making sure it's following the rules
that are set out in in law
okay thank you
um just to ask one last follow-up
question on that
um considering indigenous peoples have
unique and distinct set of legal rights
and we see that in undrip and for
reference I can cite to articles 26 and
28.
um but oftentimes that indigenous
peoples do not have redress to properly
address their rights and oftentimes they
have to assemble in a public form to
seek recognition and implementation of
their rights in different contexts
do you think that there should be a
different response by government in
consideration of kind of this uniqueness
of indigenous assembly
I think it would be up to the lawmakers
to decide that I think peaceful protest
is absolutely necessary in a Democratic
Society and I think people should have
the right to have their voices heard and
of course because I'm in law enforcement
I'm probably a little bit biased in the
sense that
um peaceful protests we promote but if
it's not in line with the rule of the
law then then we are asked to intervene
okay thank you and I'm gonna wrap up
with just a few quick questions
um before I begin asking you our
questions today the deputy commission
commissioner
um today mentioned that he had not read
the aprilwash inquiry report
um commissioner lucky have you reviewed
this report uh I've read bits and pieces
but not uh cover to cover
okay thank you and are you aware of
dynamics of systemic racism and
specifically anti-indigenous
discrimination in policing and
responding to public order or emergency
events
um
as as a result of the upper wash in
regards to the upper wash report
uh no just just broadly within the RCMP
are you aware of dynamics of systemic
racism and policing of indigenous
peoples we are uh doing a lot of
initiatives within the RCMP in regards
to systemic racism we've introduced some
new courses that we've actually made
available to all police agencies uh
uniting Against Racism
um cultural awareness and humility
courses providing uh we're updating our
curriculums at our training academy
we've also have the blanket exercise
that is is at our training academy and
that is available for all employees of
the RCMP and it's all about and we've
reviewed our whole recruiting process to
make sure there's no systemic barriers
to prevent uh indigenous people but also
the bipod community and into entering
into the RCMP in our recruiting we're
trying to be more Progressive in our
proactive recruiters so that we would be
able to have
more indigenous people in the rsmp
because it's more representative of the
communities we serve and I think it
would make our would strengthen our
organization to have more indigenous
people as police officers in the RCMP so
we can connect with those communities we
do try to
have people that of that are indigenous
to go to indigenous communities that can
assist us but also you know we do have a
higher than average percentage in the
government for indigenous employees but
it's it's not something it's not very
high in general it's at about seven
percent and I think we need to have uh I
think if we had a greater diversity
within our organization it would bode
well for uh working in indigenous
communities working with indigenous
people on uh protecting their you know
rights and allowing them peaceful
protest
okay you're you're now out of time so if
you could wrap up the place
um may I ask one last question
yes go ahead
indigenous peoples defending their
rights and speaking up for their
distinct legal rights have been profiled
as causing public order emergency events
or disturbing the peace
we are now in an in a new era of
recognition and affirmation of
indigenous rights especially since the
passing of Bill c-15 would you agree
with that
I think we always have to progress as as
a police organization and ensure that we
are meeting the needs of the various uh
people that we protect and serve
and would you agree that it's important
for indigenous peoples to be able you're
no that's not one question you're now
into more than one okay my apologies
thank you so much for your time today
and thank you commissioner for the
opportunity to ask our questions today
thank you
okay next is the Ottawa coalition
good evening commissioner Emily tamman
for the Ottawa Coalition and we don't
have any questions thank you thank you
government of Alberta she's there
good afternoon for the record my name is
Stephanie Boos for the province of
Alberta all of our questions have been
asked and answered thank you
okay next is the Windsor Police Service
uh good evening all uh this is Tom McRae
for the Windsor Police Service we have
no questions but would like to give our
time to uh Canada please
okay next is the city of Windsor
good evening
um my name is Graham reader and I'm
counsel for the city of Windsor I'll be
directing my questions today to
commissioner lucky but I welcome any
input from Deputy Commissioner duhamem
if my question touches on his knowledge
instead okay your uh your camera doesn't
seem to be on if the I don't know if
that's your intention uh I don't have an
objection if the witnesses don't oh okay
not at all my apologies I had a
commissioner
um so I'll get started uh how many RCMP
officers
um you you uh commissioner like you you
talked about the odavision Detachment in
Windsor earlier this afternoon or this
morning rather
um how many approximately how many RCMP
officers are in that Detachment at
Windsor
yes I have no idea I I no I'd be
guessing I I would be guessing I have no
no idea okay
um do you know if there's a tactical
support group in uh stationed in Windsor
no there isn't it would be posted either
in London or Toronto and it's in the
major Center
Canada Municipal Police Force ask for a
tactical support group assistance
directly to the RCMP
well as we've learned obviously Ottawa
city police did that and we provided
resources generally speaking it's um
from police to police there's often
requests in our in where we are the
police of jurisdiction in Ontario we're
not uh we don't have that normal
jurisdiction so it's through the Ontario
Police act but often in places like
Alberta or Saskatchewan if there's
something going on in a major city like
Regina they may reach out to the RCMP to
assist in in a tactical response
okay and what does that process look
like when you are not the police of
jurisdiction can you just describe it
um well I like I said I've been told
that normally it goes through the
Ontario Provincial Police in on in in
Ontario where any municipality within
Ontario if they need additional
resources they go to the opp and they
may not need to ask the RCMP because the
opp may find resources at a neighboring
uh Detachment or or Municipal Municipal
Police agency within Ontario
understood so As I understood uh police
jurisdiction a municipal police force
would not go directly to the RCMP they
would go through the OPP yeah that's
what the normal course of event is
okay thank you would you agree with me
that when the RCP is not the police of
jurisdiction during A disruption
particularly at a Port of Entry as in
Windsor at the bridge
that the rcmp's role is to support the
police of jurisdiction and protecting
the Port of Entry
um not when we're we're not the police
of jurisdiction but we can assist any
police with the right process but uh in
for example in Ontario and Quebec if in
fact uh Windsor which is right on the
border if they needed assistance it
wouldn't automatically default to the
RCMP uh we're not we're not policing in
that capacity in Ontario or Quebec
okay understood
has the role of the RCMP changed at all
in Windsor with respect to the
protection of the bridge since the
Convoy protests
no not at all we're in Windsor our folks
are still uh focused on the federal
mandate
okay and to your knowledge has the RCMP
ever been the police of jurisdiction to
respond to events at the Ambassador
Bridge not to my knowledge
and it's not it's not because if it's a
federal uh location
uh it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
a federal concern or issue or policing
matter
we've heard that a couple times here
with the NCC grounds uh it should be
RCMP but again here in Ottawa the
police's jurisdiction for criminal
matters in the city of Ottawa is is uh
Ottawa Police Service
so
thank you those are all my questions
thank you okay thank you next uh is the
government of Canada
all right
good evening for the record I'm donnery
Nygaard I'm one of the council for
Canada
um
there's been a bunch of discussion today
about the various meetings that occurred
on the 13th but I just want to take you
back one day and if we could have uh SSM
NSC or dot NSC dot can
1.50214
and um just to situate you commissioner
this will be for you this these are the
IRG meeting minutes oh did I no that's
not it that these are the RG minutes or
they should be for the day before on
February 12th see that yes and this was
a virtual meeting of uh the incident
Response Group on that day and you
attended that virtual meeting yes
so if we can go to page six please of
the minutes
and if we can scroll down
uh just to where it says the
commissioner of the RCMP uh and
commissioner there's quite a long
excerpt and I'll let you have a quick
read over it
um it starts here and it goes down onto
the next page and I'm going to highlight
just a few things but I want to just let
you situate yourself first you can ask
the clerk when you want to scroll down
okay you can scroll
okay
okay
and I think that's the end of uh the
minutes that uh refer to your update uh
and so this was quite an extensive
update of what was happening across the
country
and you have uh I just want to draw your
attention to a few things if we go back
up to the beginning of where the
commissioner uh comments are started so
yeah right there uh so you started by
talking about uh things that were
happening uh at Thunder Bay and the GTA
and and then you went on to discuss the
situation in Windsor correct yes
yes uh and you mentioned uh the
negotiations that were occurring in
Windsor and the delivery of the letter
from the Ontario government
that occurred there but that the
protesters did not accept that letter
correct and then you also describe the
situation in Cornwall
at the bridge there yes
and then you go on to describe the
situation in Ottawa including halfway
down that paragraph uh
that there were a number of additional
convoys that were reportedly still
traveling towards Ottawa on February
12th yes and then you go on to describe
the situation in Coots on the next page
yes and you indicate there that the
situation in Coots is unique and there's
a heightened risk to safety of persons
including police
including indications of weapons on site
I just wanted to pause there for a
minute the arrests were made in Coots
the following day is that correct yes I
believe so on February 14th and so that
was the information that you uh were
given giving to this committee as a
whole at that point in time about what
was going on in Coots yes and then
finally uh you talked about the
situation in Emerson yes so with this
kind of sort of cross-country update on
February 12th is this what you were
referring to in uh your speaking notes
that you didn't actually get a chance to
give on February 13th when you said
there were some there's a number of
ongoing incidents which we're all well
aware of yes this is the normal type of
situational report I would give
uh and and I think this is probably
um being cleared up by my friends but
just uh to to make sure you didn't you
did appear in the at the IRG and at the
cabinet meeting on February 13th but you
did not speak at either of those
meetings correct yes uh but the notes
that you had prepared for those meetings
you did in fact pass along to various
people correct yes so and if we can pull
up PB NSC can four zeros three two five
six
and this is uh you've seen this already
but
just
this is the the email that you sent to
Mr Jones and can you tell us who Mike
Jones is he's the chief of staff to the
minister men and Chino so he's in
Minister managino's office is that
correct uh and you would expect him to
pass this information on to minister
manager absolutely
uh and so
in in what you set out uh in that email
to Mr Jones that was
um
other than the situational report but as
far as your discussion of the emergency
measures act that was included in that
email correct yes and then if we can
pull up
pb.nsc.can four zeros3245
and that was at um
sorry that previous email was at 7 47.
oh this is it's still up there it's yes
1247 which means it was 747 so that was
prior to the cabinet meeting correct yes
and then you also forwarded it on
directly uh to MS MR menachino and also
to Jody Thomas and can just for those
who don't know who is Jody Thomas the
National Security advisor uh that and
she's the National Security advisor to
the Prime Minister correct yes and uh
this particular email includes the
majority of those speaking points uh
that you had earlier prepared to speak
at the meeting yes correct so that
information was passed on to both of
those individuals uh at 803 by the looks
of it uh from the from the timestamp on
there is that correct yes thank you and
part of that briefing uh one of my
friends took you to this had to do with
the guns that had been stolen in
Peterborough correct or part of your
your talking points had been to alert
people to that do you recall that yeah
I'm not sure if it was this it was
another meeting I think or may have been
this one I'm not sure I think if we
scroll down in in here we will and I
didn't make a note of the plate all
right there it is all right yes very
good okay you're right it was this
meeting so that was information that you
had had passed on on February 13th
correct and my friend indicated that uh
that those and at this point in time uh
you say that uh it's still being looked
into there's an ongoing investigation uh
you don't know if it's related to the
current protest at that point in time
correct yes and my friend rightly
pointed out that uh it was sorted out
rather quickly and the guns were
thankfully uh retrieved a couple of days
later but that wasn't an that was on
February 16th as I recall after the
emergencies Act was invoked is that
right yes and uh if we go to
uh the February 16th IRG minutes which
is
ssm.nsc.can 50401
and if we go just onto the uh the third
it's page five at the top of the page
yes if we scroll down a little at the oh
uh right there to the National Security
advisor providing her update and you'll
see there uh it says about halfway down
while some trucks
uh oh no sorry no the wrong place oh it
says notably the weapons that had been
stolen in Peterborough have been
recovered is that what you're yes yes
exactly
um so
she was
um
she was providing that information but I
assume she got that information from you
correct
and so everyone was informed that that
was no longer a worry as of February
16th but that was that was the first
that was when the weapons were actually
received that's when I'm assuming yes
and
uh my friends also uh discussed with you
the delegation of the provisions the
authorities that were provided to you
under the emergencies act in regard to
tow trucks and I just want to take you
to the February uh
17th IRG minutes the next day which is
SSM and
page five again
and about halfway down the page just
after those redactions
um if I can have you read that
now which one just after this the second
set of redactions there second set she
also confirmed that she has delegated
some powers to other RCMP and OPP
officers to be able to compel or
commandeer equipment such as tow trucks
confirming that the RCMP will cover
costs associated with this RCMP will
cash manage these pressures in the short
term so my question to you is I think
you said earlier that you had only
delegated those powers to commissioner
karit this indicates that you'd uh
delegated them to other RCMP members as
well so did you delegate those Powers
internally to the commanding officers
and the other divisions I I don't think
so but I may uh if I had it would have
been to uh uh the commanding officer of
e-division
um sorry BC Alberta and Manitoba but I
don't think I I think there was plans to
but they never got they never needed
them so that might have been not exactly
accurate okay
and then on still staying on the tow
truck theme can we have pb.can.401628
and maybe we can just scroll through so
the commissioner can see the entire
document
do you do you recognize this yes can you
tell us what it is this is the receipt
for the uh various tow trucks that were
uh used during the protests that after
the uh as as part of the Authority Under
the emergency Act
so it it's an invoice from uh if we can
scroll back up a little bit
it's to the Royal Canadian Mounted
Police uh and if we scroll down
further
it's from the problem it's coming from
Ontario so do you
so
your uh your evidence is that this is
the receipt that was sent to you from
Ontario for the tow trucks that were
compelled under the emergencies act yes
because I think you had said earlier it
was it was a big
bill but you hadn't uh I think we're
still cash managing
um
and is it your understanding
uh
what well what is your understanding of
your uh the rcmp's authority to pay this
bill
um well it's the federal government will
cover the costs they've asked us to pay
for it and then uh cash manage it and if
we need the money back we'll get the
money back
um but pay for what what do you what are
you given authority to pay pay for the
uh use of tow trucks in the uh in the
protests the commandeering of tow trucks
and the use of those tow trucks to
remove vehicles
thank you
and Deputy duhammer I want to turn to
you for a moment with some of the other
powers that were granted under the
emergencies Act
one of my friends from the ccela spoke
to you about in particular the economic
provisions of the powers that were
granted under the emergencies act and
you mentioned that the RCMP did not
take any action in relation to insurance
contracts and did I hear that correctly
yeah that's correct uh and why is that
uh well I we focused on on the freezing
of providing the right information to
the banks to the financial services to
freeze the accounts uh the insurance yes
that was a possibility one of the
concerns we had is a few freeze
Insurance where the truck go if
someone's ready to leave
puts us in a position so we didn't
really look at that really focused on
identifying the people validating who
was there and getting the information to
the financial services
and that sort of exercise of discretion
in in how and which particular aspects
of a law to enforce at any given time is
that something that the police normally
do or is that unusual the discretion is
something and and you have to remember
as I said earlier that we had 24 hours
to figure this out as well as the
financial services so we went with the
one that we figured would have the
greatest impact
commissioner I want to take you back to
some more of the IRG minutes that uh
from the meetings that took place while
the emergencies Act was in place and uh
I'd like to go to the February 18th
minutes
which uh are SSM and SC can 50403
and when we get there to page five
please your updates always seem to be
yeah I'm just going to say page five is
pretty popular
foreign
so if it can scroll down to the second
last paragraph on the page
so that paragraph that starts as it
relates to additional activity over the
weekend
uh
there are reports of additional convoys
on route to join the Ottawa protest
including the Alberta Freedom Convoy
three chartered buses from Toronto at
two from Saint Jerome and Gatineau
police are ready to intercept and divert
these convoys where possible
those that ability to divert convoys is
what is that based on that's based on
one of the authorities in the emergency
Act
and
if we can also
sorry I'm afraid I didn't take very good
notes here
um we'll go to uh the next days
IRG at SSM NSC can
five zeros
oh no sorry it's not the next day uh
406. this is a couple of days later a
few days later on February 21st
and it's page five again
and if we can scroll down to the second
last paragraph again
and you'll see there in in the middle of
the or to the beginning of the paragraph
it talks about uh a convoy traveling
from Fort McMurray to Ottawa was indeed
intercepted by the Ontario Provincial
Police
who advise participants not to go to
Ottawa but not prevent them from
continuing their trip and uh is it your
understanding that that advice or what
is your understanding of the advice that
was given by the OPP that at that point
if you have an understanding well just
uh with the emergency act the
authorities were not to go into a
protest area so they they were advised
not that they wouldn't be allowed to go
into Ottawa so some of them went to
Armed prior there there was a a
secondary uh not a protest site but a
secondary site where trucks were conver
uh getting together at another site but
that wasn't there was no protest at that
area okay
uh and if we can just go back a couple
of days the commissioner has asked
questions a couple of times about the
ability
for people to to lawfully protest while
this enforcement action was being taken
so I wanted to take you to the iig
minutes of February 20th which is
ssmnsc.can 50405.
page five
and if you know just um
just uh scrolling down
just before the redaction a little ways
up from the redaction there you'll see a
police order units continue to wear
tactical gear I'm sorry no next one
police are also monitoring a gathering
that has formed at the war museum of
approximately 100 people in a small look
at the Ring of 30 to 50 individuals at
Confederation Park
so
um can you tell me what you know about
those those Gatherings and
oh of course there's always uh potential
for lawful protest in and around Ottawa
that's two examples
um uh these people were lawfully
protesting they weren't impeding the
full traffic or the flow of pedestrian
traffic and so I I believe that they
were allowed to continue with their
protest and we monitor those protests
because it's not just the safety of of
people not in the protest it's also
safety of the protesters when they're
lawfully protesting we want to make sure
that they are safe when they're doing
that
but they they were permitted to remain
there and protest thank you
you in answering some questions
um
for Council for former Chiefs slowly you
indicated uh that the protest in Ottawa
wasn't a national security event it was
just an event I think you said yes uh
and and you were specifically talking
about the Ottawa situation
yes I I say it was part of a national
event it wasn't a national security uh
threat but when you say that you're not
assessing whether or not uh either the
Ottawa protest or the situation in the
country as a whole was a threat to the
security of Canada correct
no we had like I said I think I
mentioned earlier there was indication
there was some Snippets of information
on open source and that came through
intelligence uh things that were similar
to the storming of the parliament but
none of it manifested itself so that it
wasn't a national security threat it was
a national event
but in answer to one of my other friends
questions about uh the the definition in
the thesis act that that's not something
that you were turning your mind to or
that you were assessing no and it
definitely wouldn't be me doing any of
the assessments I'm just the uh
messenger there'd be people a lot
smarter than myself
doing that
and Deputy duhammer I wanted to share a
few moment uh to discuss the the plan
that was
put in place and developed by the
integrated planning unit in Ottawa and
um you as the gold Commander what was
your view of how that plan was
eventually executed
the final plan I mean I think the result
speaks for itself uh minimal Force used
in the execution and over a couple days
two days and a half we're able to
successfully clear
um the the sites I I should mention that
there's approximately seven or eight
sites where the trucks were parked in
downtown area and by the time we got to
the first one would be Weller and
Nicholas by the time we were done that
we took care of Sussex and
Welding Sussex and redo Sussex and
Rideau and then the third site was in
front of Parliament Hill and by the time
we're done with Parliament Hill all the
other sites had the people had left so I
think the results speak for itself
there's no injuries uh very little use
of force and it was done in a
coordinated fashion very professionally
thank you
and in that plan when it was developed
what was the role of tow trucks
it was uh it was I should say it was a
phase-in approach in a sense and you
heard the commissioner mention about the
role of the plts on that Thursday night
February 17th February 17th Thursday
there was an increased presence in the
control access zone or what became the
control axis Zone there's increased
communication with the people who are
there informing them what the ACT is
give them an opportunity to leave and
it's only Friday morning with light snow
on the ground that we started
operationalizing so what would happen is
we go to one site and this is the
typical typical procedures where tell
the people to leave if they don't leave
then use the right amount of force
necessary but then once if we have the
rest people leave if people left it was
good if we had to arrest people and
remove them tow trucks would come in tow
the vehicles and impound them
okay uh and and that was an integral
part of the overall plan to clear out
Ottawa it was uh for the first three
sites for sure
and you wouldn't have been able to
accomplish that without those heavy tow
trucks we would have had to explore
other options
yeah
but
there weren't many other options
for big rigs what are your other options
I I take it you you can't uh articulate
any other options at this point
no
uh and you've both spoken about the need
to shrink the footprint when dealing
with protests in general and this
protest in particular can you um either
of you or both of you explain to us why
that's important
well it's all about uh Public Safety and
officer safety so when you have
um thousands of people that is not the
time to do enforcement because the risk
to public and police safety is at a much
higher level so even sometimes if
there's a criminal court offense
sometimes you will deal with it after
the fact because if you go inside that
crowd to deal with it you might in flare
that crowd and just police presence can
be enough to inflare a crowd
um on the right time at the you know
being at their being there at the wrong
time so what are our tactics are usually
to reduce a footprint through
incentivizing or motivating people to
leave obviously uh uh sometimes it's uh
as simple as you will be arrested but
there's always going to be groups of
protesters who will stay and will wish
to be arrested but you so you can't you
still have to get rid of that footprint
so I'll obviously in in the Ottawa
scenario on the weekends it was far too
big and so trickling off Monday and you
know looking at past we looked at past
weeks and our numbers were the lowest on
I think it was Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday so that was the time the to
start doing the enforcement
unfortunately we lost some time in our
plan so we did a very uh you know quick
engagement of two days with the crowds
to say uh now the emergency Act is here
this is what will happen yeah if you
don't leave these are some of the
consequences there was many people who
actually wanted to leave but their
trucks were kind of stuck in amongst
trucks and those people we we tried to
make arrangements when the time came to
move those trucks to get them off the
out off the site and once the footprint
was down to uh the minimum numbers we
felt we could get them down to that's
when we started our enforcement auction
and that that makes it a safer
environment for everybody
if I if I may add and it's I believe is
Chief slowly who shared this at a
briefing or uh Steve Bell uh when you're
referring to a lot of people they were
they were in a situation that in some
instances they couldn't perform an
arrest on an individual because the Ops
uh would be swarmed by people around the
police car and the only tactical uh
option would be just to release the
individual and get out of there so the
controlled access Zone that was in place
on Friday morning that that that was uh
that was a benefit to uh our operations
in the sense that Friday morning there's
no one that was entering that the
control access Zone other than the
people that were already there they're
not allowed to leave not allowed to come
back so that limited and the fact that
the work that was being done with
regards to informing the people what the
EA is uh I seriously think that deterred
people for coming to see what was going
on on the Fridays and Saturdays
so so that prevented the footprint from
growing as it normally would what was
done uh to shrink the footprint that was
already there before the enforcement
action was taken allowing people the
opportunity to leave and telling them
the consequences of some of the
consequences that would happen and some
of the new authorities that we had under
the emergency Act
so for instance the financial
authorities were one
um one incent we we had
um some of our police officers reporting
that people were leaving because their
spouse had called and said you need to
get home so we can get the account
unfrozen and
um so we're motivated and and you've
also spoken I have two more questions
okay you've also spoken
um
about uh children to some extent can you
tell me why uh what what the risks are
or the concerns are in relation to
having children uh in the vicinity when
you're taking enforcement action well
because we we can't predict how that
enforcement action is going to go we we
want to do it with the minimal amount of
force but um if all of a sudden that
turns and we would have to use more uh
force or get into maybe
um using
um some kind of irritant we don't want
children there we don't want anybody to
get harmed and and children can't really
defend themselves as adults can run and
know what direction to go because we
always provide an egress but children
aren't uh you know able to do that in
all cases
and
So based on all of the things that
you've you've just said would it be fair
to say that the enforcement action in
this case couldn't have happened in the
way that it did without the emergencies
Act
I would say the emergency act allowed us
to have uh the safest type of
enforcement it allowed us to reduce that
footprint because there was large
amounts of people there and it not only
allowed us to reduce the footprint it
allowed us to stop people from coming in
and we saw how every weekend those
numbers grew tenfold and uh it avoided
people coming into the area
we obviously blocked off the areas as
well
and it allowed for us much safer result
and I think Mike Deputy Commissioner Dem
said said it himself the results speak
for themselves thank you those are
online questions
okay any re-examination
uh thank you commissioner I have uh just
two areas that all
re-examine on if
you'll accommodate that I I realize
we're running late in the day so I'll be
as quick as I can go ahead the first of
them I think they're both for you Deputy
Commissioner the first one has to do
with some uh answers you gave to
questions uh about meetings you were at
with senior government officials where
you were I'll just use word
uncomfortable I don't think you voiced a
strong principled objection but you were
uncomfortable
uh that perhaps that line between
government and police might if not be
crossed I think you used the word was
getting blurred by the presence of those
senior officials at the meetings do you
recall that evidence yeah and and the
way I wrote it and what was going
through my mind through different things
but I I found that having having them
and this is my opinion it's having them
Reach directly in uh kind of blur the
communication because I've always said
I haven't seen if if you look at the
police act the minister of Public Safety
solicitor general the commissioner OPP
all have a role to play
um when something's unfolded in Ontario
and I just think that having Federal
representative reaching in just blurred
the lines as to exactly
um request how the requests should be
funneling in I viewed it as the
commission is ultimately responsible for
the RCMP and any briefing of government
departments should be done but this is
my own opinion should be done to ensure
that we keep we keep each other in this
in the right lanes and whatnot thank you
and do you remember which meeting it was
that that brought that to your to your
that focused your attention on that
point I don't remember exactly what
meeting I'd have to go through my notes
but it was one where we're with Chief
slowly and other people around the table
because obviously uh Public Safety and
PCO wanted to talk to Mr slowly but I
don't recall everybody who's on that
call
do you ever call whether there was more
than one meeting where you had this same
discomfort
um I think that was the only one because
as of around the 12th of February I
broke off and was designed full time to
the uh for the RCMP side of the Convoy
so I I think that was the only
okay thank you the the second line of
questions uh has to do with your uh
answers to questions about freezing bank
accounts or giving Banks information
that they would use uh as you put it to
exercise their discretion to freeze
accounts
and I'm I'm not going to uh well let me
Begin by reminding uh
uh you you of the two caveats you made
and that just so you know you know that
these questions are asked with those two
caveats in mind the first one I remember
was you saying
we didn't write this law
and the other one was we had maybe 24
hours to implement it so we had to move
very quickly so not only just the not
only law enforcement but Financial
Services as well had to figure out how
we're going to process with all this
well well put so so both you had to
initiate action and then the financial
services industry had to react to that
all within a very short period of time
so we accept those caveats but I want to
I want to ask you about your so the way
you phrased it which is that uh the
notice is you uh gave to the financial
institutions didn't require the
financial institution to freeze the
account it gave them the discretion to
form their own view about whether the
account should be Frozen now what I've
got in front of me is the act uh or
sorry the regulation and the the actual
notice uh that that the RCMP served on
financial institutions but let me see if
I can do it without taking you to to
those documents would you agree with me
that in effect you strike me as a
practical uh man Deputy Commissioner in
effect once the financial institution
got one of those notices that absent for
example that you gave some exceptional
information that the bank had that the
information they'd been given by the
RCMP was just wrong absent that
information they were effectively Bound
by the regulations to take measures to
stop dealing with that customer yeah and
I said discretion because I'm not
familiar with the exact language that's
in the order or the regs if they had to
I'm not quite sure our responsibility
was to provide that information to the
financial services and then they uh they
had I'm not going to say an obligation
but they were the ones responsible for
deciding if they're going to freeze it
or not based on the information that
they might have in their Holdings and
the information that we had
would it be fair to say that you fully
expected the financial institutions to
stop dealing with these customers as
soon as you gave them the name and they
confirmed that they held accounts in
that name
to a certain degree yes but I don't know
what the bank had in their Holdings with
regards to these individuals won't we
once we identified them okay thank you
that that will uh that will serve for my
purposes and so Mr commissioner those
are my questions in re-examination
okay thank you
um but I know you all want to get out of
here but if if and I know we have a
witness waiting who probably is even
eager more eager than you to get out of
here but if I could just ask a couple of
very uh just a few questions
firstly
we spoke about the Hendon report and I
think this is for you a Deputy
Commissioner but it it seems to me odd
that the hinden report if you've looked
at it is really a
National in scope and I don't really
understand why that function is being
carried out by the OPP rather than the
RCMP and I realize it's shared and OPP
has the RCMP as input in it
but it would it would have been sort of
my sense that that should be a national
initiative do you have a comment on that
so a new commissioner also if you'd like
so I'll lead it off commissioner I I'm
not I didn't see the Hendon report my
understanding is
there's not there's National there's
National information coming in from
different provinces but the henon report
my understanding that in the report was
really
um a view of what was going on in the
province of Ontario but being fed in
from different organizations that was my
understanding of the project and so that
the opp was in a position to have a a
view a good understanding of what was
going on in the province of Ontario
which which they facilitated a lot of
the work for the commissioner when she's
briefing downtown because we relied on
our partners to provide that that
situational uh report when it comes to
what was going on in Ontario so my
understanding is is really focused on
the province but there's National
Intelligence that was fed in from events
going on across the country
and I I would add I don't it's not
unusual for something to originate from
outside the RCMP and I would think that
eventually if this was something that
was ongoing
um there would be a point where we would
probably pass it off we would take it
and if it became National and scope but
I think it was because of the fact that
things were going to converge on in
Ontario and they were dealing with
various aspects of that it originated as
uh Deputy Commissioner Dum so I and I'm
not intimately familiar with the report
myself but yeah I think it originated
from an Ontario need but developed into
something bigger bigger and I guess
the follow-up question is is there
something that the RCMP produces that's
equivalent to the Hendon report that's
that updates nationally
so we we were sorry but we do have like
each province has a criminal
intelligence service that is integrated
with all police agencies uh so there's
uh
cisbc CIS Alberta and each one of those
are integrated and they we have a
centralized Bureau so all of it can go
in that way I think it was more sort of
a uh like almost like a task force of
intelligence taken out to to examine
something specific because we have all
kinds of mechanisms to feed that
information and uh and and and produce
those types of reports uh nationally we
do have a team that looks at it from on
a monthly basis of different events that
are taking place across Canada and we'll
we'll prepare a document to that uh
obviously when it gets uh when it gets
bigger and starts moving uh you'd have
to look at uh probably uh increasing but
on a on a monthly basis we do provide a
report our Intel folks do provide a
report what's going on across the
country and throughout this this uh
throughout this uh uh even even before
they arrived in Ottawa uh our
ideological motivated criminal
intelligence team did produce some
strategic threat advisory just informing
people the community uh both law
enforcement and and the government as to
key things that are going on some of the
things that we're seeing and that was
fed into a lot of the combined
intelligence group as well it don't get
me wrong I'm not seeking to to criticize
I'm just I have a recommendation mandate
and I'm trying to understand what
is good what can happen whether some
changes so well there's another there's
another Avenue for that because under
those
um
criminal intelligence bureaus there's
what we call a national executive
committee that has representatives from
each province they meet once a year they
mandate the criminal intelligence
Service Canada of what uh what they want
to dig deeper into they could actually
be tasked with doing a whole report on
protests or doing you know the opioid
crisis they do various different reports
on specific elements as per the
recommendations of that national
executive committee which are all police
officers from across the country
okay
um turning to another subject where did
the officers come from that participated
in the enforcement action in Ottawa do
you have any idea where factually they
did come from so
if my number serves me right I think
there's 14 different public order units
that were deployed to Ottawa 16. okay
there goes my memory and I think there's
a somewhere around 25 or 26 different
law enforcement agencies or Department
that participated in what took place
here and I I do have a list of the
different organizations that
participated but I don't have it with me
so RCMP from different provinces they
all participated
for the most part and then there was
Saskatoon City Police Calgary City
police all the major municipalities
provided resources as well but we do
have an actual list if you
um okay and and which leads me to the
next question in the period
leading immediately leading up to and at
the time uh that the emergency was
declared and the actions and the actions
in Ottawa uh what was the status of
police resources available
if there had been another crisis
somewhere I'm just trying to get a sense
of where what was the status of the
police resources for regular policing as
is necessary and to cover for
some emergency any kind whether it's a I
can't speak to them to
to side of the RCMP but that's exactly
why we only draw 10 percent at any given
time out of a province Plus at that 10
we also have Federal resources that are
uh like uh Deputy Dem explained we have
5 000 across the country uh we can draw
on those resources they aren't uh
respond First Responders they are on
important tier one investigations for
example but they're not First Responders
and that's why on the provincial side
under our provincial uh uh and Municipal
Services agreement we only can draw up
to ten percent for that very reason so
that we're not uh leaving some area
vulnerable by taking too many from one
area
the uh the initial initial concern
commissioner is we were seeing uh some
popping up here and there and that's why
we decided to go within the organization
the first step was to use federal
policing uh members across the country
so it has no impact as the commissioner
said on the front line policing in those
provinces
uh uh and again for uh as the
commissioner said I'm not able to speak
on behalf of other uh law enforcement as
to what was that uh threshold for them
where they felt comfortable in releasing
a number of members so and another
example I don't believe we took any
resources from BC because you'll hear
from Deputy Commissioner sablocki he had
invoked an article 9 to take resources
from BC for his situation
okay and would there be many Pou units
available for redeployment that weren't
already deployed to Ottawa and to BC or
rather to Alberta at the time or I just
I don't know how many there are
available
I I don't either yeah um but most big
municipalities have their own uh public
order units so
um and some of our bigger divisions have
two uh or one of our divisions has two
we don't have anything in in certain
divisions but I I would say that uh the
number of public order units I'm not
sure how many they have in Ontario but
there was a a big majority of the public
order units were here in Ottawa so from
from a RCMP perspective we do have a
public order unit in in um in in the
province of Quebec and we have two units
here in Ontario one in Toronto and and
one here in national capital region and
mindful that this is not a full-time job
these are people that are they're on
regular duties and then they volunteered
to this type of work and uh
in the larger divisions they might be
one or two public order units I know
that substance Quebec have two or three
public units there's one here to assist
us but it varies as the commissioner
said from one uh from one agency to
another
but there's no no
sort of central number uh available uh
to
that that
you can tell me about
we do have all the numbers that of the
resources that came here but to say
whether they've surpassed a threshold
um and and it's important to note that
like I said these people are not
full-time so we're actually taking from
the front line uh Frontline policing
when we take some of them are federal
resources some of them aren't but for
the most part they're uh uniformed
police officers that are doing that as
an additional duty
okay and then
you you spoke about or you were taken to
your memo uh or speaking notes for uh
the IRG and uh about uh the fact that
criminal code is really sort of utilized
and you remember those notes I guess my
my question is did you make any
recommendation to IRG or the cabinet on
the invocation of the emergencies act no
we we stayed away from that on it was
for them to decide if it was necessary
if they had the have had met the
threshold
um that was for uh
it's it's no different than um any of
the other legislations that we are
um uh providing input on we provide you
know the input on in regards to
questions same as cannabis legislation
uh
the gun legislation we provide the
subject matter experts in that field but
we don't say whether it's absolutely
needed or not that's for the
parliamentarians to do that did you have
a view
um
I think now obviously I have a view now
I think and we've talked about it in I
have a Chiefs of police Roundtable and
we've talked about should we be looking
at some of these authorities and looking
at if there's some regulations that
could be put into place to add to these
to give us additional authorities and
like I said it's not for the people who
are legally protesting it's for the ones
that uh refuse to leave and are blocking
roads and downtowns and and disabling
vehicles and not wanting to leave that's
what the the legislation or regulations
or we put it would be helpful because
the only motivation we have for people
to leave the area is to arrest which
means then often that means we have to
resort to some level of enforcement
which could lead to an intervention
which again now we're using uh some
level of force for arrest
um which is not where we want to go when
people are refusing to leave because a
lot of these people are very true to
their cause and it we don't want to have
to be forced to use that type of
intervention so if there's things that
may may motivate people to leave that do
not involve the police uh that's that's
something that
um you know should be considered
which gets me to my final question do
you have any recommendations do you any
suggestions as to what I should be
recommending either with respect to
the relationship of the RCMP with the
the government with respect to the
emergencies act or protests of this type
uh I think one of the ones that was
mentioned is the facilitating a uh an
ease of you know uh swearing you know
members uh from anywhere in Canada
um you know providing some type of
recommendation that would ease that I
don't know why
um that would would be something that we
need to do uh as and provide an
impediment it's not like somebody's
going to come into a province and just
start enforcing laws it's when we have
additional uh request uh uh request for
assistance there's one looking at the
authorities that were in the emergencies
act and and nobody is you know nobody
wants to infringe on anybody's Charter
of Rights um but when people aren't
following the laws this is where like I
said we don't want to be having to use
Force to deal with that
um we don't
pick and choose what we enforce we just
uh that that's the unfortunate uh
position that we're in and I think um
uh more and more people are going to
want to let their voices be heard
and I I wouldn't want this to be you
know
increasing exponentially so that the
police are dealing with this and you
know that that 24 days that that lasted
that was a huge drain on all resources
and policing and also it undermines uh
policing who are trying to uh you know
keep things as peaceful as possible but
you know we talk about if we went in too
early what would be the circumstance
what would people what would be the
commentary if we came in too early and
did a quick enforcement we'd probably be
criticized for that criticized for late
enforcement so how do we deal with this
and not letting it last for 24 days
um because I don't think it's acceptable
in anybody's buses that that went on for
as long as it did but it was a difficult
situation and I I've said this before I
can't imagine the pressure that Chief
slowly was under during those days and
it's it's not an easy thing to reconcile
with
okay Deputy uh I I would add
commissioner that uh
I think the whole
definition that we find under the
parliament act with regards of
Parliament Hill and the precinct should
be Revisited
uh and and set those boundaries where
there's limited traffic in certain areas
that the downtown core of Ottawa that's
that's something other than that I think
the commissioner covered uh covered it
again it would be nice if uh if I was
told that the swearing in process
although I thought it was smooth I was
told that there were some hiccups or
bumps on the road so if there's any way
we could do it from a national
perspective
that would be that would be great too so
okay well thank you both very much for
your testimony and your perseverance
in all these questions and I understand
you're not feeling a little under the
weather commissioner so that's
appreciated that you came nonetheless
thank you thank you sir so I think we're
going to go on to our next witness
finally
um I don't know if we need a couple of
minutes to change the uh the setup
yes so we need maybe five minutes so
we'll just take a few minutes to uh
get the witness up and organized
the commission is in races for five
minutes
thank you foreign
so we have our Final witness for the day
uh
we have here with the Swarm please
will you swear on a religious document
or do you wish to affirm
please
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out my name is Curtis
Michael zablocki zablocki spelled
z-a-b-l-o-c-k-i
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so happy God yes I do
thank you
thank you
good evening uh Deputy Commissioner
zablocki and uh
my name is Gordon Cameron you might
remember we met out in Saskatoon for the
interview of you and your colleagues and
uh
now the summary of that interview that
you will have looked at to confirm its
accuracy has already been adopted by
those who proceeded before you but while
I've got you in the sand as
uh what I'm going to do is just ask you
to confirm that you did review that
summary of your interview and to your
knowledge and belief it's accurate is
that correct thank you for that Mr
Cameron on page 18 there's an amendment
or a correction that I would like to
make uh in the context of that summary
please go ahead then thanks yeah I
believe it's the first paragraph on page
18 about halfway through there's a
sentence that refers to
um well it uses uses the words lip
service in the context of uh the towing
Association that that we're working with
within the province of Alberta and then
infers that that we weren't uh getting
straight information our clear
information from that towing service and
I I believe that's inaccurate quite
quite to the contrary they were working
and doing their best to be helpful
okay well thank you for that
clarification and correction and with
that uh correction uh you can confirm
that the summary of your interview is
otherwise accurate I will do that yes
thanks thank you very much
I'd like to begin by uh asking you uh
to describe some of this well let me ask
you you were in the audience when the
commissioner and the Deputy Commissioner
were justifying earlier today
off and on through the day okay yes sir
some of this will will uh we'll repeat
that but just so that you can put your
evidence in context can you describe uh
what division of the RCMP is under your
command and how that fits in with the
national uh the way that the RCMP is
organized nationally yes certainly so
I'm the commanding officer for what we
call K division which is the province of
Alberta and the commissioner so myself
as a Deputy Commissioner I'm a direct
report to the commissioner to
commissioner lucky
and uh
we've we've heard that the country is
divided up into divisions uh and uh
we're going to hear a little bit uh
about uh the interaction between your
division K division which is
geographically Alberta and if I've got
it correctly e division which is
geographically the province of British
Columbia is that correct that's correct
and did you also interact with the
Prairie Provinces or any of the other
divisions the new division not in the
context uh of the Kutz protests no okay
thank you
um
can you describe
what role the RCMP plays as the police
in the province of Alberta
certainly so the RCMP
um is the contracted Provincial Police
Service for the province of Alberta so
there's a a contract between Public
Safety Canada and the province of
Alberta with the RCMP as the Provincial
Police Service or the police service
provider within the province so in
essence the Provincial Police Service
has responsibility for policing
communities with populations of less
than 5 000 persons in addition we police
communities with populations above 5000
that have a desire to contract
uh with the RCMP to avoid that policing
services and those are primarily in the
context of municipalities so we have 48
Municipal policing contracts in addition
to our our broader provincial policing
contract uh within Alberta and of course
within those responsibilities we also uh
police a number of indigenous
communities and metis settlements as
well
thank you that's a very complete
description now now just because uh
uh I want to
get past the conception a lot of us have
that the RCMP is only a national or is
Canada's national police force when you
are the police of jurisdiction when you
are in effects the Provincial Police for
the province of Alberta you're wearing
RCMP uniforms correct very very true yes
okay but but you are in a fact the same
type of police force as the opp is in
Ontario or the surictated Quebec is in
Quebec is that correct that's correct
they are Provincial Police Services and
those two uh locations you've mentioned
as we are within the province of Alberta
and the same is true of e-division in
British Columbia they are the Provincial
Police of British Columbia that's true
yes thank you
and you described the the way that your
policing uh can flow down to
municipalities and with respect to Coots
in particular which we're going to
obviously focus on today
was there any other police force with
jurisdiction in Kutz or the vicinity
relevant to the blockade at Coots other
than the RCMP no the jurisdiction for
policing in Coots the community of Coots
in the area was the the jurisdiction of
the Provincial Police Service or the
RCMP thank you
and just I'll just see if I can refine
that a little bit that that was all uh
the RCMP K division as Provincial Police
not any of the municipal
you not where you were providing
Municipal police forces correct okay
thank you
can you uh help us with the I'll give
the acronym and the name the community
conflict mediation group The ccmg and
where that fits in your organization for
k group doubtless it's the same for the
the other divisions but if you can
describe it for k group a k division for
us yeah certainly so that is uh a group
of trained individuals that we use I'll
say to intervene or engage in protest uh
situations like we had at Coots these
are individuals that are trained in
um in um mediation negotiation they're
trained to to engage communicate open
the channels of communication they're
trained to de-escalate as well so it'd
be similar to the plts that I think
maybe have been described uh previously
during the commission here and such so
we often utilize these teams to engage
with the organizers of protests and
advance of protests if we have alerts
and and information to suggest there's
going to be blockades or or issues or
challenges around protests
and are some or all of the members of of
the uh
ccmg uh full-time and dedicated to that
role or all of them perhaps some
part-time how does that get structured
in K division right so these are our
police officers that have substantive
work outside of their ccmg roles
but if but if an event arose where uh
some interaction with a public order
incident was required you would call on
those people perhaps take them out of
whatever other station they're in and
bring them to the location where they're
required correct yes correct
and uh is it is it fair to say that uh
in K Division and in the province of
Alberta those officers uh would get some
reasonable level of experience at that
work uh given both the environmental and
perhaps uh indigenous issues that are
encountered uh in in the province of
Alberta yeah that's a very accurate uh
statement uh our folks have engaged in a
number of uh uh protest situations
giving them that experience thank you
now now coming uh to the uh events in
question at at Coots
um
can you describe first just to begin the
story where you first where and when
where you saw the the the protests
forming up when you first became aware
of it how did this first come to your
attention or perhaps people who report
to you when it first came to their
attention yeah I think it first came to
our attention in uh well I'll say in
January 19th we received some open
source information
uh suggesting that there was going to be
a protest or a blockade at Coots the
very next day on the 20th of of January
uh again on the 19th there was a a
separate uh source of information uh
received I believe was open source
information that suggested there was
going to be a blockade on the 29th of
January at Coots so the 20th came and
went without any uh protest without any
activity at the Coots uh Port of Entry
on January 26th we received some further
open source information
about a potential blockade
Convoy 2 codes and a potential blockade
Adkins as well
so uh we started to of course uh started
some of the planning around that
we engaged with our ccmg staff
identified the organizers of the uh of
the Convoy and engaged in open
Communications with them over the course
of the days leading up to the 29th we
had several meetings engaging partner
agencies
including the Alberta Sheriff's uh
Canada Border Services
also with our U.S Partners in the U.S
CBP uh Customs and Border Patrol
entities there as well some of the
information indicated that there was
going to be a number of trucks up to a
thousand trucks on the United States on
the USA side coming to the Port of Entry
so we had it like I mentioned we had
engaged our U.S Partners there as well
we prepared to uh employ some resources
to Coots for the 29th as well but we had
activated our gold silver command
structure as well we had activated our
division Emergency Operations Center
because there were other planned
protests or convoys in the province of
Alberta scheduled for January 29th as
well we consulted with legal counsel
around our authorities our authorities
to to stop Vehicles just to to confirm
that as well too so we took a number of
steps in preparation for the possibility
of a blockade now I'll go back to our
engagement with with the protest
organizers and the last information the
best information that we had leading up
to the 29th and it was from the protest
organizers was that they were no longer
going to blockade at Coots but they were
simply well not not simply but they were
going to conduct slow roles
uh through to Coots with the Convoy and
uh we were advised that it was their
intention to do three slow rolls two
Coots uh back to Milk River uh the
community of Milk River which is also on
uh Highway four uh north of Coots and
that they would conduct three slow rolls
through this area ensuring that they had
maintained the uh at least one lane open
at all times while they were conducting
these slow rolls
um at the time you were performing all
of these uh Preparatory uh measures and
analyzing the intelligence did did you
or the people who were doing the
intelligence analysts uh for you form a
view about whether the people who were
planning the slow rolls as it was
initially uh envisaged whether they were
associated with or aligned with the
other Convoy events that were emerging
then coming
um all the way from Vancouver towards
Ottawa and from other locations uh ended
up being various other ports of entry
and ultimately Ottawa
I think it was reasonable to conclude
that this slow roll was Associated to
perhaps the larger Convoy that was
traveling uh west east across uh you
know across the Prairie Provinces and
into uh into Ontario okay
I'm going to try to do this without a
map but uh you mentioned Highway 4 and
and uh would it be fair to say that that
the Coots border crossing is a
particular place on the Canada U.S
border that one can drive up to and
there's a cbsa
the Border point there uh
but that the slow rolls wouldn't just be
at the border point I mean I think this
was one of the things you've described
in other parts of your evidence that the
whole highway was vulnerable to whatever
activity the whole highway down to the
Border point was vulnerable to whatever
activity uh that that the slow rolls
would engage in maybe you could just
describe the geography for for us on how
what a challenge that presented to you
from a policing point of view sure
um you know as as you've alluded to
um the slow rules wouldn't go right to
the Port of Entry uh and it would be if
they were going north to south they
would come to the U.S uh Port of Entry
uh as they traveled southbound but there
was a turnaround in advance of that and
that that Convoy would utilize that
turnaround between the two uh it would
be uh between the two southbound and the
two Northbound lanes and then be able to
do uh Loops back to Milk River if they
saw desired the general
geography there it's very flat and open
and I'll say you know through the
ditches and Fields they're very
accessible
if one was or had a desire to to move
off the roadway and to travel uh through
the ditches or intermediates or into the
adjacent Fields as well okay while
you're on that point I'll mention it
because it becomes relevant to the
developments later on but what I was
describing was was that you you didn't
just have a particular border point to
be concerned about that anywhere along
the road accessing that border Point
could effectively block the Border point
but another point you just mentioned is
that in terms of controlling that
roadway it there were certainly some
Vehicles such as Farm Vehicles which
could go around any policing effort you
might undertake on the highway did I get
that right yeah that's correct and you
know I might
you know allude to you know a situation
where this Convoy could stop anywhere on
the road and effectively block the
highway at any point whether it was you
know just uh south of Lethbridge the
City of Lethbridge or if it was you know
closer to the the Port of Entry uh it
would be very challenging uh at that
point to deal with with that situation
now maybe it could take us to the day
that the blockade actually materialized
and how how the
uh K division uh forces dealt with that
how the blockade
materialized and
how the police reacted to that yeah so
the Convoy was in the process of of
doing their slow roles when I'll say
suddenly one of the semi-trailer tractor
units jackknifed itself on the roadway
effectively blocking uh travel in in
both directions and bringing the Convoy
to uh to a halt at that point so
effectively
um you know I would say at that point uh
creating an offense in the context of uh
provincial or criminal code statutes
did you uh Deputy Commissioner or the
the people working uh in in K division
on this on the reaction to this uh slow
role which ended up becoming a blockade
uh did you form a view about whether
that uh
particular truck that formed that
jackknifed itself and blocked the road
or others who followed the same uh
pattern
was that that as you and your forces
perceived it the intention of everybody
on the slow roll or was that the actions
of some smaller part of the of the Slow
Rolling trucks I I believe it was the
actions of uh a certain segment or
portion uh of a group as I had mentioned
earlier the organizers that wasn't their
intention uh to blockade uh and we later
you know learned that they had lost that
control and as we saw over the course of
of uh the next few days a splinter group
uh Splinter leadership group developed
from the larger protest group and we
know as well that there were a number of
individuals that were caught up in that
blockade uh that did not have the desire
to uh to be part of part of that
blockade
did you mean they got trapped you know
that's exactly right uh you know was in
the next uh couple days following that
uh uh well specifically on January 30th
we were able to assist a group of about
uh 30 or so uh semi-trailer units they
had uh cleared Canada Customs coming
coming uh North into Canada they were on
the Canadian side of the border at that
point but had been blocked by the Convoy
and uh had nowhere to go so we worked
with them uh with uh Canada with cbsa
and uscbp uh to uh allow them to to turn
around move back through the us and come
back into Canada and another location so
they had no desire to be part of that uh
part of that blockade uh at all and then
the following day the 31st there was a
another group of individuals uh of uh
folks that were I'll say caught up in
that blockade
that were were released and were able to
uh to uh to move on from uh from the
blockade
now you described fairly extensive uh
uh
planning and preparation and
anticipation that is Advanced knowledge
and consequent planning and preparation
and anticipation of the slow roll
uh and yet uh we've heard that uh it's
it's in the uh evidence of the mayor of
Coots that that he thought that that the
icmp were caught off guard
by the blockade where you caught off
guard by the protest in the slow roll or
by it having turned into a blockade by
this jackknife that you described
so we we knew there was at the very
least going to be a slow roll through
Coots however uh we were also planning
for uh you know potentially a blockade
as well
we had as I mentioned earlier we had
deployed resources to that immediate
area we did we didn't deploy resources
in a quantity that would allow us to uh
you know take any necessary enforcement
action in the context of arrests and
such at that particular time so we
needed the 30th and the 31st of of
January to deploy further resources into
the area to bring up our our resource
numbers to ensure that if in fact you
know if in fact it was necessary to take
enforcement action that uh you know we
have sufficient resources to uh you know
do our best to ensure Republican and and
police officers safety at that
particular time
you know I think one can say that in a
situation like this where you have the
the number of participants that were
that were present and the number of
vehicles that were present uh the best
way to resolve that type of a situation
is is trying to gain voluntary
compliance to move people along right
those are difficult situations to manage
uh in in that context and during those
first few days that you described the
28th 29th 30th while you were trying to
Marshal your forces in case uh
enforcement action was necessary was
your ccmg group in trying to deal with
the protesters they they were right they
were and uh they were challenged though
in those first couple days uh attempting
to identify a leadership group within uh
within the larger protest group and
um it seemed like no one wanted to uh to
step forward to identify fight
themselves as Leaders or or such so it
was I would say it was quite quiet is
the way it was described to me uh as far
as any interaction or or even the
potential to find individuals to
interact uh with us that that might be
uh part of a leadership
um or playing a leadership role in the
protest
um now taking us we've gone to 28th 29th
30th and
what do I understand correctly that part
of the forces you marshaled in
anticipation of potential enforcement
action was to get some heavy lift towing
capacity
arranged in case it was needed right
that was part of our objective and part
of our operational plan uh when we
weren't getting a response in in the
context of Engagement with our our ccmg
we recognized you know the the potential
that we might have to take enforcement
action uh in that situation so we we did
a range for uh towing capacity and of
course this is heavy duty towing
capacity to move these large tractor
trailer units from the roadway that were
blocking the roadway and we got
cooperation to do that in fact we were
able to Marshal some tow trucks I
believe it was on the 31st uh and have
them uh in place as it turned out in
31st later in the day we got the
engagement from individuals uh within
the protest group and started some
communication and actually some
negotiation at that particular point so
uh we held off on any enforcement action
at that particular time and held off
until later in the day unfortunately
later in the day those negotiations I'll
say negotiations
fell off and uh
uh given that time of the day we weren't
able to initiate
any action with the with the uh tow
trucks at that particular time
our communication with the tow truck
operators and the companies was such
that they indicated they would be back
the next morning and uh as such it was
the next morning that we planned to
deploy resources uh into the protest
group and uh of course first seek
compliance for uh The Operators of the
vehicles to move along and of course if
if they did not volunteer or comply with
that we were preparing to make arrests
and with the arrests you know uh
ensuring that we had the towing capacity
to to necessarily remove the trucks from
the roadway
and and
uh
do you know why that the towing capacity
uh wasn't there after your by the end of
the day of the 31st we understood that
uh two companies two operators uh were
receiving phone calls there was a
barrage of online negative uh commentary
uh to uh towing companies and and
operators as well around their potential
participation and assistance of the of
the police in the situation so
um there was a lot of that surfacing and
uh of course you know
um that was a significant factor in in
towing companies and operators deciding
not to assist the police the following
morning
and throughout uh
the rest of the remainder of the event
at Coos did you ever manage to regain uh
commercial Towing uh contracts or
commitments
from either those companies or others at
Coots uh no we did not no uh that never
that never came to be uh and I would say
our folks made significant efforts to
obtain that uh that requisite to
incapacity uh we can't have a swing
companies across Alberta Saskatchewan
and British Columbia we even reached
into uh into the United States into
Montana and campus towing companies
there uh for their uh interests in
assisting us uh at Coots and uh I would
say for various reasons uh we were
turned down and found no cooperation
in that in that context
I'm just gonna
take a slight digression uh Deputy
Commissioner and talk about a topic that
uh that I saw pass by as you were
describing the geography and the
scenario and and I'm going to begin I'm
going to talk about the efforts that K
division undertook
to uh see if you could get the
protesters to relocate uh or uh uh
otherwise carry on their protest in a
way that wouldn't uh well block traffic
or put another way be illegal and I'm
going to begin that with a quotation you
might recognize this is uh Chief
superintendent dahu who's here uh you'll
know as the officer in command of the
Southern Alberta district and and this
is the quotation from him that I'll put
you and then ask you to comment on okay
our first
and typically most effective approach in
moving a protest protest into a lawful
state is communication
at Coots we engaged our community
Conflict Management Group to move the
protest back to a lawful state
and that's the end of the quotation
right I just want to ask you about that
concept of uh the the that the that is
as uh
uh Chief superintendent daru put it uh
the step number one when confronting uh
a protest that has become unlawful is to
see if you can find a way to make it
lawful again have I caught his thought
correctly yeah I believe I believe you
have yes and and uh what types of steps
were you hoping to take or that the
people working in K division to see if
that could be done with respect to the
protest at Coots yeah well one of the
primary things that we attempted to do
was create a lawful protest site so
again we wanted to move uh the unlawful
protest from the Port of Entry area
further up the highway when I say up the
Highway North uh towards Milk River
or quite frankly away from the immediate
Port area
and so we did a number of things to try
and accomplish that we created what we
call the community stakeholder
engagement team so we assigned two
senior police officers to uh to engage
with uh with the community leaders in
the area so the community leaders from
Coots and Milk River and and uh and the
municipalities uh to work with them to
to help us find potentially find an area
that would be suitable
to create as a lawful protest area
um we were cognizant that you know the
protesters to get them to uh to move to
such an area that you know this would
have to be an area of visibility so
somewhere along the highway potentially
is is was one of the one of the
requirements that we we certainly had in
mind as our folks undertook this work
and uh and we needed to have an area
that was uh convenient that was
accessible and and as I mentioned uh
visible so
um we uh commenced that work it would
have been during the second week of the
uh of the protest uh situation there and
um and then I want you to I'm just going
to interrupt you there but please sure
about sequence because because I do want
you to continue on with how you
attempted to Define that but just if I
can explore that thought that you were
describing before about trying to
balance the interests of the protesters
uh and the interests of the law
enforcement uh but it's present
I think you're describing a the
attention where the the protesters want
visibility perhaps they even want to be
a nuisance or or uh cause people to to
pay attention to them do something to
attract attention
and yet you want to make sure they you
want them to be able to do that much
correct
right we want them we want them to still
be able to protest but in a lawful
manner right right and of course that
would include you know uh them leaving
leaving the poor debt area and and
moving elsewhere
and and and so so there's this tension
between you wanting to make sure things
are legal and not too disruptive and the
protesters wanting to be somewhat
disruptive so that they're getting uh
attention and so one thing you described
is is moving them to an area where
they're not obstructing as much traffic
and yet still have the visibility
they're looking for so they can make
their point right and is that also the
the uh
the thinking behind approaches such as
opening one lane or letting so many cars
through an hour in other words so that
they're having some disruptive effect
but not to the point where you would
call it an illegal disruption
well you know opening one lane I would
suggest would still be an illegal
disruption
that Port Entry but uh I suppose that
it's a bit of a consolation but our
objective was to open the entirety of
right access through the highways right
right and part of your your uh ccmg
group would be having these discussions
with the protesters to come up with some
uh
give or concession that allows them to
have a highly visible and uh
highly visible protest appropriate to
their objective and yet
ideally not be illegal and and to be as
to not to be as uh to allow things to be
going to go ahead without as as much
disruption as possible is that fair
that's fair now
so now there I interrupted you on that
point of the the objective and you were
about to describe how how your folks
attempted to accomplish that by
relocating the uh the protest at Coots
right we engaged uh I'll say the protest
leadership uh early in in that week and
again this is the second week of the uh
of the blockade and there initially
there seemed to be some interest uh from
the protest leaders uh in that
uh so we continued our work with uh
identifying a proper location where we
were able to work with uh the government
of Alberta actually had a uh a small
parcel of land adjacent to Milk River I
was alongside Highway four so that
visibility component would have uh been
met there as well too so
um
the the Municipal Affairs Branch within
Albert Transportation Branch within the
Alberta Government uh worked with with
us and created a a site there for for a
lawful protest
okay and how did that did that succeed
in in solving the problem at Coots uh in
the end it did not uh the interest uh
definitely waned and the feedback we
received later that week from the
protest leadership indicated that they
were no longer interested in in moving
to that lawful uh protest site did they
say why I don't believe they did
did you did you form a view of it
talking again about our balance did they
not consider that that lawful protest
site would give them the visibility and
the disruption they wanted to make their
point you know that was that was I
suppose that was uh potential I I don't
know that we had enough information to
really form a view other that they
didn't want to
um they didn't perhaps see value in
moving in they thought their position
might be stronger by staying at the Port
of Entry
and at some point I understand uh
well for some period for the first week
or so I understand that you were
attempting to minimize enforcement in
the terms of uh traffic tickets rather
highway traffic act defenses is that
correct
right so the first week
um yeah we weren't we didn't move out uh
strong or heavy on on traffic
enforcement we wanted to ensure that you
know uh well quite frankly it wasn't
until checkpoint 10 uh was created that
we started to have concerns around
traffic
um not traffic flow but just you know
the haphazard parking of vehicles and
I'll describe checkpoint 10. it's a it's
a location again on Highway four uh it's
uh between the Port of Entry and uh and
Milk River and it's at the intersection
of Highway 501 and it was a location
that earlier on in the blockade we had
we created a checkpoint there uh to uh
try and regulate the flow of traffic
down to the Port of Entry
and uh of course we wanted to allow
Community residents and legitimate
traffic to Coots to travel through there
but we also wanted to negate the flow of
of protesters to the protest site as
well too via vehicle so we created this
uh this checkpoint and over time
this checkpoint you know it almost
turned into another blockade location
for the protesters as they gathered
there as they formed there in fact they
eventually brought farm equipment and uh
and from time to time would put it
across the roadway effectively blocking
access through uh through checkpoint 10.
and um so that it was as a result of
some of the safety concerns around
checkpoint 10 that we started to become
a little stronger on our our traffic
enforcement under the traffic safety act
and and did you perceive any uh
beneficial impact of that enforcement
from your point of view
did it have the effect you were hoping
it would have well it didn't it didn't
help resolve the blockades which of
course uh you know was the primary or
one of the primary objectives
um I'm not I'm not sure what that
traffic enforcement you know exactly
what that effect had uh I don't think it
was significant right
um
now as this as these events are
unfolding as you've described the
attempt to set up the lawful protests on
the attempt to establish checkpoint 10
and its Evolution have you yet started
to bring in resources from either within
the province of Alberta down towards
Coots or from e-division in British
Columbia over to
to Coots we brought resources down to
Coots
um well and initially in preparing for
the slow rolls and and the potential of
a blockade we brought some resources at
that point we furthered that that same
weekend and brought additional RCP
resources and across the province uh two
Coots and then later in the week uh I
believe was the uh third of uh February
uh we made a request to activate or
initiate article 9 under the Provincial
Police service agreement to bring in
resources from British Columbia
so our folks have been on the ground uh
for for almost a week solid there day
shifts and night shifts and and uh and
such there too so we were looking to uh
provide some relief uh for our folks
that were working uh on the protest and
can you describe uh
do you need to engage any of the
provisions of of the agreements you have
with municipalities in Alberta or other
segments of Alberta to move those uh
resources down to Coots or as long as
it's within Alberta do you have the
unilateral ability to move from around
right there's no direct mechanism within
the contracts uh with the municipalities
for that the provincial contract is
overarching and allows us to do that and
to do that with the municipalities
and can you tell me how the contractual
I'm not going to ask you to be a
contracts lawyer but just as from an
operational point of view how it works
as between when you seek resources from
another province
so when and and we're able to do that
under the Provincial Police service
agreement and in Alberta quite frankly
we've we've done it a number of times uh
you know obviously uh in Coots with uh
obtaining resources from British
Columbia we did it this past summer as
well uh for the people visit which was a
significant lift for for uh policing
services within Alberta as well and and
we've also done it for not natural
disasters where we needed additional
resources to support our policing
efforts as well too so that request goes
out through uh the commissioner will
will send a letter to ministers and uh
and Advising that uh in our case Alberta
uh would be seeking additional resources
under article line of the Provincial
Police Services agreements
and when the commissioner sends out that
letter is is she it will use K Division
and E division here and and the
commissioner wants resources to go from
e-division to K division
and she writes to the Ministers of the
respective provinces telling right uh
them of her intention is she asking
permission to do this or is she invoking
a right that the RCMP has under those
agreements with the provinces it's it's
it's more the latter yeah right uh and
uh and the commissioner has the
authority to draw up to 10 of of
resources from a province uh to it to
assist in in other RCMP jurisdictions
for uh under the under the contract
deemed uh emergency or extraordinary
circumstances or events and have there
been occasions when the Commissioners
asked that resources go from K division
over to e division
specifically to e-division I I believe
so I believe we may have
uh accomplished that with some of the
protests recently in British Columbia if
I recall I know we sent resources I
don't know if we sent resources in a
significant quantity right to trigger uh
article 9 in the contracts but I know we
we assisted with the resources in
British Columbia right
and when you get resources from
e-division to come and work with Unk
division they are
basically the same they are RCMP
officers wearing RCMP uniforms who've
been trained with the same equipment and
went through the same College Etc is
that right that that's correct and and
that's uh I'll say there's significant
value in that being able to bring
resources from other Province who who uh
have the the same training uh and use
the same type of equipment and you'll
you can see most seamlessly insert them
into your operations right
now
on February 3rd you might recollect this
we can call it up if it's uh necessary
but you might remember writing to
minister Savage in Alberta uh uh
and in that letter you made this
statement that the situation at Coots
does in my opinion constitute an
emergency in the province of Alberta do
you remember saying that I do and when
you said that uh well obviously you
viewed the situation as an emergency
were you were you making reference to
Alberta's uh
emergency legislation or anything else
in particular that prompted you to use
that expression or was that just a
characterization of what you were facing
the reference I was making using the
word emergency what's to the provincial
policing contract so emergency is
defined within the uh Provincial Police
Services agreement and is defined as an
emergency in the context of a policing
situation uh where additional resources
are need to deal with an event or a
developing or uh present situation right
so this is different than the
commissioner giving notice to British
Columbia that you're going to borrow
some of their resources here you're
giving notice
uh
I would say your emergency would have
the same meaning in that context yes it
would sign up thank you yes
um can you tell me about your efforts to
obtain uh uh Towing assistance from the
from the Canadian Armed Forces
certainly
um so it was February 4th uh when I
signed a request for assistance
uh which is a form that we have uh
to complete when we're desirous of uh
support or assistance from the Canadian
Armed Forces so uh that request was
forwarded uh through uh to our national
headquarters and
um I didn't hear immediately the results
of that request it was a number of days
later when I learned that the request
that there had been uh inquiries
made with the Canadian Armed Forces at
our national headquarters level and that
the Canadian Armed Forces did not have
the equipment that would uh be suitable
uh or of assistance to our situation at
Coots and and was your effort to obtain
Towing assistance with Canadian Armed
Forces equipment a wholly independent
from the uh request by the province of
Alberta to
Ottawa to obtain assistance from the
Canadian Armed Forces
so I was aware that the government
government of Alberta were also making a
request through to the Canadian Armed
Forces for similar assistance
in fact I had a conversation uh with
government officials
where you know I I think it was myself
that suggested we both should be putting
the request forward I see so so you each
knew that the other was making the
request and it was basically for the
same end result which was that the Armed
Forces Towing equipment be able to help
out at Coots that's correct
and you both got roughly the same answer
I'm aware of the answer that we as the
rcfp received and right I'm not I'm not
real firm on the answer that the
province received right now uh
are you aware that I our reference for
this is is what Alberta has said in its
institutional report but you you uh
might be aware of it as well uh and I
think you've spoken about it in in your
interview summary that eventually
Alberta acquired I bought some uh the
province Alberta bought some heavy lift
towing capacity are you can you tell us
about that yeah certainly I can so of
course
um
as I mentioned earlier we had made a
number of efforts to locate towing
capacity we were unsuccessful we also
looked uh to see what was available
uh for used or new Towing equipment and
it was in those same early days that
officials from the government of Alberta
made similar efforts again contacting
towing companies to see if they were
available and and quite frankly received
the same same response as as the RCMP
received and uh and however they they
also set out to see what might be
available on the market for towing
equipment and eventually did purchase
used Towing equipment Heavy Duty Towing
equipment to uh to potentially assist I
had codes
and was that ever was that equipment
ever put into service for the purpose of
clearing Coots
it was uh as I mentioned it was acquired
it was moved to Southern Alberta and uh
and staged and uh it was on the 15th of
February where the equipment equipment
was at least some of the equipment was
moved down to the immediate uh Port of
Entry the immediate Coots area but was
it used to move protester vehicles
it was eventually used to move protester
Vehicles not in the context of
disassembling the blockade
um
which happened essentially on the 14th
and and the morning of the 15th of
February it was Mo it was used
subsequent to that I believe later on
the 15th or the 16th to remove two or
three vehicles that had been involved
in an incident
uh the evening of the 13th where a
police vehicle at a checkpoint was uh
nearly struck and was was forced to take
evasive action as a one of these
vehicles that was seized uh came at it
in a in a reckless fashion
oh
was the heavy lift Towing
equipment used to lift heavy vehicles
it was in the context of those two or
three vehicles
um that I just described involved in
that incident involved in the incident
but again after the protest had
disassembled understood thank you
well I want to talk to you about uh the
incidents or incidences or the Continuum
of your concern about Firearms among the
uh
blockade participants at Coots
and if if I Can Begin by putting it this
generally it's our understanding that
you had the art that the RCMP had
concerns about Firearms at Coots as
early as the early days of the protest
that is around February 1st can you
explain how that happened right because
if the protest that is around February
1st can you explain how that happened
right so it came to our attention
uh that an individual
um within the protest group may have had
a firearm uh with him
um and had displayed it within the
protest group
uh we weren't successful in in following
up to obtain any further information
around that so we weren't able to
validate uh I'll say the the report that
we received
that is no one was willing to point a
finger when you went and asked about it
is that what you're saying yeah yes in
essence
um and uh
then around February 9th there was new
information about uh another issue with
firearms and
you're going to want to be cautious and
you've probably thought about this a lot
I should prepare this testimony so we're
not gonna we're gonna try not to ask any
questions that the list answers that
you're reluctant to give but can you
tell us what you can about how that uh
uh what we'll call more serious incident
involving firearms that could first came
to your attention and how it evolved so
it was on the ninth as you as you
alluded to where we when we received
some information about a potential cache
of firearms
at the Port of Entry within the protest
within the protest group
that information came to us
through our ccmg folks and as a result
we
undertook some covert investigational
methods to further
investigate that information which of
course was very concerning to us
and uh and required a very focused
effort and investigation going forward
and uh
I understand you were prepared to take
further investigative steps but that the
uh
the uh events were precipitated uh by an
incident at the protest site can can you
take us through that uh
I'm not sure okay uh could you rephrase
that again please Council yes I I
understand that that you were prompted
your forces were prompted to act on its
concerns and move in and make arrests
and conduct searches uh and that that
was prompted by an incident involving a
a vehicle that uh well it's probably the
incident you were describing earlier the
collision between one of the trucks and
one of your officers Vehicles right at
the near collision and you're correct uh
we we had planned to execute an
operational plan
um the morning of
of the 14th of February in the early
morning hours of the 14th we were
planning to execute an operational plan
in the context of uh the execution of of
search warrants and and potentially
arrests
um as a result of our investigation
around the information that pertained to
to Firearms within the protest group
we were we did execute that plan earlier
uh than we initially anticipated
given the near Collision I'll say with
our police vehicle
We Came Upon as a result of that the
incident We Came Upon some of the
subjects that we were intending to
arrest later
later that morning and uh so for that
reason we made those arrests at that
particular time and uh initiated the the
enforcement action
and and if you can just describe it in
numbers of arrests and charges and uh
Firearms seized can you give us a
description of how the operation
proceeded
so that morning we executed uh uh search
warrants at Smugglers Inn which uh was
the headquarters for the protest group
or certainly the leadership within the
protest group we executed search
warrants at a mobile home and two travel
or Holiday trailers that were adjacent
uh to that particular residence
and uh we uh from the mobile home and
the uh the travel trailers we see just a
number of firearms
um we seized uh I believe was uh 13 long
guns two handguns two sets of body armor
uh machete uh significant quantity of
ammunition as uh as well
we arrested
um
12 individuals during the course of the
execution of that of those search
warrants and later that same day on the
14th we arrested an additional
individual
who who we allege was part of the I'll
say the cell or the group of four who
are today charged with conspiracy to
commit murder on police officers also
charged with mischief and charged with
possession of weapons dangerous to the
public peace
so that 13th individual was arrested
away from the site as they traveled to
the site they were arrested between the
City of Calgary and and the community of
Coots
and it's alleged when they were arrested
that they were this individual was in
possession of of two Firearms at that
time and heading to the uh Coots site
and uh
the the it's probably a long list of
charges associated with that but can you
give us a general description of what
criminal charges came out of this
operation
uh certainly so four individuals who are
charged with conspiracy to commit murder
they were also charged with mischief and
they were charged with uh possession of
of uh weapon dangerous
uh there were additional
I believe uh six individuals that were
uh charged with Mischief as well as
possession of of weapon dangerous
um
that's ten I'm obviously missing
a little bit here
um
yeah I'd have to refresh my memory on on
the others there
um
okay uh I I want to just uh ask a bit
about the relationship between the
people who were involved in this uh in
the Firearms offenses
uh and the rest of the protesters and I
I'm gonna my starting off point for that
uh Deputy Commissioners is to ask it
this way
you there's some information in the
public domain about how you learned
about
these individuals and the Firearms cache
but I'll let you use your words to to
make sure you're comfortable with how
you describe it but the way you told us
earlier was that what that it was your
your
your your liaison group
that first learned or
started the investigative steps with
respect to this Firearms cash and arrest
is that right
I believe I may have said that right so
um and um as as I think about that I
think it was another source of
information that that did come to us and
that was a result of a covert
investigational
uh technique that we had deployed
what I'm what I'm trying to find out is
did you if you if you're allowed to tell
us did you learn about the individuals
who were involved in these firearms from
your interaction with the other
protesters on the site
no we did not okay so it was it was an
investigative effort
through which you you were in effect
penetrated uh enough to get the
intelligence that allowed you to to make
these arrests and these seizures is that
right correct that's right
now
with that said uh can you tell us what
impact at least as you saw it this
incident of the arrests of the
individuals and the seizure of the
Firearms what impact that had on the
other protesters the ones who weren't
involved in the arrests and who weren't
uh charged or otherwise connected in any
way with the investigation that resulted
in the arrests yeah it certainly seemed
to have an impact and and quite frankly
I think what it obviously contributed to
decisions that the protesters made to
distance themselves from that group of
individuals that had been arrested and
charged and uh ultimately uh
dismantle the blockade and move in a
different direction
um
I'll try to get you to expand on that
and so I'm just going to
lead you even more than I have so far uh
you um
you sensed that the rest of the
protesters I'm going to use the word
we're embarrassed by or ashamed by but
wanted to distance themselves from the
people who had the firearms and were
arrested is that the sense you got yeah
that was my sense yes thank you
foreign
do you have anything else you would like
to tell us about how the the matter
wrapped up I mean it came to a pretty
prompt conclusion to put it in a summary
way after the arrests basically the
protesters they wanted to clean up the
site but they did that and then then
left correct yeah I think it's important
uh to say as well that the protest group
or at least the protest leaders wanted
to negotiate uh their uh dispersal from
the blockade and initially proposed and
looked to
um you know potentially address
their legal positions are standing as
far as any potential charges that that
they might be facing into the future so
that was put on the table by uh by the
protest group uh however was not uh not
accepted in in consultation with with
legal counsel and and our policing
services but it was agreed that they
could uh they could stay in the location
for a few more hours to clean it up
before they left so the agreement was
was that so this this uh these
negotiations I'll say happened uh the
afternoon of February 14th
ultimately it was agreed that
the protesters would remove and at that
time it was it was a lot of farm
equipment and tractors that were across
blocking the highways but that they
would remove their uh their equipment
and their and their tractors from the
roadways they would park them alongside
uh in the adjacent Lots or or field and
uh and they would turn the keys over to
the RCMP uh they indicated that they had
an interest to remain overnight for one
more evening that they wanted to uh to
clean up the site including cleaning up
the site the following morning so that
was the arrangement in the agreement
again through negotiation that that was
arrived on uh late afternoon of February
14th
thank you very much Mr commissioner
those are my questions of Deputy
Commissioners blocky and I will hand it
over to the rest of the parties okay
thank you uh first to the Convoy
organizers
uh Council stepped out maybe we should
jump to the government of Alberta
instead
good evening
um Deputy Commissioners blocking my name
is Stephanie Bose I'm counsel for the
province of Alberta much of the
questions I had prepared for you are
have actually already been covered but I
just have a few areas that I'd like to
ask some questions about
um so I understand that in responding to
these protests the RCMP had various
tools at their disposal the criminal
code the traffic safety act and the
critical infrastructure Defense Act is
that correct that's correct yes and I
think you um talked about this a little
bit in your testimony but when you're
dealing with large protests like this
you you can't just go in right off the
bat and start laying a bunch of charges
would you agree with that I would agree
the first step is to try to negotiate
some of um some of the various aspects
of the protest
that's correct
some success at various points
negotiating with the group of protesters
is that correct yes that's correct
there were times when the RCMP could
negotiate the departure of some of the
trucks that were there right
times when the RCMP could negotiate the
opening of various Lanes to and from
Coots Port of Entry
yeah I think that's true I'm not sure
how much influence we had in negotiating
the lanes to be open but we certainly
put an effort forward yes that's correct
and there were times when the RCM people
were able to escort vehicles that were
there
um for the purpose of actually accessing
the support of Entry is that correct
that's correct
and I also understand there was
difficulty though at other times in
negotiating with the group of protesters
that's correct
and is that because there wasn't always
clear leadership with the group of
protesters
that was certainly the case in the early
days uh certainly from you know the 29th
30th 31st uh into that into that week
there was really an absence of of who
the leadership was at that particular
time so uh again we didn't make a lot of
progress uh negotiations obviously in
that that in those early days
did you feel that at some time the
leadership eventually stabilized and
there was a an identifiable group that
you could negotiate with it seemed to
there were certainly individuals that
that came forward to speak with us there
were individuals that came forward and
were speaking to Media as well uh
and conveying their messages and and we
we had a lot of communication with uh
with those individuals yes
okay and very soon into the protest the
RCMP set up various checkpoints
um the most significant one being
checkpoint 10 near Milk River is that
right I would say that what it was the
most significant checkpoint yes
and the purpose of the checkpoint was to
prevent further vehicles from joining
the blockade closer to the Coots Port of
Entry correct
and you felt at that time were
um The Incident Commander felt at that
time that the RCMP had sufficient
authorities to set up those checkpoints
to limit travel to the port of entries
to um only those that were there for a
legitimate purpose is that fair to say
that's very fair to say yes
and eventually this changed from
policing a public order event to a
criminal investigation correct that's
correct
and that changes the approach to
policing the protest
it does but you know I would say you
know potentially even from day one uh
this could have been deemed a criminal a
criminal event as well right the offense
of Mischief blocking interfering uh with
critical infrastructure uh Highway
um you know that that uh that was very
significant and of course I think you're
referring to however the criminal
investigation relation to the firearms
right so so you had to you had to um
conduct a criminal investigation
alongside of policing the public order
event correct
and your testimony today was that you
were prepared to execute search warrants
and make arrests related to the criminal
investigation in the early morning hours
of February 14th
but that those actions actually ended up
occurring earlier because of the
circumstances
that's correct we initiated those
actions before midnight on on Sunday the
13th
so at that point in time were the police
um confident that they had all the tools
they needed to execute those search
warrants make those arrests and deal
with um enforcement related to the
blockade
yes we were confident we had the the
needed authorities
so the authorities related to Lane
charges under the criminal code Or the
critical infrastructure Defense Act the
traffic safety act but also the tools
you needed with respect to heavy towing
capacity
so and the towing capacity came in uh
right at the end of of uh the the
blockade situation of course uh uh I
think I mentioned that tween capability
the heavy duty towing capability was
available on the 14th to 15th of
February
and even if equipment wasn't quite there
yet he knew it was on the way and it had
been secured for the rcmp's use right we
it was brought to Coots on the 15th the
morning of the 50s
do you know when the protesters first
indicated a desire to leave the protest
site
um can you be more specific in uh
context
so we our understanding from the
testimony of Marco van hoogenbos is that
the protesters didn't want
um the Coots protest to be associated
with the criminal element uncovered by
the search warrants and Lane of criminal
charges and you indicated that the
protesters had attempted to negotiate
um their departure and in relation to
any potential criminal charges they
could be facing I'm asking the question
of what at what point in time did the
protesters first indicate to the RCMP
their desire to start to leave the
protest site yeah that time was uh was
approximately mid-afternoon mid to late
afternoon on on February 14th
so uh as you're aware we made the
arrests uh early in the morning hours of
the 13th and 14th and it was later on
the 14th uh that they first indicated uh
and uh and they I think they went back
and forth a bit amongst their group to
make to make their final decision as I
understand it
and did they give you any indication of
what their reasons were for wanting to
leave at that time was it simply because
of the um the uh the criminal
investigation that had been undertaken
that that was my understanding is that
it was uh again they wanted to distance
themselves from uh that criminal uh
aspect that criminal investigation
okay
now all of this happened without the
powers of the um
the power is granted under the
emergencies Act is that correct that's
correct
and I understand that at that time some
of the protesters did transition over to
the legal protest site is that your
understanding as well yeah and that
occurred after uh the blockade uh
dissolved I'll say uh some of the uh
protesters moved to the lawful protest
site primarily protesters from
checkpoint 10 as I understand it not
from the main protest site uh near the
border
okay
you know how long a protesters stayed at
the legal protest site
I believe some stayed for quite a period
of time a number of weeks and and
perhaps Beyond as as well uh maybe maybe
a couple months uh duration some there
were never a large number at that
particular location
but there were some that certainly
seemed
um I'll say some somewhat comfortable or
or steadfast in their desire to stay
and they were there even after the
public order emergency Declaration was
revoked correct that's correct
and after that time with no extra powers
under the emergencies act there were no
further blockades of any of the port of
entries in Alberta is that correct there
were no further blockades at the Port
that's correct all right uh thank you
Deputy Commissioner those are my only
questions today thank you thank you uh
Convoy organizers please
foreign
my name is Brendan Miller and I am legal
counselor of Freedom Corp which
represents the protesters that were just
in Ottawa in January and February I
don't represent uh anyone who is at
Coots okay but I have a few questions
for you sure um if we could please first
bring up and I I know my friend was
trying to avoid investigative privilege
and I I have something to that may
assist and uh deal with that could we
please bring up Poe Dot hrf00008
so sir uh what this is is uh it's a news
article by a CBC journalist Megan Grant
and Rachel Ward and I understand in
September of this year uh they brought
an application and got access to some of
the itos in the matter and what this is
is a summary of what's in those itos and
for the folks at home uh what that means
is an information to obtain it's an
affidavit an application from a police
officer to obtain a search warrant so
I'm wondering if we can just scroll
through this and if you could tell me
I'm not going to have to read it to you
just if the facts in here are accurate
because these are public facts and we
don't need to worry about any form of
issue with privilege
so what I can tell you is that I you
know obviously I think you probably
assume that I haven't read the itos that
I'm not familiar with the facts uh in
the itos
so I'm not sure how much I can assist
okay to your question well maybe if I
can I guess I was going to try just to
avoid having to go through it and I'll
see if uh if this information I put to
you you can agree with
so I understand that for that operation
uh the the undercover operation there
was a wiretap as well as a search
warrant for the raids is that about do
you remember that or you're aware of
that yes right and there was two
um undercover uh officers from the RCMP
uh embedded uh with these individuals
who were eventually arrested is that
fair
um again I'm I'm going to refrain from
getting into any of the details uh of
that particular investigation as those
charges are are before the courts right
and I I understand that and this is all
from this article I'm not taking it from
anywhere else
um it's and I can appreciate that it is
a it is a news article right it's it's
not from uh a court document uh itself
so okay my hesitancy I understood uh but
it's it's fair to say that the entire
time with these individuals
uh almost from the get-go the RCMP knew
about them and they were on it is that
fair
I don't believe it's fair that's not my
understanding okay but from early
February is it fair
um prior to their arrest around February
5th uh they were aware of these
individuals and the first one was
arrested in the 13th Mr uh lysac and the
remainder were arrested on the 14th no
we weren't aware of them on on February
5th okay and can you give a date of when
you did become aware of these
individuals as I mentioned earlier we
became aware of potentially the cache of
weapons
on the on the 9th of February 9th of
February all right and according to this
article
um the two undercover officers uh
essentially interacted with these
gentlemen uh in a bar and were able to
gather Intel and that led to the arrest
and the raid on the house is that fair
uh again I'm I'm very hesitant to
comment thank you well that's the this
article just outlines that and I
understand the itos are actually
publicly available so I'll try to get
those for the commission so they just
have a better understanding
um I can probably get them from Alberta
sometime next week if we can bring up uh
pb.nsc dot can dot zero zero zero zero
three zero three nine underscore Rel dot
zero zero zero one
okay have you seen this document before
I I saw this document just very briefly
before I took the stand here this
evening oh okay
um so you're familiar then uh with
respect to this document being a
memorandum I believe from your legal
department in March of 2020 with respect
to uh the emergencies act but it's not
speaking about a public order emergency
uh it's speaking about a Public Welfare
Emergency regarding covid is that fair
uh again I'm not I I wouldn't say I'm
familiar with the document sir I just
had it uh put in front of me okay a
short time ago could we please scroll
down though
and to the second page please
and the third page I apologize
all right and I just want to take you to
the role of the RCMP and my colleague
with the CCF touched on this a bit with
the commissioner but this summarizes it
nicely and given us an internal document
um there at the second point it states
that under section 18a of the RCMP act
in section 141a of the RCMP regulations
RCMP members serving as peace officers
have a duty to enforce the law
and it's speaking to orders invoked
under the emergencies Act
so
is it fair to say that I know you
haven't been overly familiar with this
document but when there was the
invocation of the emergencies Act was it
your understanding that
the RCMP
due to the operation of section 18 of
the act and then of the RCMP act and 14
of the RCMP regulation was compelled uh
as a matter of Duty and law to carry out
enforcing the orders that were passed
under the emergencies Act
I'm not sure that I understand your
question so the purpose that's in there
is that it's explaining that section 18a
of the RCMP act in section 14 uh one a
of the RCMP regulation uh collectively
require the duty to enforce the law and
when the order that is passed under the
invocation is passed that it's at least
implicitly uh that those two sections of
the RCMP Act and the section of the RCMP
Act and the regulation compel the RCMP
to carry out whatever is in those orders
is that fair it seems to suggest that
yes right and with it David fruity for
the government of Canada just a brief
objection of that last question and I
understand that a response has been
given the witnesses testified that he's
not inherently familiar with the
document and the question it was just
asked is to provide his opinion as to
the purpose of certain sections of the
document within a legal opinion
uh and given the testimony we've had I'm
not sure that's
right I understand an entirely proper
question is witness I'm gonna move on uh
he's answered the question so
you've been an RCMP officer pretty much
your whole entire career I take it you
didn't have a second career before what
you're doing
that's correct right and you've you've
worked and you're essentially in the
highest ranks of uh what you can do
within the RCMP subject to becoming a
full-time commissioner like Miss lucky
is that fair correct all right
um
could you opine it all
or give us evidence that when a
regulation or an order is passed by an
executive branch of government
that requires certain things and certain
conditions or puts
restrictions on any area or individual
that due to the operation of section 18a
of the RCMP act in section 141a of the
RCMP regulation that essentially
the passer of that regulation or the
passer of that order
is able to direct what the police are to
do and again sorry I'm just going to
object again these are legal
interpretation questions that are being
asked of the witness and that's
inappropriate in our view I'll rephrase
have you had situations arise where
there is
orders and counsel or regulations
that dictate
whether specifically or whether
implicitly that the RCMP has to do
something with regards to carrying out
that regulation or with regards to
carrying out the ordering Council
foreign
nothing comes to mind at this particular
moment right so it's a very
if there is an order or a regulation
that would compel the RCMP to do
something that would be a very
exceptional thing to interfere uh in the
direction of policing is that fair
you're asking a very hypothetical
question I don't know that I can comment
that's okay thank you very much thank
you
okay next uh the uh democracy fund jccf
good evening Alan Hunter for the
Democracy fund we have a very few short
questions for you I should be out of
here in two minutes
um we've heard evidence
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's an aspiration
that's what I thought so we've heard
evidence about how the province of
Alberta procured its own equipment after
having trouble securing tow trucks
um but before doing that I understand
that the RCMP contacted tow truck
companies from the Western and
Northwestern United States but they all
refused to help is that right correct
correct they refused or some weren't
able to uh there were I'll say various
reasons why they they were not able to
assist and one of the reasons why some
of those tow operators were unable to
assist was because they were
unvaccinated
I'm sorry is that a question yes
and your question is is that correct
yes uh in regard to the operators in the
United States that was some of the
feedback uh we received when we made
some of that contact they were prevented
from coming into Canada because there
was an order in council in place which
prevented unvaccinated people from
coming into the country unless they were
part of an Exempted class does that
sound right to you it could be tow truck
drivers were not part of that Exempted
class as far as you know
I'm I'm not certain okay
um and this border mandate uh sorry this
this
this border mandate that we're talking
about the uh
the vaccine mandate was in fact one of
the animated animating factors behind
the uh Coots protests and other protests
across Canada
it seemed that when uh that was put in
place on January 15th that the activity
in relation to convoys and protests uh
uh increased okay thank you those are my
questions okay
two minutes dead on okay
um
The
Windsor Police Service please
uh good evening Heather Patterson for
the Windsor Police Service I don't think
my camera's working unfortunately
but we have no questions for this
witness so you don't need to see me
well
so thank you
thank you
the city of Windsor
good evening
um Graham reader for the city of Windsor
we have no further questions and we
yield the remainder of our time to the
government of Canada thank you okay next
is national uh police Federation and our
questions were asked by commission
Council and answered so thank you very
much
a government of Canada
good evening Deputy Commissioner donnery
Nygaard for one of the council for the
government of Canada
uh
you spoke to commission Council about
some of the reasons that the tow truck
companies were not uh willing to
cooperate after the first time that they
showed up and then they didn't the
second time right uh and I
I'm not sure if I caught all of the
reasons uh that you indicated but um so
perhaps I could just get you to repeat
this again sure certainly so
um when we
sought that assistance uh after it had
fallen through
um we we learned that some of the
companies were subject subjected to
online harassment uh negative comments
uh they were some were subject to uh
harassing phone calls to their place of
work we also heard that uh in particular
one company had been
uh offered a donation a financial
donation in return for uh withdrawing
their Assistance or not assisting the
police with that situation so there were
a variety of reasons we uh other
responses were no or busy we have other
work we're doing and so on and so forth
so some seemed uh connected uh to Coots
and and others uh now perhaps weren't
and
to your understanding what was
the complaint of what was what was the
group protesting about
uh so I think it it started as a protest
around the uh Public Health measures uh
that uh had been put in place both uh
provincially and and federally and as I
mentioned earlier
um but Convoy aspect of of protests uh
seemed to
uh initiate or or perhaps increase uh
after the January 15th announcement
around international travel restrictions
and did you have any understanding of uh
what they were trying to accomplish with
their protest
I I think they wanted to be heard I
think they wanted the uh the health
measures to be revoked or or removed or
stood down uh it seemed that that was uh
the just through the thrust of of their
concern
and during the protests in Coots on
February 8th the Alberta Government made
an announcement rolling back some of the
mandates correct
uh they made that announcement on
February 8th that's correct and did that
have an impact on the protest
uh well unfortunately it did in the
context of uh uh prior to the eighth uh
there was one lane of traffic in each
Direction open uh through the port
um it was shortly after the announcement
on February 8th that the protesters
blocked that uh that free lane of travel
and uh and communicated to us that they
weren't happy with
with the uh with the announcement
and and just about just to back up for a
moment there was obviously a number of
of Border blockades across the country
the Kutz one was the first correct
correct and and it developed around the
same time that the convoys arrived I
wrote I arrived in Ottawa that's my
understanding yes
and
prior to
um the arrests that occurred on the 14th
and the incident on the 13th that you've
you've described what if any level of of
uh violence or or that kind of behavior
was there at the protest
well there were about six incidents you
know not unlike I I described uh earlier
where we had to take evasive well let
let me be more clear there were
approximately six incidents where uh
large equipment tractors uh
trucks uh uh went through barricades
around barricades uh uh in essence
um
you know breaking the perimeter that we
had set up and I would call it a
perimeter but it was a very loose
perimeter given the geography of the
area and as I mentioned earlier the
ability to travel through medians and
ditches and across Fields so uh but uh
nonetheless uh there were about six
incidents uh that that really concerned
us and and the safety of our of our
police officers at that site
okay
and my friend uh asked you about the
charges that were laid and I'm going to
call up a document it's
pb.nsc.can.408371
and uh this appears to be a briefing
note that was provided for you
is that what this is yes appears to be
uh and if we scroll down
there's an update on the arrests that
are there
and is is that a list at least for the
first 11 people that were arrested of
the charges that were laid uh yes it is
and and you said that there were
additional you I believe you said there
was 13 people in addition can you tell
us what the other two were or
does that list help
there was uh another individual that was
charged under the uh critical
infrastructure Defense Act
as well but not charged in relation to
the uh the criminal investigation within
the within the protest group
and uh I believe one of the individuals
that fled uh went through uh barricade
uh and uh again the incident where our
police officer had to take evasive
action I believe that individual was
charged as well yeah I'm sorry I was
unclear in my question I I thought and
maybe I'm mistaken I thought I had heard
you say earlier that there were 13
individuals charged in relation to the
investigation uh but that some were
charged not on that day later but
perhaps I heard you wrong
I know that that's what I said they were
my understanding is there were there
were 12 uh in relation to the
investigation and then the 13th was uh
later that day wasn't arrested uh on
site
so we've got 11 listed here so we've got
um
two missing is that right appears to be
okay
that's just what I was trying to clarify
okay thank you
um
after
the blockade was resolved after these
arrests and and the protesters entered
into the negotiations and agreed to to
hand over their keys and then clean up
and leave the next day
did you receive any information in the
following days about the possibility of
additional blockades arising
about the possibility of additional
blockades uh threats or not not actual
blockades arising but were you receiving
any in in and perhaps it's easier if I
take you to a document if we can uh call
up
pb.nsc dot can
four zeros four two six eight
foreign
and first can you tell us do you
recognize what this document is
uh it doesn't look familiar to me but
I'm sure I can interpret it okay uh if
we can scroll down towards uh
oh they're up a little bit
um the last bullet point there under
um superintendent to rocks
was that information that was provided
to you as well
so this is subsequent to the dismantling
of the blockade oh yes we can we can go
up to the top and see the date
17 on the 17th Federal 900 okay
I don't know that I was privy to that
information okay okay good
and were you we'll pull up another
document a
pb.nsc DOT can
um
four zeros eight three six two
have you seen this document before
I believe I have if you could scroll to
the bottom that may be helpful
yes I have seen this document
and if we can scroll back up to the top
uh right up to the top
so it talks about in order to keep
protests legal
so is and and then if we could go down
it
uh for a little bit further and then it
quotes from the emergency act and and
the provisions that have to be complied
with and the consequences uh that may be
um occur if they aren't complied with do
you know what this document was used for
my understanding it was used on February
18th as we had uh I'll say stragglers at
checkpoint 10 that were still occupying
uh not blocking the roadway but
occupying aspects of the roadway in the
immediate areas median uh so on and so
forth and they remained at checkpoint 10
even after the dismantling of the main
site to the main blockade at the Port of
Entry and uh as I understand it our uh
our staff our our police officers uh
presented or handed out this document
this pamphlet to uh to those individuals
uh encouraging them to uh to disperse or
or move to the lawful protest site and
do you know if they did
I believe they did I believe they've
actually did yes
and then if we pull up one uh last
document pb.nsc.can.405444
now as as the commission uh indicated
earlier when you were interviewed that a
number of your colleagues were also
there including um the Deputy
Commissioner from BC we don't have them
appearing uh before us here so I'm going
to ask you a question about BC uh this
is uh an email uh that it appears to be
from an RCMP officer or
this one is uh to the RCMP officer but
if we scroll down you can see at the
beginning
it appears to be from her
and then if we can go back up to the
response she receives
and and perhaps I should ask have have
you seen this email before uh no I'm not
familiar with that at all
um
so could I have you read the response
that starts hi Deborah just so you can
familiar yourself familiarize yourself
with what it says
okay and
um it seems to uh indicate that this
individual was providing tow truck
services as a result of being directed
to by the Serie RCMP under the
emergencies Act
uh
what is your understanding of um the
delegation of the commissioner's power
to compel tow trucks within the RCMP was
there was that power delegated to you
for example or to your colleague in BC
as far as you're aware
for certain I can tell you that I
received that delegation from the
commissioner and uh I subsequently uh
made delegations to I believe four of of
my senior officers as well in Alberta
I
I would assume it was also made in the
context of the commanding officer of
British Columbia uh to give him that
ability to
and are they are the concerns expressed
by this um tow truck operator
um who's saying that she's got they're
going to comply but is expressing some
concerns are those similar to the
concerns that you were hearing when you
were attempting to get tow trucks oh
they are as I read here you know this
individual is indicating his office
staff experience abusive behavior and
threats uh and so on and it also appears
that they have a towing contract with
the RCMP or for the RCMP yet at Surrey
but because of that they were reluctant
or unable to to fulfill that thank you
those are all my questions
thank you any uh re-examination
you're not going to want to hear this Mr
commissioner but I have one question
uh Mr clerk could you please call up PB
NSC can
four zeros 8508
and Deputy Commissioner I'm just going
to ask a few questions because I might
be able to uh
show you a document that you're more
willing to talk about than the newspaper
article you are willing to talk about
with my friend Mr Miller
have you got the right document there
it should be an RCMP crimp K division
criminal law now there we go thank you
do you recognize his document Deputy
Commissioner
I believe I do but I wouldn't mind if we
were able to scroll uh
scroll down through it all right thanks
quickly
yes I do recognize it thank you and I
just the the only questions I have about
this is is is to ask you if if first of
all does this document Accord with your
understanding of the uh at least the
publicly available information about the
investigation yes
and the the point uh that I'd like to
draw to your attention is the uh
section under assessment
which reads to date there has been no
information uncovered to suggest that
there is an organized effort between the
individuals charged in Alberta and
individuals involved in the Ottawa
protest do you see that there I do and
that's your understanding of the
assessment of the Criminal
investigation today that is yes thank
you I have no other questions thank you
commissioner
okay well uh thank you very much for
your testimony and for coming and for
being uh resilient although it may be
still Alberta time for you
um which is not for us or for most of us
so uh with that uh you're free to go and
with our thanks thank you
so we'll adjourn until uh tomorrow
morning uh at 9 30 and uh we again
should anticipate long days I hope not
as long as today but uh that I'll try
and be more
uh regimental with the time allocations
but I can't guarantee it
okay thank you very much the commission
is adjourner